allez monsieur Lucas vous pouvez
commommencer par le 189 merci monsieur
le Président ravi de vous retrouver ce
soir pour nos débat et bien nous
proposons de supprimer cet article 19
bis qui s'oppose au durcissement des
critères bref pardon donc notre groupe
s'oppose au durcissement des critères de
réunification familiale prévu à
l'article 19 B C il s'agit là encore
d'une nouvelle attaque contre le droit
au respect de la vie familiale consacrée
par l'article 8 de la CEDH les
dispositions prévues à cet article ne
revêent aucun caractère de nécessité et
viennent encore fragiliser le droit des
personnes étrangère dans notre pays le
suivant n'est pas défendu monsieur porte
vous défendez le 764 défendu le 948
Monsieur
valotac Merci monsieur le Président pour
les raison identique à celle que vient
d'exposer monsieur Lucas nous proposons
la suppression de C article 19 bis C et
par ailleurs supprimer la possibilité de
réunification familiale pour les frères
et sœurs du réfugié et nous considérons
que cette disposition restreint sans
utilité et par pure démagogie même les
les possibilités de réunification
familiale d'où cette suppression madame
Foss on 208 c'est défendu défendu Madame
Dupont merci monsieur le Président la
demande des réunifications familiales
est une des pierres à l'édifice multiple
que constitue l'intégration tout
particulièrement pour des personnes
bénéficiaires de la protection
internationale qui ont donc vocation à
rester sur notre territoire pour un
temps long durcir les conditions d'accès
à cette runification va donc à
l'encontre de mon point de vue d'une
intégration pleine et entière donc cet
article revient et réduit les critères
permettant cette cette réunification
d'où cette proposition de suppression de
l'article monsie le
rapporteur
ça sera défavorable euh sur l'ensemble
de la de la suppression après il y a je
vais proposer des modifications et pour
maintenir par exemple les frattereries
dans dans cet article étant donné que ça
avait été sorti par le Sénat donc on va
border les choses en l'état c'est
défavorable sur vos amendements de
suppression on ne peut pas faire sauter
toute cet article et on pourra reparler
de la réunification sur les 18 mois les
24 mois sans aucun problème mais le
supprimé serait
délétaire je mets au voix qui votre pour
qui votre contre
rejeté le 137 Monsieur
camardine Merci monsieur monsieur le
Président euh cet amendement se fonde
sur le modèle des des avancés obtenues
par le Sénat etant permis de repousser
l'âge des personnes pouvant demander le
regroupement familial de 18 à 24 ans
donc cet amendement propose de redéfinir
à la hausse les critères d'âge des
personnes étrangères pouvant demander la
réification familiale auprès de leurs
épousx ou leur comp cubins et on obtenu
la protection au titre de l'asile en
faisant passer le seuil de cet âge de 18
à 24
ansard n'est pas là Monsieur le qui
défend le rassemblement national 320
défendu monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur
allez-y défavorable je mets au voix qui
pour l'amendement de Monsieur pog contre
rejeté l'amendement 320 du rassemblement
national qui pour contre
rejeté le diilipo n'est pas défendu
Leard non plus le
293 monsieur gilet défendu monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable je mets au voix
qui vre pour qui vote contre
rejeté monsieur le rapporteur c'est
votre amendement qui suit
alors comme je l'ai dit il y a quelques
secondes c'est un enjeu de cohérence
pour la majorité de maintenir cette
cette préservation des des frateries
d'ailleurs chose que nous avions intégré
nousmêmes dans la loi d colon de 2018
très concrètement cette limitation
placerait les parents d'un mineur
réfugié dans une situation intenable
dans laquelle il aurait à choisir entre
leurs enfants mineurs les uns étant
réfugiés et les autres contraints de
rester dans leur pays d'origine et pour
nous ça paraît totalement inadapté et
nous donc nous proposons de réécrire
cette partie imposée par le Sénat
alors pour la commission des
Affaires
étrangère ben il y a personne pas
défendu
monsieur monsieur Mandon le
1347 oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement comme le vient de
l'indiquer le rapporteur nous sommes
nous élevons contre une mesure qui qui
n'aurait finalement pas de sens et qui
est très illogique par cette limitation
et c'est pourquoi nous également enfin
notre groupe a souhaité déposer cet
amendement de suppression monsieur le
rapporteur
favorable bien entendu je mets au voix
Quiot pour qui qui pour du rapporteur
pour qui vot
contre il est adopté alors est-ce qu'il
fait
juste le 467 madame jeunevard oui merci
monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement du président
Coti qui propose en complément et
renforcement de ces mesures de retenir
s'agissant de la réunification familiale
de la la date à laquelle l'autorité
compétente se prononce pour apprécier
l'âge des enfants
impliqués monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable et en fait vous
créz les délais dans lesquels les
autorités diplomatiques et consulaires
se prononcent estt en variable dans
différents pays il y aurait une rupture
d'égalité madame jeunevard donc
défavorable madame
tourgia merci donc monsieur le
rapporteur vous parlez de rupture
d'égalité moi je voudrais aller plus
loin je je demande pourquoi dans cet
amendement les républicains n'ont pas
rajouté la phrase qu'ils affectionne
concernant les ressortissantsalgérien à
faire une rupture d'égalité allez-y à
fond et d'ailleurs ouais pourquoi vous
rajoutez pas ça viment je ne comprends
pas je le mets au voix alors Monsieur
Camard à ma collègue qu'elle peut elle
ne peut pas nous faire des injonctions
de rajouter de ne pas rajouter si si ça
l'intéresse elle peut elle-même le
rajouter le retirer c'est tout donc
c'est pas la peine de nous de nous
enjoindre de faire ce que vousmême
pouvez le faire
faitesle je mets au voix qui pour qui
vere contre rejeter le
135 le 135 ça l'intéresse pas monsieur
camardine monur camardine le
135 alors écoutez le 135 monsieur
camardine le 135 monsieur le Président
c'est excellent cet amendement de notre
excellent collègue monsieur poet euh est
justifié par le fait que l'étranger
protégé auut de l'asile qui demande la
réunification familiale en France n'a
pas obligation d'être en situation
régulière ou d'avoir des revenus ou un
logement pour accueillir sa famille
l'absence des critères minimaux pour la
réunification de familles de personnes
quiant obtenu l'asile font exploser le
flux migratoire et qu' condamne ces
familles à une extrême pauvreté aussi
c'est c'est pris sur le modèle de
dispositif qui a été approuvé du
regroupement familial pour les personnes
disposant d'un titre de séjour que cet
amendement propose d'imposer des
critères de régularité de séjour de
ressources de logement aux étrangers
protégés au titre de l'asile qui demande
la réunification familiale Mons le
rapporteur c'est le numéro le c'est le
135 merci monsieur le Président
défavorable vous voulez aligner la
réunification familiale avec avec le
regroupement familial ce sont deux
procédés totalement différents et il
faut respecter ça là en l'état on ne
peut pas confondre réunion FAM
réunification familiale avec
regroupement familial monsieur camardine
donc
défavorable alors Monsieur monsieur car
pardon
merci monsieur le Président bon on voit
une certaine obsession depuis le début
de ce projet de loi la part de nos
collègues des républicains sur la
conditionnalité réduire en fait la
possibilité à tous les étrangers quelle
que soit leur situation de pouvoir
accéder au pays en réalité donc c'est
bien une démarche qui est xénopobe
profondément xénophobe pens la forance
comme une forteresse assiégée l'asile ne
se base pas sur une série de critères
mais sur une nécessité de protection
c'est l'accord international issu de la
conférence de Genève il faut quand même
repartir du droit si vous voulez revenir
en plus de revenir sur l'accord de 68 la
Convention européenne si vous voulez
aussi ressortir de notre Constitution
allez-y jusqu'au bout revoyez la
Convention de Genève revoyez la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme de 89
allez-y sortez intégralement de la
République de toute façon les
républicains n'ont que de républicains
le nom alors je mets au voix
l'amendement 135 qui vote pour qui vote
contre
705 n'est pas défendu
l'article on finit là dans le calme
l'article 19 B qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté
l'article 19
bis amendement de madame Martin
alors est toujours sur la question de de
de
l'exercice des conditions qui vont
permettre
effectivement de prendre en compte le
l'organisation de de l'asile en tant que
tel de
l'instruction de l'instruction des de
ceux qui effectivement demandent
demandent protection et de ce point de
vue là il il nous apparaît que ce se
bien à ceux de de
qui doivent être en capacité donc de
mettre en œuvre ces conditions
matérielles qui sont un peu la première
étape si je puis dire donc de la demande
d'asile après après ou en même temps que
le passage en
Guda monsieur rapporteur monsieur
l'endement
suivant
cignacum votre micro parce qu'on vous
l'avit pas rendu merci monsieur le
président l'appréciation au cas par cas
de l'administration est quand même utile
et en l'occurrence cet article 19 bis il
estend les les cas dans lesquel l'OFI
est tenu et je dis bien tenu de retirer
ou de suspendre le bénéfice des
conditions matérielles d'accueil
considère que ce sont des des
disposition coupré et que l'OFI n'est
pas particulièrement clémente déjà dans
ses décisions qui n'est pas utile
évidemment de renforcer ce qui finirait
par confiner au harcèlement des
étrangers alors
monsieur Mandon vous êtes signataire du
non madame fossillon
1009 merci on on est là vraiment dans
une ligne directri une ligne directrice
pardon qui est une logique punitive et
est totalement disproportionné et qui
vise toujours à s'attaquer en réalité au
aux personnes les plus vulnérables et
au-delà du fait quelque part de de la
cruauté de ce type de mesur très
clairement en fait on plonge un peu plus
des gens à chaque fois dans des
situations de très grand vulnérabilité
et je veux dire il y a un moment pour
notre cohésion
sociale ce type d'automatisme en réalité
place tout le monde dans de grandes
difficultés donc il faut cesser ça à la
fois au nom je dirais de simplement
notre humanité mais aussi en terme de de
cohésion sociale et j'espère que
beaucoup de députés l'ont à cœur
ici le suivant monsieur le Président
merci effectivement notre groupe ten
souligné qu'on était pas favorable à à
ce principe d'automaticité qu'on
considère d'ailleurs comme étant un
problème même sur le plan conventionnel
et c'est pourquoi nous en revenons à une
suppression de
l'article monsieur
Lucas madame rol 6,80 € on parle ici en
moyenne de 6,80 € dont les demandeurs
d'asile disposent par jour pour vivre ou
plutôt essayer de survivre les CMA
doivent leur permettre de subvenir à
leurs besoins essentiels et et la
directive européenne accueil prévoit que
l'État peut limiter au retirer
totalement les CMA dans des cas
exceptionnels et dement justifiés alors
les dispositions du droit français en
l'état ne sont déjà pas conformes au
droit de l'Union européenne C cet
article s'inscrit en contresens total de
la démarche à suivre pour se rapprocher
du droit de l'Union européenne en
systématisant le retrait ou le refus des
CMA dans les cas mentionné aux articles
suscités du cza aujourd'hui l'OFI peut
décider du rrait ou du refus des CMA
dans ces situations mais ce dernier est
loin d'être systématique en plus de
précariser toujours plus la situation
des demandeurs d'asile cette mesure est
totalement contre-productive en privant
les demandeurs de moyens de subsistance
et d'hébergement du dispositif national
d'accueil ce sont les dispositifs
d'hébergement d'urgence du droit commun
que l'on sature toujours plus il faut
donc supprimer cet article monsieur le
rapporteur je seraiis défavorable à ces
amendements alors mais mais je dois
reconnaître que je considère comme vous
que la suspension et le refus des
conditions matérieles d'accueil doivent
tenir compte au cas par cas de la
situation des demandeurs et de leur
vulnérabilité c'est pourquoi j'ai déposé
un amendement le cl 14 12 non mais je
vous l'explique quand même madame
Rousseau on n'est pas obligé de tout
supprimer c'est voilà ce que j'essaie de
vous expliquer on peut le réécrire et en
fait dans dans cet amendement on exige
que ce retrait ou ce refuse soit
effectué dans le respect de l'article 20
de la directive asile du 26 juin 2013
l'article en question précise que les
étatsmembres peuvent limiter ou dans des
cas exceptionnels et dum justifiés
retirer les conditions matérielles
d'accueil en examinant au cas par cas la
situation individuelle du demandeur donc
on tempère très très très fortement ce
qui avait été écrit par le Sénat
logiquement vous devriez pouvoir suivre
cette proposition donc
défavorable monsieur madame Martin
non
simplement pour décrypter un peu
l'intention des sénateurs moi ce que je
je trouve gênant dans l'ajout de cet
article c'est qu'après avoir cousu cette
loi de l'idée selon
laquelle les les exilés voulaient
profiter du du système français là on a
maintenant un autre angle qui dirait
institutionnellement nous serions trop
généreux alors qu'évidemment ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas le cas sur l'amendement
monsieur Mendes que vous propos vous
nous permettrez de prendre le temps de
regarder le cadrage oui oui oui
mais d'accord mais vous nous permettrez
d'avoir le temps de regarder si le
cadrage que vous proposez correspond à
ce à quoi on est susceptible
d'aspirer monsieur de la porte non c'est
pas merci monsieur le Président juste
une petite question monsieur le
rapporteur depuis quand faut-il préciser
dans les textes qu'il faut respecter le
droit européen en fait votre amendement
il modifie rien du tout il modifie rien
du tout il change rien au texte initial
donc les raisons qui font qu'on veut
supprimer n'ont pas bougé après votre
amendement puisque finalement euh ça
s'imposerait même euh la version
initiale du 19 bis adopté donc voilà
vous voulez enfumer les députés ici
présents ou alors je me trompe tuux oui
oui répondez allez-y mon Président je
oui oui monsieur rapporteur alors
excusez-moi monsieur de la porte mais
j'essaie d'en fumer personne je vous je
vous je vous ai euh je vous expliquer
pourquoi j'étais contre la suppression
je vous expliqué ce que je pouvais faire
je vous laisse regarder la directive
peut-être que vous comprendrez que
justement on va plutôt dans votre sens
malgré ce que vous nous faites croire il
y a je cherche en fumer personne en
papoué personne on est là pour débattre
échanger et argumenter la réalité c'est
que quand on regarde cette directive
européenne on devrait aspirer à
l'argumentation que vous nous avez
apporté sur l'article de suppression en
l'état le supprimer serait une erreur
mais on est d'accord pour dire que en
l'état on ne peut pas accepter cet
article tel qu'il est rédigé donc je
vous ai proposé une nouvelle rédaction
vous pas vous n'êtes pas obligé de
l'accepter vous pouvez être contre cette
rédaction vous pouvez toujours vouloir
simplement supprimer cet article mais je
pense que la démocratie ne fonctionne
pas que comme ça et qu'on doit aussi
trouver un accord à un moment ou un
autre et faire en sorte que ce texte
soit adapté équilibré qu'on apporte les
bonnes réponses et on le cadre sur la
vulnérabilité on respecte le cas par cas
ce qui n'était pas le cas sur la action
du Sénat donc je vous laisse regarder ce
que dit la directive européenne de 2013
et vous verrez que vous serez
normalement totalement satisfait et
qu'il y a aucun enfumage et s'il vous
plaît je me permets juste ça évitez de
dire que les rapporteurs essayent de
vous enfumer ou que on essaie de vous
trahir parce que c'est pas le cas et je
crois franchement que on est très on est
très honnête avec vous quand on est
d'accord ou pas d'accord et à chaque
fois qu'on a voulu essayer de trouver un
accord avec vous on vous a demandé de
retirer pour l'écrire donc si on pouvait
juste se respecter ça ferait pas de mal
monsieur la tombe et a près votre oui
merci monsieur le Président l'objectif
de l'amendement de mes collègues
démocrates était justement de dire qu'il
y avait un problème de conventionnalité
au-delà de la au-delà de la la solution
qui était proposée par mes collègues qui
était la suppression sèche clairement il
faut qu'on rendre qu'on r la disposition
conventionnelle et donc clairement
l'idée est plutôt d'aller vers
l'amendement du rapporteur et je
soutiens sa démarche en disant que on
garde le le le on on ne vote pas la
suppression de cet article mais il faut
absolument qu'on vote l'amendement du
rapporteur qui renvoie une disposition
qui est la directive et qui nous met et
clairement dans dans un système de
protection et qui renvoie vraiment
clairement au texte de la directiv ni
plus ni moins ce qui est le plus
protecteur alors sur ces amendements de
suppression qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté amendement
761 monsieur porte mer monsieur le
Président un amendement pour que la
location pour demandeur d'asile octroyée
par l'OFI dans le cadre des conditions
matérielles d'accueil soit sanctuarisée
et elle doit pouvoir être décorrélée de
l'acceptation par le le demandeur
d'asile pardon de la proposition
d'hébergement qui lui est faite monsieur
le
rapporteur défavorable je mets au voix
qui votre pour qui votre contre
rejeté monsieur le rapporteur votre
amendement 1412 alors je l'ai plus ou
moins déjà expliqué euh donc comme je
l'indiqué en donnant mon avis sur les
amendements de suppression il est
indispensable de de s'assurer que la de
la conformité de cet article 19 bis avec
la directive européenne sur l'asile
l'article 20 de cette directive de 2013
dispose que les décisions portant
limitation au retrait du bénéfice des
conditions matérielles d'accueil sont
prises au cas par cas objectivement et
impartialement et sont motivés elles
sont fondées sur la situation
particulière de la personne concernée
les États-membres assure en toutes
circonstances en toutes circonstances
l'accès aux soins médicaux conformément
à l'article 19 et garantisent un niveau
de vie digne à tous les demandeurs voilà
ce qu'on réintègre dans cette dans cet
article je crois qu'on répond à toutes
vos inquiétudes depuis tout à l'heure
oui toutes et si jamais vous me dites
qu'on y répond pas je suis désolé c'est
que vous faire voulez faire plus que ce
qui est prévu je mets donc au voix
l'amendement du rapporteur qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté alors
les deux suivants ne sont pas défendus
l'article 19 bis qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est adopté
le 817 madame fossillon
oui c'est un amendement de mon collègue
dviman qui qui cherche à à ce qu'il ait
plus de collégialité dans la rédaction
et la déclinaison des des schémas
régionaux des demandeurs d'asile et et
ce dans le but de de limiter un rôle
assez prépondérant des des préfets
l'amendement prévoit aussi que ce schéma
soit élaboré conjointement avec la
commission de concertation composé de
représentants des collectivités
territoriales des services
départementaux de l'Éducation national
de gestionnaire de lieu d'hébergement
pour demandeurs d'asile et d'association
de défense des droits des demandeurs
d'asile j'aimerais vous dire Madame fon
que c'est déjà satisfait estce qu'en
fait ce que l'article que vous visez
prévoit déjà que le schéma régional est
établi par le représentant de l'État
dans la région après avis d'une
commission de concertation composée de
représentants des collectivités
territoriales des services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
de gestionnaires de lieu d'hébergement
pour demandeurs d'asile et d'association
de défense des droit des demandeurs
d'asile donc c'est satisfait je vous
propose un retrait ou
défavorable monsieur gilet
oui très rapidement sur sur cet
amendement de notre collègue David
miriman député de guyan puisque c'est
déjà satisfait peut-être est-ce un
amendement d'appel puisque en Guyane les
élus locaux aimeraient être davantage
associés mais surtout en Guyane les élus
locaux les maires en particulier j'en ai
rencontré un certain nombre début se
sont tous opposés à l'immigration
massive qui frappe leur territoire ils
en ont assez parce que leur territoire
est totalement submergé par une
immigration massive qu'il ne supporte
plus et qu'il ne peuvent plus assumer
donc j'y voilà peut-être un amendement
d'appel de la part de notre collègue de
guyen monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie beaucoup
monsieur le député de de votre réflexion
mais avec monsieur le rapporteur
peut-être pour un petit mot c'est la
première fois qu'un
texte en dur si je dire tout de suite
les dispositions euh qui auraiit dû
relever de l'ordonnance il y aura un
titre un article par territoire et ce
qu'on propose peut-être c'est de laisser
les ultramarins et singulièrement
peut-être les élus de ce territoire nous
dire ce qu'ils souhaitent je pense pas
qu'il vous ai choisi comme porte-parole
en tout cas je pense qu'on pourra voir à
l'article 27 tout à l'heure territoire
par territoire comment on pourra
discuter de ce sujet et je pense que
monsieur riman qui avec qui nous avons
discuté le sait très bien et je remercie
madame fousion d'avoir présenté je pense
que le rapporteur a raison de renvoyer
les choses à cette discussion je mets au
voix l'amendement 817 qui vote pour
contre rejeté le suivant Madame
Dupont merci monsieur le Président cette
cet article vise à favoriser l'expulsion
des personnes débouté du droit d'asile
de l'hébergement accordé au titre du
dispositif national d'accueil et et donc
quitter pour certaines personnes quitter
le logement occupé depuis parfois
plusieurs mois peut-être
particulièrement complexe notamment dans
le cas de famille ou encore lorsqu'elles
n'ont pas d'alternative d'hébergement
identifié et dans ce cas le 3 positif
permet déjà de de graduer la réponse en
cas de maintien indu dans un dispositif
d'hébergement allant jusqu'à la demande
du concours de la force publique qui
peut-être accordé par le préfet aussi il
me semble que ces mesures constituent un
durcissement inutile d'où cette
proposition de
suppression monsieur le
rapporteur pardon
alors a priori votre amendement est déjà
satisfait mais ça peut apporter quelque
chose dans le texte je dis
sagesse
pour qui vote contre il est adopté le 30
n'est pas défendu le 1528 madame
jeunev merci Monsieur le le président
alors c'est un amendement madame
louvagie qui est très bonne connaisseuse
de ces sujets il s'agit de resserrer les
conditions dans lesquels un étranger en
situation
irrégulière peut bénéficier d'une
prolongation du bénéfice de la
protection universelle maladie qu'on
appelle souvent la Puma lorsqu'il ne
respecte plus les conditions permettant
en principe d'y être affilié cet
amendement ne remet pas en cause le
maintien des droits mais il en
subordonne le bénéfice à une durée
antérieure de résidence d'au moins 6
mois sur le territoire à l'heure
actuelle le bénéfice du maintien de
droit est subordonné à une résidence
stable et régulière en France de manière
ininterrompu depuis plus de 3 mois ainsi
dans le droit actuel un étranger ayant
par par exemple reçu un titre de séjour
d'une durée de 4 mois et dont il ne
sollicite pas le
renouvellement peut bénéficier d'une
extension de sa couverture pendant 6
mois ce n'est pas acceptable une durée
minimale de présence régulière sur le
territoire d'au moins 6 mois doit être
exigé alors monsieur le
rapporteur alors logiquement c'est
satisfait étant donné que je viens le
faire pour Madame Stella Dupont je vous
propose la
sagesse madame jeev vous n'avez pas
écouter le rapporteur vous don avis de
sagesse estimant que le dispositif
satisfait mais que ça lui coû pas cher
bon alors je mets au voix avec avis
sagesse du rapporteur qui vote pour qui
vote contre il est
adopté je vous ai pas vu madame torinia
vous avez plein d'amendements encore le
1414 monsieur le rapporteur sur la
19 alors logiquement je pense que avec
tous les défenseurs de l'amendement nous
devrions d'accord je propose la
suppression de cet article
l'héberargement d'urgence en France est
un droit fondamental et inconditionnel
et j'ai pas l'envie de revenir là-dessus
monsieur Lucas le suivant merci
Président nous proposons la suppression
de cet article issu du du
Sénat également celui-ci précise en
effet l'exclusion des personnes
concernées par uneqtf ou débouter du du
droit d'asile du dispositif de garantie
de l'hébergement d'urgence on est encore
sur un article qu'on pourrait qualifier
de célérra de mesquin j'ai pas besoin de
d'y revenir et d'expliquer à chacun à
quel point il nous faut quand même
retrouver un peu d'humanité dignité au
moins dans dans la suppression de cet
article monsieur kbrat le
758 merci monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement comme monsieur le rapporteur
ou mon collègue Lucas vise à supprimer
l'vincement des personnes sous qtf ou
des boutiles de droit d'asile un accès à
un hébergement d'urgence et je suis
content qu'on se retrouve sur la
primauté qu'on donne sur ce droit au
logement parce que en effet qu'on soit
français résident en France ou étranger
résident en France on considère que la
mise à l'abri de toute personnes euh se
retrouvant à la rue devrait être un
impératif c'est un peu dommage que nous
ayons voté quand même dans cette
assemblée une loi qui s'appelle qu'on
appelle communément la loi casbariant la
loi antiquat comme vous vous l'appelé
euh qui elle remet en prima le droit à
la propriété et casse le droit au
logement donc je pense que remettre un
peu d'humanité dans ce texte qui a été
bien amimé par le Sénat serait peut-être
utile donc supprimons cet article euh le
150 monsieur
valallot raté
euh le le l'article 19 TER a c'est c'est
pour nous l'article du
désordre c'est c'est c'est c'est
l'article qui est totalement
incompréhensible ou ou ou
malheureusement trop compréhensible
puisquen décidant de de faire dormir à
la rue les les étrangers en situation
irrégulière dès lors qu'on les exclut
des garanties d'hébergement d'urgence
euh on on institutionnalise le désordre
c'est-à-dire qu'on alimente les
campement fortune et nous nous le
souhaitons pas euh on maintient des
femmes et des hommes dans des conditions
sanitaires qui sont absolument
déplorables et donc cet article 19 terre
a institutionnalise en quelque sorte le
le refus d'un besoin vital qui est quand
même l'hébergement d'urgence lorsque on
en dispose pas donc évidemment c'est un
amendement de suppression
oui on est là sur un
article je dirais particulièrement
indigne et qui
euh enfin le le supprimer est évidemment
une nécessité mais je veux rappeler
simplement ce qui nous anime quand on
dit inconditionnalité de l'accueil
inconditionnalité de l'hébergement
d'urgence vous avez quelqu'un qui dort
dehors qui fasse froid qui fasse chaud
et cetera il est dehors on le met à
l'abri point et en fait c'est c'est ce
qui fait nous c'est en fait c'est ce qui
nous permet de tenir debout et de dire
qu'on est humain quoi donc il y a un
moment en fait je je ne comprends même
pas qu'à l'heure où nous sommes où nous
voyons qu'il y a presque 3 gamins qui
dorment dehors encore aujourd'hui dans
la rue il y a des gens ici dans ce pays
qui pensent à dire on va mettre des
barrières et d'ailleurs dans les fait il
y a déjà du tri et j'ai honte qu'il y
ait encore et qu'il y ait aujourd'hui du
tri parmi les gens qui sont dehors pour
dire ben on va accueillir plutôt
celui-là que plutôt celui-là qu'on
déclenche des critères de vulnérabilité
parce qu'il y a pas assez de place non
on dort pas dehors on dort pas dehors
quand on est un homme une femme un
enfant on dort pas dehors donc vraiment
je il faut le supprimer ça c'est évident
mais je veux
merci Madame
chassagol merci monsieur le Président
c'est aussi un amendement de suppression
de cet article qui exclut des étrangers
de l'accueil en hébergement d'urgence il
y a déjà un risque constitutionnel à mon
sens d'établir une telle discrimination
pour un droit fondamental ça veut dire
sans distinction d'origine ni lien avec
le statut administratif d'une personne
ensuite je ne vois pas comment laisser
ces personnes dans la rue résoutra
résoudra les problèmes que l'on
rencontre déjà avec la saturation des
héberg d'Ur et je peux vous dire aussi
que dans ma circonscription c'est une
situation qui est permanente même quand
des familles sont hébergées d'autres
arrivent avant de l'être à nouveau et
elles dorment dans la rue actuellement
il fait très froid et dans Paris vous
avez des personnes qui sont souvent en
situation irrégulière elles sont sans
abri et j'ai pas l'impression que ça
leur donne forcément envie ou que cette
situation accélère leur retour dans leur
pays
d'origine alors le Balanant 1351 qui le
défend monsieur
oui merci monsieur le Président oui nous
pensons au groupe démocrate qu'il est
pas nécessaire d'ajouter problèmes au
problème eteffectivement en excluant
systématiquement les étrangers en
situation irrégulière d'un dispositif
d'hébergement d'urgence certainement pas
une solution en tous les cas à plusieurs
niveaux donc nous sommes nous volontaire
effectivement pour supprimer l'article
en déposant cet
amendement mad
oui monsieur le Président il est
défendu un amendement pour rétablir
l'inconditionnalité de l'hébergement
d'urgence pour les pour les étrangers
quelle que soit leur situation
administrative monsieur le rapporteur
votre avis est favorable puisque vous
avez un amendement monsieur gilet
oui chers collègues en 2023 il n'est pas
acceptable de voir des gens dormir
dehors en France c'est inévidence mais
combien de français sont mal logés
combien de français sont SDF aujourd
aujourd'hui combien de retraités qui ont
bossé toute leur vie se retrouvent
obligé à aller vivre chez leurs enfants
ou se retrouve même parfois à vivre dans
leur voiture je l'ai vu dans mon
département par exemple alors
effectivement personne n' vocation à
dormir dehors et je suis bien d'accord
avec vous mais nous parlons là de
personnes sous octf dont la demande
d'asile est définitivement rejeté et qui
peuvent bénéficier d'une aide financière
au retour dans leur pays et donc ils ont
moyen de retourner chez eux avec un
trajet qui leur est payé par l'état
français il faut le
rappeler monsieur le rapporteur voulez
répondre excusez-moi monsieur gilet mais
on vient de de parler d'un droit
inconditionnel dans un pays comme la
France parce qu'on est en situation
irrégulière on ne vous met pas dans la
rue on vous laisse pas mourir dans la
rue en fait ce que vous êtes en train de
proposer c'est ça et nous on n'est pas
du tout dans ce fonctionnement là c'est
pas la France la France c'est
d'accueillir les gens de façon
inconditionnelle dans un hébergement
d'urgence que la personne soit en
situation irrégulière ou non cela ne
change rien on parle d'être humain et
pas d'un bout de papier ce que vous êtes
en train de faire monsieur gilet est
inadmissible c'est abject voulez faire
des catégories d'humain et de dire
certains on le droit d'être héberger
accompagné de dormir au chaud et de les
e de les laisser crever dans la rue et
ça c'est abject monsieur de la
porte écoute
président quand on entend ça on ne peut
qu'être choqué et par ailleurs il y a
pas que le RN qui le pense puisque il ça
a été voté au Sénat et c'est donc que
nos collègues sénateurs républicains le
pensaient je vais dire à mes collègues
républicains je les invite à venir par
exemple à
wistream c'est pas très loin d'ici c'est
2hur de train et vous avez actuellement
250 soudanés qui dorment alors qu'il
gèlent dehors pourquoi parce parce que
le droit inconditionnel à l'hébergement
c'est certes un droit mais aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas un droit en acte et on
trouve encore de trop nombreuses
personnes qui sont à la rue et qui
l'attendent et je pense aussi à tous ces
enfants qui subiraiit une telle mesure
parce que leurs parents se
retrouveraient sous qtf qu'ad
deviendrait-il des familles voilà elle
serait elle aussi à la rue donc voilà je
je ne comprends pas que les républicains
a pu voter une telle mesure digne des
pires horreurs du musée du rassemblement
national monsieur le
ministre non mais quelques instants pour
un un sujet qui est
pardon pour un sujet qui est évidemment
très
important et
qui et qui mérite évidemment qu'on
essaie de trouver j'espère la plus
grande unanimité pour lutter contre des
personnes qui effectivement meurent de
froid dans dans la rue quel que soit
leur nationalité quel que soit leur
statut quel que soit leur âge c'est
évidemment encore plus choquant
lorsqu'il s'agit d'enfant mais ça
concerne tout le monde je pense que
c'est un peu c'est un peu dommage dans
l'article du Sénat qu'il n'y ait pas de
distinction d'abord entre ce qui relève
de la du la DNA c'est-à-dire là où les
demandeurs d'asile les étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui sont même sous
TF en recours contre leurs TF parce que
parfois on pe on peut être sous UTF et
pendant 2 3 ans devoir rester sur le
territoire national pour attendre la
réponse de la justice et ce qui relève
de l'hébergement d'urgence qui n'est pas
fait pour cela l'hébergement d'urgence
il est normalement fait pour les
personnes qui sont à la rue pour les
personnes qui ont des difficultés très
fortes de logement et qui sont en
situation régulière parce que étrangère
ou qui sont ou qui sont français et
l'une des difficultés c'est qu'il y a
tellement de monde à gérer qu'il
s'agisse des SDF comme on les appelle
classiquement des personnes qui sont
dans la difficulté extrêmement forte de
logement ou des personnes qui sont
irrégulières et qui ne sont donc pas
dans un schéma normal mal de logement
que les choses se confondent et que on
voit bien que les crédits budgétaires
personne ne peut en faire l'attaque au
gouvernement augmente chaque année de
manière automatique parce que
malheureusement la crise du logement
rejoint la crise migratoire qui rejoint
la crise de la salubrité et que nous
mettons nous mettons dans l'hébergement
d'urgence des personnes qui relèvent
d'autres dispositifs et et donc je pense
qu'il faut d'abord distinguer les deux à
la fin c'est des personnes qui doivent
trouver un logement c'est pas les mêmes
programmes budgétaire c'est pas les
mêmes façons de faire c'est pas les
mêmes action le seule chose difficile
parce que moi je suis effectivement pour
rejeter cet article 19 TER a il y a
aucun doute la seule chose difficile
indépendamment des moyens budgétaires
c'est le fait que les personnes
attendent des mois des mois et des mois
une réponse de l'administration ou de la
justice c'est c'est cet article 19 a et
les difficultés de logement n'auraient
pas lieu si et je l'espère ce texte de
loi va être voté et va permettre les
articles de simplification que nous
évoquons pour qu'on ait une réponse en 1
an définitive plutôt que laisser les
gens 2 3 ans 4 ans qui ne peuvent pas
travailler parce qu'il régulier parce
qu'ils sont en demande d'avoir des
papiers et qui font des des des des
recours et des recours et des recours ce
qui est tout à fait compréhensible et
qui se termine par un nom c'est ça qui
ne va pas ce qui ne va pas c'est pas le
fait que on doit réduire les places de
logement pour que les gens irréguliier
puisse dire tiens j'ai froid en France
et du coup je repars dans mon pays
évidemment c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe wiream on est un bon exemple
monsieur le député vous le savez
d'ailleurs que on a appelé Monsieur le
Préfet pour régler le problème avec vous
pour les les l'hébergement parce
qu'effectivement il faut loger ces
personnes même s'ils veulent passer en
Angleterre pour une partie d'entre eux
on a déjà parlé mais évidemment ce n'est
pas digne de la répque de les laisser
ainsi dehors tout à fait d'accord avec
vous mais on est bien d'accord que l'une
des difficultés c'est que plus on laisse
les gens longtemps sur le territoire
national en attendant d'avoir des
réponses bah plus il se trouvent dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes donc
je crois que euh les sénateurs prennent
sur un vrai sujet le le mauvais côté de
du du sujet il faut évidemment pas
adopter ce dispositif il faut en
revanche indépendamment des moyens
budgétaires très importants qui ont été
augmentés qui on augmenter qu'on
simplifie et qu'on raccourcisse les
délais parce que comme ça comme sur tous
les autres sujets qu'on a évoqué c'est
le raccourcissement des délais qui fait
que notre service public marchera mieux
elle laissera des placesbergement
d'urgence au SDF et permettra de faire
dans laadna le travail qu'on doit faire
autour des étrangers qui sont irrégulier
ou en demandeur
d'asile il reste monsieur
léoman
merci monsieur le Président alors déjà
sur le raccourcissement des délais dans
les services publics on peut se
féliciter du fait que hier l'Assemblée
nationale et adopter la proposition de
loi de ma collègue Daniel auonau qui
permettra d'améliorer les services
publics d'une manière générale ensuite
sur cette question de l'hébergement
d'urgence la logique du rassemblement
national c'est celle d'une gestion de la
pénurie c'est-à-dire ils nous disent ah
mais en fait comme il y a pas assez de
logement pour tout le monde il faut
loger d'abord les Français et puis les
étrangers sousoccup UTF on verra après
c'est la démonstration du fait qu'ils
sont xénophobes parce que en réalité
quand on est des êtres humains qui
pensent en fonction de l'humanité on n'
pas envie que quelqu'un dorme dans la
rue et on se soucie pas d'abord de
savoir quelle est sa carte d'identité ou
sa nationalité on se soucie de loger la
personne en l'occurrence en ce moment il
y a 3000 enfants qui sont à la rue dont
700 qui ont moins de 3 ans et puis tout
ça pour vous dire que le racisme rbête
en réalité parce que y compris même pour
pouvoir faire exécuter les TF il vaut
mieux savoir où sont les gens plutôt que
de les perdre dans la nature voyez même
même pour votre logique à vous et ben
c'est stupide ce que vous venez de
défendre merci
alors Monsieur
Lucas merci merci Monsieur le le
président simplement tout à l'heure
notre notre collègue de la porte
s'étonnait à juste titre d'ailleurs que
le groupe nommé les républicains ce qui
est quand même un peu difficile à à
concevoir quand on sait ce qu' la
République et voter ce texte au Sénat
moi je m'étonne parce que là on vote des
suppressions d' certain nombre de choses
je m'étonne que les sénateur et
sénatrice macronist de la majorité
présidentielle emmené par Monsieur
patria et voter ce texte avec ce nombre
de choses assez horribles dont don dont
une partie que vous que vous détricotez
donc ça prouve quand même une forme de
duplicité ou d'amateurisme dans cette
séquence et et d'une forme de légèreté
avec des sujets qui sont graves et qui
sont sérieux et enfin Madame
genunevard
merci merci monsieur le Président en
réalité personne personne ne peut être
insensible à la situation de ceux qui
dorment à la rue et en effet
particulièrement les enfants mais je
voudrais dire mes chers collègues qu'on
ne peut pas tout à la fois vouloir lever
tous les freins de l'accueil et en même
temps déplorer que nous ne soyons pas en
capacité d'accueillir dignement ces
personnes c'est pas possible ça n'est
pas possible et et la la répartition la
répartition des étrangers sur l'ensemble
du territoire national selon une
politique voulu le le le gouvernement et
la majorité est une politique qui n'a
rien résolu qui n'a absolument rien
résolu et je trouve que la seule
solution décente et bien c'est de
réguler des flux migratoires de façon à
ne pas avoir à gérer ces problèmes-là la
France la France dépense 2 milliards
d'euros pour les demandeurs d'asile pour
les personnes en situation irrégulière 2
milliards par an vous ne pouvez pas dire
que la France est insensible à la
situation de l'hébergement bien sûr
qu'elle y est mais il les politiques
publiques et les budgets n suffisent
plus il faut donc réguler les flux si
vous sinon nous n'y arriverons pas et
vous continuerez de déplorer une
situation dont vous refusez de traiter
les causes alors je mets au voix les
amendements de suppression qui vote pour
contre adopté il supprime l'article 19
combien TER
a après c article j'ai un amendement du
groupe écologiste qui le défend
l'amendement de Monsieur
tachéend défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable étant donné qu'on vient de
supprimer l'article c'est donc
satisfait je mets au voix qui votre pour
qui vote contre il est rejeté merci pour
les se personnes qui ont voté le 19 TER
votre amendement monsieur le rapporteur
donc comme beaucoup à nouveau je je je
propose de supprimer cet article 19 TER
étant donné que en fait cet article
paraît totalement trahir l'esprit de la
loi SRU donc à partir de là proposition
de suppression et je serais favorable
pour tous les amendements de suppression
monsieur lucal 61 oui ben une fois de
plus nous allons supprimer ensemble ce
que vos collègues sénateurs RDPI ont
voté je m'en je m'en réjouis en
l'occurrence euh nous proposons donc la
suppression de cet article lui aussi
issu du du Sénat celui-ci intègre les
places des centres d'accueil pour
demandur d'asile centre provisoire
d'hébergement dispositif d'hébergement
d'urgence des demandeurs d'asile et
centre d'accueil et d'évaluation des
situations dans le décompte du taux de
logements sociaux imposés aux communes
par la loi cette manœuvre dont le lien
avec le texte initial est discutable au
sens de l'article 45 de notre
Constitution enfin on reconnaîtra
évidemment que ce n'est pas le seul dans
dans ce texte qui est un tracte de la
droite radicalisée vise à permettre aux
communes un moindre investissement dans
les logements sociaux lesquels profitent
aux habitants de notre pays les plus
précaires et ont besoin de solidarité
publique alors le châelin n'est pas
défendu la demande an
torinia je viens de vous appeler votre
amendement madame par votre nom en
plus
donc par cet amendement nous nous
voulons supprimer cet
article parce que voilà cet article
prévoit d'intégrer les places
d'hébergement destiné à l'hébergement
provisoire et d'urgence dans les
logements sociaux à hauteur de 20 25 5 %
donc là en fait ce dont il est question
c'est de de trouver une solution pour
ces commune qui refuse de respecter les
les objectifs pour leur permettre en
fait de diluer un service public dans un
autre et donc il est temps effectivement
que toutes les communes remplissent leur
leur objectif mais sans passer par les
logements sociaux et donc c'est c'est
une c'est une idée qu'on a vu surgir
aussi lors de de l'examen du texte
de l'obj ou je sais pas qui avait eu
l'idée de d'intégrer la création des des
des places supplémentair de prison dans
les logements sociaux ah oui c'est
vrai l'amendement 951 monsieur de la
porte oui merci c'est un article qui a
été une nouvelle fois ajouté par LR au
Sénat il est une nouvelle fois mesquin
mais il est aussi profondément indigne
parce que il vise à remettre d'une part
en cause la loi sus qui est une espèce
de marote permanente de LR mais en plus
il donne l'impression que bon finalement
on pourrait pour certaines communes les
intégrer tous ces centres
d'hébergement d'urgence pour et de ces
cada pour les demandeurs d'asile mais je
le dis encore une fois ma collègue
jeunevar encore faudrait-il que les
sénateurs LR soutiennent l'implantation
de cada sur leur commune parce que une
fois encore ici on on est dans une forme
de remise en cause non seulement de la
loi mais aussi du principe de l'asile où
on veut dire bon bah voilà on va tout
mixer ensemble et c'est c'est la grande
confusion c'est la grande confusion et
ici vous ne faites une fois de plus que
soutenir des mesures indignes et je
finirai en répondant à votre
interpellation tout à l'heure vous vous
dites bon la France n'a pas les moyens
d'accueillir c'est pas vrai la France
accueille et moins que les
autres le 12 1211 madame fosson oui cet
article il dans le prolongement du
précédent à à tenté de remettre en cause
l'inconditionnalité de l'accueil je je
simplement dire aux collègues de de LR
que en fait un des problèmes aujourd'hui
du du manque de place aussi dans dans
l'hébergement d'urgence c'est le manque
de logements sociaux c'est un des vrais
manques du de de logements sociaux et
ceux qui proposent de remettre en cause
l'inconditionnel l'inconditionnalité de
l'accueil c'est les mêmes qui ne
respectent pas la loi SRU écoutez je je
suis élu du 92 les 22 communes qui ne
respecte pas la loi SRU dans mon
département sur 36 communes sont tenu
par des maires les républi donc
construisez des logements sociaux
respecez la loi SRU et vous verrez on
pourra peut-être accueillir des gens
dans l'hébergement d'urgence monsieur
Mandon le suivant
oui monsieur le Président évidemment sur
ce point nous n'approuvons pas la
démarche qui a
été votée à l'époque par la commission
du Sénat ils ont intégré les places
destinées à l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile dans le décomte du taux de 20 %
à 25 % de logements sociaux imposés aux
communes depuis la loi su dans
l'impression effectivement que on
voulait faire d'une pierre de coup mais
ici nous pensons que ce n'est pas du
tout une bonne solution et c'est
pourquoi nous avons sans hésiter proposé
la suppression de cet article alors et
donc nous voterons je défends mon
amendement mais je vous suggère
lorsqu'il y a une grande unanimité sur
ce genre de sujet d'aller un peu plus
vite si on peut
le monsieur le rapporteur vous êtes
favorable monsieur le ministre vous
vouliez
parler non en 20 secondes monsieur de
laapte et je vous le dis en tant en tant
que maire qui avait à la fois beaucoup
plus que en tant plus que pourcentage de
lo fue et accueillant des CAD sur mon
territoire dans ma commune non non je je
je je vous le dis vous dites il faudrait
que les collègues des républicains
accueillent des CAD mais mais on peut le
dire on peut le dire pour non mais
attendez un historique oui il y a un
historique qui avait ni fait de cada ni
fait d'accueil des gens du voyage vous
avez bien raison et qui avait concentré
90 % des ls sociaux dans le même
quartier bon on va pas faire le débat
municipal il a été gagné déjà tranché
par deux fois donc il y a pas de sujet
non vous disiez à Madame jeunevard assez
justement d'ailleurs qu'il fallait que
les sénateur etir accueille sur leur
territoire des CAD mais il faudrait que
tout le monde le fasse parce que en tant
en tant que ministre je constate que les
préfets sontigé de forcer quel que
soient les les communes y compris les
communes socialistes je vais pas vous
faire une non non y compris les communes
socialistes
voilà le monsieur
porte merci monsieur le Président
évidemment en soutien de de cet
amendement parce que c'est il y a quand
même quelque chose d'indécent à vouloir
intégrer ses place dans le dans le
logement social alors qu'on manque de
logement sociaux dans le pays et je
voudrais dire à nos collègues
républicains qui nous font des leçons
sur les respects des lois de la
République sur les les devoirs qui
devraient com à toutes les personnes et
la très grande majorité de leur mère
refuse d'appliquer la loi SRU et préfère
payer des amendes préfère payer des
amendes plutôt que de construire des
logements sociaux donc avant de donner
des leçon demander à vos élus qui sont
en responsabilité de respecter la loi
SRU ça sera déjà une première étape
madame
Jeeva merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais dire à mes aimables collègues
que je ne suis pas la représentation de
la totalité des sénateurs donc s'il
pouvit s'adresser d'une députée à une
députée ce serait quand même
sympathique
ensuite vous êtes absolument incroyable
parce que si les centres
d'acc si les centres d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile si les centres
provisoires
d'hébergement ne sont pas des logements
à vocation sociale mais c'est que vous
avez comme on dit chez moi de la peau de
saucisse devant les yeux parce que ce
sont des logements ce sont des logements
j'ai été maire de Morau ce sont des
logements à vocation évidemment sociale
vous déploriez le ministre le ministre
déplorait que davantage de communes
n'accepent pas des CAD mais précisément
si vous les intégré au cota de logements
sociaux parce que c'est leur vocation
ils seront peut-être mieux clin à le
faire donc ce ce ce procès permanent est
insupportable j'ajoute que quand vous
lancez comme ça à la cantonnade la
majorité des mères LR ne font pas de
logements sociaux c'est scandaleux parce
que je vous demande je vous demande des
chiffres et des statistiqu évidemment
vous regardez ça à l'ône de votre
circonscription sur votre territoire il
y a peut-être des exemples en effet mais
vous ne pouvez pas en tirer une
généralité merci non ça c'est
franchement malhonnête
intellectuellement par équité madame
jeev je laisser un peu plus de temps
parce que j'ai compris que les collègues
étaient tous sur votre dos ce
soir monsieur
gilet
[Musique]
dans ce cas-là on risque d'avoir on
risque d'avoir 10 minutes de temps de
parole nous concernant mais là sur cet
amendement je me permets de de rebondir
parce que mon mon amendement risque de
de sauter puisque vous allez approuver
ces amendements de suppression mais moi
je suis d'accord avec la collègue
effectivement les maires qui font
l'effort d'accueillir ces structures
d'accueil d'hébergement d'urgence bien
ça leur coûte ça leur coûte non
seulement de l'argent mais aussi en
investissement c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas évident en investissement je
parle pas d'investissement financier
mais en investissement au quotidien
chers collègues quand vous accueillez
des structures d'accueil d'hébergement
d'urgence sur vos territoires vous avez
toute une logistique derrière vous avez
aussi vos centres communaux d'actions
sociale qui vont être mis à contribution
et dans l'amendement que je vous
présenta juste après monsieur le
ministre et là c'est pour vous nous vous
ion d'inclure également les places en CR
dans ce calcul pour la loi SRU parce que
si vous voulez rendre attractif
l'installation de cras sur les
différentes communes en France il faut
aussi que les maères y trouvent un
bénéfice et ce bénéfice ça pourrait êre
à madame yououfa il rest madameoua
je suis pas sûr que l'c est une vocation
sociale inée mais madameou allezy je
voulais remercier Madame jeevard pour ce
moment en fait vous parlez de du stade
de Cavani à mamouzu qui est actuellement
occupé par une soixantaine de
migrants tous demandeurs d'asile qui
comme ils n'ont pas de logement pour les
demandeurs
d'asile il y a plus de place d'urgence
il y a absolument rien pour les loger on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas les évacuer
les dégager du seul stade de la capitale
administrative de Mayotte c'est
faut quand même se stadeada vous en avez
pourtant un mais en fait c'est vous dire
que quand il y a pas de logement social
qu'il y a un espace qui est contraint
que les mairies n'ont pas les moyens de
construire du logement social ajouter
cette obligation d'accueil avec l'asile
n'est pas chose facile pour pour dire
les choses c'est en train de créer un
absès de fixation dans mamouzu c'est
devenu un lieu
extrêmement déjà insalubre violent et le
voisinage le VI mal voilà je voulais
vous donner un voilà c'est les
amendements de suppression qui vaêtre
pour amendement de suppression vous avez
tous défendu peut-être voilà qui vre
contre ils sont adoptés ils font
suppriment l'article 19 TER 19 quoi TER
monsieur Lucas amendement 62 madame
madame rigole vous avez été
abandonné défendu madame rle j'arrive
merci monsieur le Président chaque nuit
on en a déjà parlé mais j'en rajoute une
couche des dizaines des centaines de
familles sont sans solution
d'hébergement et donc dorment à la rue
ça représente des enfants qui après
l'école n'ont nulle part où aller je
sais que dans chacune de nos
circonscriptions on a des exemples comme
ça des parents démunis ou encore des
personnes isolées auxquelles on refuse
la plus élémentaire des dignités à
savoir celle d'avoir droit à un toit
nous demandons la suppression de cet
article parce qu'il modifie ses édat
afin que les débouttés du droit d'asile
ne puissent se maintenir dans
l'hébergement qui leur a été attribué au
titre du dispositif national d'accueil
sauf en cas d'avis contraire de
l'administration sans cela sans cette
suppression c'est autant de sansabris
supplémentaires créés fabriqués c'est
autant de marchands de sommeil qui
pouront exploiter la précarité des
personnes expulsées et de leur
hébergement nous demandons donc le
respect inconditionnel du droit à
l'hébergement et son effectivité tout à
l'heure monsieur le rapporteur Mendes
disait que la France c'était la capacité
d'accueillir inconditionnellement et
bien l'accueil inconditionnel il est
correct monsieur porte le
753 merci monsieur le Président un
amendement pour supprimer cette
proposition sénatorielle qui vise à
rendre impossible le maintien d'une
personne déboutée du droit d'asile dans
un hébergement accordé au titre du
dispositif national d'accueil
effectivement puisque cette personne
pourra avoir droit à une régularisation
via d'autres titres et en la jetant à la
rue ça a été dit par ma collègue regol
on va encore accélérer la précarisation
l'exclusion de ces personneslà on les
fragilise alors qu'elles sont déjà dans
une situation qui est extrêmement
compliqué et le principe humaniste il
est de s'assurer que tout le monde a un
toit sur la tête donc c cette
disposition sénatoriale est indigne elle
est dans la droite ligée de ce texte là
et il faut la supprimer pour remettre un
petit peu d'humanité dans ce texte qui
est extrêmement sordide le
952 monsieur de la porte merci monsieur
le Président alors je vais pas rapporter
ce que viennent de dire mes collègues
avec Briot talent et humanité mais j'ai
l'impression à voir l'amendement du
rapporteur qu'ici vous ne nous suivrez
pas que vous allez décider de maintenir
cette mesure qui vise à harceler les
personnes les plus précaires celles qui
sont débouté du droit d'asile et qui se
retrouvent sans rien à les jeter hors de
ce qui leur reste c'està-dire
l'hébergement et donc àer rejeter dans
la rue parce que c'est ce qui va se
produire avec cet article et donc
monsieur le rapporteur en disant bon on
fera sauf pour ceux qui sont vulnérables
et bien peut-être que vous dites que
vous offrez une protection à ceux qui
sont de toute façon ble mais je trouve
que c'est indigne puis et c'est pour
cela qu'il aurait fallu simplement
supprimer cet
amendement madame fossillon le
suivant monsieur Balan monsieur Mandon
le suivant oui monsieur le Président
c'est vrai que nous sommes avons été
surpris en prenant connaissance du texte
qui nous venait du
Sénat de voir ce de telles dispositions
instauré parce que tout cela conduit
finalement à rendre les conditions
toujours plus compliquées et comme je le
soulignais tout à l'heure nous n'avons
absolument pas intérêt à ajouter des
problèmes au problèmes donc sur ce point
précis là encore nous estimons que la
suppression
s'impose madame Dupon le comme mon
collègue Mandon c'est vrai que nous
prenons la suppression pure et simple de
cet article puisque quitter le logement
occupé depuis parfis plusieurs mois
peut-être particulièrement complexe
notamment dans le cas de famille débouté
du droit d'asile parce qu'elles n'ont
pas forcément une alternative
d'hébergement identifié le droit positif
permet déjà de graduer la réponse en cas
de maintien indu dans un dispositif
d'hébergement allant même jusqu'à la
demande du concours de la force publique
qui peut-être accordé par le préfet et
en allant en me rendant sur différents
centres j'ai pu constater que les
mesures étaient effectives et mises en
œuvre donc moi je ne suis pas favorable
du tout à ce maintien d'article et je
propose sa
suppression monsieur rapporteur
défavorable sur ces sur ces amendements
alors je pense qu'il faut il faut
vraiment qu'on entende le l'enjeu de
l'engorgement actuel des des
hébergements accordés au titre du
dispositif d'accueil c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui a motivé le Sénat à rédiger cet
article pour autant nous ne pouvons pas
accepter de laisser cette écriture tel
quelle et je propose un amendement
certes comme le dit Monsieur de la porte
cores conviendra pas à tout le monde
mais qui permettra d'atténuer les choses
sur le principe de vulnérabilité qui est
important et c'est ce que vous nous
dites aussi depuis tout à l'heure
quelqu'un qui est déboutté aujourd'hui
du droit d'asile même s'il est en
procédure s'il est débouté du droit
d'asile pour de bon il n'a pas vocation
à rester dans son hébergement je prends
il y a plusieurs départements où on peut
démontrer qu' on manque de à peu près
1000 à 1500 place d'hébergement pour les
demandeurs d'asile parce que justement
ce qu'on fait avec cette loi qui
n'existait pas jusqu'à maintenant de
réduire les délais de réduire énormément
de choses pour mieux les accompagner
pour répondre à leur demande d'asile
pour qu'il ne puissent pas rester de ou
3 ans dans ces centres d'accueil ils
vont pouvoir libérer des places mais en
attendant il faut pouvoir libérer des
places et quelqu'un qui a été déboutté
de son droit d'asile ne peut pas y
rester donc défavorable alors madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président c'est
précisément pour éviter ce genre de
situation dramatique c'est précarisation
des étrangers irréguliers sans abrisme
mallogement que nous souhaitons que les
demandes d'asile soient formulé dans
depuis les pays d'origine ou depuis les
pays voisins sûr et c'est pour que les
déboutés du droit d'asile qui sont en
nombre qui se maintiennent sur le
territoire national en nombre puisque
personne n'est expulsé et bien c'est
c'est précisément à cause de ces
personnes que nous avons des personnes
qui ont le droit à ces logements qui ne
peuvent pas en bénéficier donc pour nous
nous considérons que les déboutés du
droit d'asile ne doivent pas occuper ces
logements accordés au titre du
dispositif national d'accueil mais ces
déboutés du droit d'asile n'ont pas non
plus vocation à se rester en
France Monsieur monsieur de la
porte en fait monsieur le rapporteur
c'est une garantie juridique en
plastique que vous nous apportez là
parce que ceux qui vont finalement
décider de la vulnrabilité c'est les
préfets or ce sont les mêmes qui sont
confrontés au manque de place dans les
cadas mais c'est aussi ce manque de
place dans les cadas qui permet pas
d'aller vers le logement social par
exemple ou alors vers l'hébergement
d'urgence puisque l'hébergement
d'urgence est saturé et alors que c'est
là où pourrai se retrouver ces personnes
finement qui sontbout donc aujourd'hui
on n pas dans un CAD par plaisir moi je
peux vous dire j'en croise des personnes
qui sont en cada il me disent il y a des
cafar me disent il y a des rat on n pas
dans un centre dans un cada parce qu'on
a envie d'y rester c'est parce qu'on a
pas d'aut solution et parce qu'on est
déjà en situation de vulnérabilité donc
monsieur le rapporteur s'il vous plaît
cette fois-ci retirez votre amendement
et soutenez les autres il est encore
tempsci je comprends pas très bien par
quej le cas de toute façon les personnes
qui reçoivent unqtf elles ont en général
ils sont donc dans un CAD avant ensuite
il reçoivent leqtf ilelles ont trois ou
4 jours d'hôtel et ensuite elle se
retrouve à la rue et moi dans ma
circonscription voyez ces jours-ci il a
fallu que je m'occupe d'une maman qui
venait qui avait reçu nos qtf qui venait
d'accoucher au CHU de Saint-Étienne et
qui s'est retrouvé avec son nouveauné
donc à la rue puisqu'elle avait leqtf
elle avait pas de cadar et heureusement
qu'elle a été pris en charge par une une
citoyenne qui n'a pas voulu laisser
cette maman et ce nouveau né dans les
rues de Saint-Étienne
commence à faire froid voyez cette
semaine il commence déjà même à neiger
donc on a besoin de de de de place
d'accueil et c'est déjà le cas quand les
gens reçoivent une qtf ils ne sont plus
dans les CAD et c'est bien ça le
problème moi dans ma circonscription à à
Saint-Étienne il y a
une il doit y avoir entre 100 et 150
familles aujourd'hui qui sont prises en
charge par des associations parce que
les gens et y compris des gens qui
votent France National ne veulent pas
laisser les gens mourir dans la rue
Monsieur la tombe et les prêt merci
monsieur le Président pour aller dans le
sens de ce qu'a dit le rapporteur je
suis pas forcément je suis pas favorable
à une suppression sèche de cet article
mais ça ne peut s'accompagner que si
nous adoptons l'amendement du rapporteur
qui module qui permet de trouver un
équilibre sur cette sur cet article donc
je me je vote trit contre les
amendements de suppression mais pour
l'amendement du rapporteur je vous
remercie madame
potion non simplement l'histoire je
rejoins mon collègue de la porte
l'histoire de la vulnérabilité on sait
dans les fait euh ce qu'elle donne euh
dans le cadre de l'hébergement d'urgence
quand il y a déclenchement des critères
dit de vulnérabilité en fait ça se fait
en fonction des places existantes et des
besoins euh je je j'ai vu d'ailleurs
queà certains endroits ils étaient
aujourd'hui révisés l'effet qu'il y a eu
par exemple en 2018 quand il y a eu une
très forte montée c'est que on jugeait
pas vulnérable les personnes qui avaient
pas un enfant de moins de 3 ans on est
même descendu à 2 ans on on était pas
vulnérable quand on était pas enceinte
ou handicapé donc à partir du moment où
on était une femme seule avec trois
enfants qui avaient plus de 3 ans on
nétait pas vulnérable donc ne nous
racontez pas d'histoire sur cette
appréciation de la vulnérabilité parce
que en réalité elle vient juste
permettre de dire il y en a qui sont
plus vulnérables que d'autres et donc la
person elle sera pas jugée
individuellement sur sa vulnérabilité
mais au regard des autres donc voilà
pourquoi il a raison de dire que c'est
en carton comme comme critère parce que
ça ne repose sur rien à part sur les
besoins existants et les manque de
place merci selon le projet annuel de
performance de la mission asile
immigration intégration le taux de
présence indu des bénéficiaires de la
protection international s'établit à 12
% et celui des déboutés du droit d'asile
à 7,5 %. donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on
constate près de 20 % des places du DNA
seraiit occupé par des personnes n'ayant
plus vocation à y séjourner et donc
c'est une réalité bien entendu mais
j'insiste sur le fait que l'augmentation
qu'on constate aujourd'hui est lié à
l'occupation indu par des réfugiés des
gens qui obtiennent la protection donc
on a un problème de fluidité du
dispositif nationale d'accueil mais qui
relève plus des freins à l'accès au
logement que du maintien ind des débout
du droit d'asile puisque souvent ce sont
des familles pour lesquelles il faut du
temps bien entendu avant de sortir du
DNA donc je pense vraiment que on n pas
besoin de d'aller aussi loin dans ce
texte d'où cette proposition de
suppression donc je le mets au voix C
amend de suppression
qui qui ve
pour qui vote contre ils sont rejetés
monsieur mendzre amendement l' défendu
merci président alors qu'on soit clair
cette proposition elle est ni en
plastique ni en carton et je préférais
le carton en plastique parce que ça se
recycle le carton et le plastique c'est
parfois plus compliqué euh non mais pour
revenir sur sur le fond du sujet je
rappelle que quand on est notifié de
d'être d'avoir été débouté du droit
d'asile ou d'avoir une ocutf on a un
délai de 30 jours pour quitter le
territoire et on doit quitter
l'hébergement 30 dans les 30 jours plus
fin de mois ce qui veut dire qu'on ne le
quitte pas du jour au lendemain ce qui
ce qui m'a dérangé monsieur monsieur de
lappte dans dans votre
entaire c'est que vous mettez en doute
les préfets les préfets qui sont au
quotidien les préfets et sous-préfets le
corps préfectoral que vous remettez en
question qui sont au quotidien
confrontés à ces problématiques là et je
pense et et je pense que vous savez très
bien comment fonctionnent les
préfectures je pense que vous savez très
préfectures de France et je trouve
dommage je trouve dommage d'attaquer le
les préfets et les sous-préfets de cette
manière-là ce que nous proposons là
c'est de garantir que les critères de
vulnérabilité soient respectés et donc
on ne mettra à nouveau personne à la rue
et quand on peut demander aussi un
hébergement spécifique quand on est
frappé d'une TF et qu'on souhaite
quitter le territoire national il y a
des hébergements spécifiques pour
préparer le voyage c'est aussi une
réalité qui a été mis en place par
l'État ça fonctionne aussi on ne dit pas
aujourd'hui qu'on veut mettre tout le
monde dehors on d'ailleurs on a interdit
le fait de les sortir de des
hébergements d'urgence ça démontre juste
une chose c'est que quand on est débouté
du droit d'asile et qu'on sait qu' on a
débouté définitivement on n rien à faire
dans un hébergement qui correspond à un
demandeur d'asile c'est tout ce qui est
écrit dans ce texte et nous garantissons
des critères de vulnérabilité pour être
certain qu'on puisse pas expulser la
personne comme ça du jour au lendemain
alors qu'elle est ultra vulnérable voilà
ce que nous vous proposons avec cet
amendement merci Madame
genev merci monsieur le Président je
suis un peu surprise de l'amendement de
notre rapporteur parce que vous dites
qu'on se fondera dans l'appréciation de
la situation sur la vulnérabilité de la
personne
semblant considérer qu'il y a des
personnes vulnérables et d'autres qu'ils
ne sont pas je vous rappelle qu'à
l'article 15 vous avez attaché à chaque
étranger la qualification la qualité de
personnes
vulnérabl les irrégul oui mais là c'est
bien les irréguliers dont il est
question
déb débouter du droit d'asile déb as bon
allez c'est plus un dialogue on met au
voix l'amendement de monsieur le
rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote contre
Monsieur lean vous étiez compté quandême
pour donc la non est
adopté non c'est c'est bon madame
Diaz le
423 ah attendez il est peut-être non il
est pas tombé allez-y madame
Diaz allez-y ah c'est bon oui merci
monsieur le Président donc par cet
amendement il estosé de permettre
l'évacuation de l'occupant d'un lieu
d'hébergement pour demandeur d'asile en
cas de manquement par celui-ci au
règlement du D lieu en clair quand on
est accueilli on se tient bien on
respecte les lieux comme le personnel et
si on décide de violer le règlement
intérieur on en assume les conséquences
à savoir prendre le risque d'être
expulsé mon le
rapporteur
défavorable mais
euh je sais plus quoi dire quoi parce
que franchement c'est c'est tellement
c'est tellement ignoble ignoble mais non
on peut pas je je je sais plus de quel
quel argument trouver pour essayer
d'éveiller d'éveiller en vous ce qu'il
pourrait rester
d'humanité parce que là franchement on
parle de demandeur d'asile alors bon je
sais pas de quel règlement de quel
règlement il s'agit exactement bon voilà
quoi est-ce que si on met la musique
trop fort bon ben voilà allez bam craque
allez toujours le truc c'est les mettre
dehors les mettre à la porte d'ailleurs
vous avez des mots sans débarrasser les
dégager mais réveillez un peu l'humanité
qui est en vous je l'espère bon madame
Diaz vous répondez et alors après je
vous préviens non non mais madame Diaz
juste avant avant que vous répondiez
après je n'accepterai les interventions
qui sont seulement en lien avec les
amendements parce que normalement c'est
c'est ce que je devrais faire depuis le
départ je vous laisse débattre de façon
extensive
vous réagissez à tout et n'importe quoi
ce ne sera plus le cas
bientôt sur
l'amend merci monsieur le Président mais
notre
amendement est un amendement de bon sens
vous êtes hébergé dans un lieu il y a un
règlement intérieur vous décidez de
violer le règlement intérieur c'est
normal qu'il y ait des sanctions et moi
je m'étonne que les macronistes vous
ayez US cet amendement de mon sens et je
ne suis pas surprise de la réaction de
l'anupes qui comme d'habitude verse dans
la culture de l'excuse ESS de trouver
des raisons pour justifier ce laxisme et
en fait chez laanupes on a une seule
chose c'est la culture de
l'anarchie de
l'anarchieanarchie je mets au voix
l'amendement 423 qui vot
pour
re amendement suivant le 750 madame
Martin
bon alors nous portons un amendement de
suppression de cet article 20 parce que
au travers de ces modifications qui
peuvent paraître fort satisfaisantes
puisque la logique est affiché et de
rapprocher les demandeurs de protection
via la demande d'asile des dispositifs
qui vont leur permettre de d'attribuer
éventuellement ce statut de réfugié si
particulier deux choses nous paraissent
poser problème et
entamer un examen qui soit un examen de
qualité de ce type de demande ce qui est
évidemment absolument nécessaire le
premier c'est cette localisation
relocalisation
déconcentration je ne sais comment dire
de la Cour nationale du droit d'asile
mais cela suppose si cela rapproche les
gens de cette cours cela supposerait
qu'il y ait dans les territoires comme
on dit parfois des avocats spécialisés
parce que ça demande des avocats
spécialisés et des interprètes et il est
bien évident que nous ne pouvons pas
amendement suivant monsieur de la
porte oui merci c'est un article
important qui a été notamment dénoncé
par la Défenseur des droits puisqu'il
fait finalement de la collégialité
l'exception alors que ça devrait être la
norme c'est cela là le véritable
problème et ça comme le dirait donc la
Défenseur des droits ça constitue une
étape supplémentaire dans l'approche
comptable de la justice dédiée au
demandeurs d'asile or étant susceptible
de priver les requérants des garanties
procédurales fondamentales d'une justice
équitaable que sont l'indépendance et
l'impartialité du juge les restrictions
au principe de la collégialité devrai
être strictement limité voilà j'en
arrêterai là pour vous dire à ce stade
qu'il y a une opposition extrêmement
forte de la part des membres des
juridictions et de la CNDA notamment et
nous sommes régulièrement saisis par des
assesseurs par des juges qui sont très
inquiets mais aussi par des avocats bref
l'ensemble des partis vous demande de
renoncer à cela madame
regol monsieur le Président le groupe
écologiste nup s'oppose aussi à la
réforme des CND et donc demande la
suppression de cet article d'une part
parce que les affaires que traite les
juges sont très complexes et nécessitent
des échanges collégiaux pour arriver à
avancer pour atterrir pour décider pour
partager parce que ce sont
essentiellement des audiences des
contentieux où l'oral est
particulièrement
sollicité on s'appuie aussi dans ce
choix sur les différentes décisions
propositions en tout cas la Défenseur
des droits qui rappelle que sans moyens
sans accompagnement comme des
interprètes des avocats des associations
il y a un risque de fragil iser le droit
un recours que le président des
rapporteurs de la CNDA est aussi très
dur dessus qui rappelle que la
collégialité permet d'assurer un débat
utile pour la prise de
décision et même si on prend un are
point de vue l'association forum
réfugiier qui rappelle que la
collégialité est un élément clé pour une
justice équitable bref quel que soit le
point de vue cette absence de
collégialité ce juge unique est un souci
pour le bon respect des droits et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous vous
demandons de supprimer cette amendement
monsieur le
rapporteur
défavorable monsieur le ministre al je
ah pardon je me permettrais non mais je
voudrais juste me permettre je crois que
vu le nombre d'amendements on aura le
temps d'en débattre de cet article lire
une partie c'est l'ALA 19 à moins que de
sa propre initiative ou à la demande du
récurrent le président de la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile ou le
président de formation de jugement
désigné à cette fin ne décide à tout
moment de la procédure d'inscrire
l'affaire devant une formation
collégiale le requérant le requérant
lui-même peut refuser le le juge unique
nous sommes en train de mettre en
place il sera oui madame régol
laissez-moi terminer au moins mon
argumentaire par principe chaque
ressortissant est informé de ses droits
que ce soit par le système associatif ou
par d'autres personnes pouvez pas dire
que ce n'est pas le cas ils sont pris en
charge même par leur avocat la rité là
donc ils connaissent leur droit on leur
dit leur droit la réalité c'est qu'on va
mettre en place les cours
départementales à partir de là on aura
aussi des besoins sp spécifique et on
n'ura pas le HCR de présent partout
d'ailleurs nous l'avons auditionné la
semaine dernière et le HCR ne dit pas
qu'il est contre il dit que ça doit pas
être un principe fondamental et qu'on
doit garantir qu'il y ait une
possibilité de collégialité c'est
exactement ce qu' nous a dit c'est ce
que propose le texte on ne dit pas qu'il
y aura que le juge unique on dit c'est
la le juge unique qui devient la norme
mais la collégialité existe toujours et
elle peut changer à n'importe quel
moment ce qui veut dire que si le juge
décide que l'affaire est trop compliquée
en juge unique il le portera en collég
si le recurrant ou son avocat décide que
ça doit pas être pris en décision de
juge unique il le portera en
collégialité le texte est du cet article
est équilibré dans le respect des droits
et s'opposer et demander à le supprimer
est une erreur fondamentale donc
défavorable madame Martin
oui comme ça on va pouvoir terminer
parce que je pense quand même que c'est
quelque chose de fondamental donc il y a
la question des ressources à l'échelle
locale mais il y a évidemment la
généralisation du juge unique puisque ça
tombe bien on a déjà
du recul par rapport à ça et on peut
déjà constater que quand il n'y a pas de
représentants du HCR puisque c'est eux
effectivement ces représentants là qui
vont sauter on perd de la collégialité
dans l'instruction mais on perd de la
compétence aussi parce que c'est du côté
du HCR qui a une connaissance précise de
la situation dans les pays dont sont
issues les personnes or on a besoin de
ça et puis si on voulait aborder la
question des deniers publics qui après
tout n'est pas une moindre question ça
va coûter une petite fortune cette
affaire là donc ça va coûter une petite
fortune pour des instructions qui seront
moins bonne et moins garante du droit
bon c'est quand même c'est quand même
bien dommage foutons la paix à la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile laissons les
demandeurs d'asile faire faire le chemin
et ça sera très bien comme ça je mets au
vo les amendements de suppression qui
vote pour pardon
excuse-mo
merci en fait ce qu'on vient de vous
expliquer monsieur le rapporteur et sur
à quoi vous n'avez pas répondu c'est que
l'exception devient la règle
c'est-à-dire
que la possibilité de déroger au juge
unique devient l'exception et que tout
repose sur la bonne information du
requérant ou des requérants or toutes
les études qu'on a sur les les Français
qui sont justiciables démontrent qu'ils
ont une connaissance partielle du droit
et pour cause on nenseigne pas le droit
à l'école il faut faire des études
supérieures spécifiques dédié au droit
pour le connaître et donc vous demandez
à des personnes qui sont dans une
situation fragile qui arrive de faire ça
accompagner très bien alors pourquoi
aucune ligne budgétaire ne vient
renforcer l'accompagnement en question
il n'y a pas dans le texte que vous nous
donnez de moyen affectés au au CNDA il y
a pas de moyen supplémentaires il y a
pas de d'interprète il y a pas d'
accpagnant si effectivement votre
réponse est sincère et fondée alors
dites-nous à quel moment il y a des
moyens affectés pour accompagner donc
cette fois on vote qui vote pour vot
contre rejeté amendement suivant Madame
Dupont défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je mets au voix qui vot pour
contre rejeté le 747 on continue donc
sur cette affaire en zoomant sur la
question de la territorialisation en
insistant sur le fait que l'on va
manquer et que les demandeurs d'asile
manqueront d'interprètes et d'avocats
spécialisés ce qui est absolument
nécessaire pour que les choses puissent
bien se passer pour les demandeurs
d'asile par ailleurs on un point plus un
point ça finit quand même par faire une
ligne et on a bien vu cette volonté de
développer la vidéo conférence et ça
aussi ça nous pose problème on ne peut
pas se défendre devant ce type de cours
avec encore une fois la de récit qui est
absolument centrale avec des questions
extrêmement précises qui sont posées moi
j'ai vu dans le cadre d'un d'un juge
unique ce juge unique interrogait un
Afghan pour vérifier qu'il venait bien
du village X et lui demander si la
maison à droite de la sortie je je vous
garantis que c'est vrai quoi était bien
bleu bon vous comprenez bien qu'on a
absolument besoin que que la personne
perçoivent les questions qui lui sont
posées qui quelqu'un pour les tro dur et
C merci Mad Martin
le suivant le 709 Monsieur
nagelen Merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement il est il est
relativement simple on est
fondamentalement pour la
territorialisation et ce qu'on demande
c'est de modifier la linée 6 pour que
les chambres soient spécialisées en
fonction des zones géographiques il faut
une connaissance des conflits des
tensions politiques nationales des pays
concernés pour évaluer le sérieux de la
demande d'asile et une chambre
spécialisé sur une zone gagne en
efficacité comme elle traite des mêmes
des mêmes dossiers vous le mettez dans
l'alinéa 8 il peut en outre spécialiser
les chambres en fonction du pays
d'origine et donc utiliser nous on
demande à modifier laalgéa 6 pour que de
fait ces chambr puissent être spécialisé
pour avoir une comme son comme son nom
l'indique une vraie spécialisation
madame regol le
1020 merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement de repli vise tout simplement
à enfin ce s'occupe de la question des
chambres territorialisées et vis
simplement à s'assurer que leur
territorialisation ne se fasse pas
encore une fois et comme trop souvent au
détriment des territoires
ultraarins monsieur neigelen le 707
monsieur serva vous le défendez mon le
président oui pour rebondir sur ce qui
viennent d'être dit par les deux
collègues je trouve que la
visioconférence c'est bien mais le
contact physique c'est mieux entre le
demandeur d'asile et le juge d'autant
plus
que en areomère il y a 3000 demandes par
année de demande d'asile c'est quand
même important et nous souhaitons que
d'une façon d'une autre peut-être en
séance nous arrivions à trouver une
solution concernant cette situation pour
les ultramariss alors vous n'étiez pas
signataire donc c'est monsieur nagelen
qui vous défendez le deuxième Alley
merci monsieur le Président en fait
c'est une demande un peu comme on
l'avait fait d'ailleurs sur la liste des
mé en tenstion on demander une
départementalisation là on demande une
véritable territorialisation de la CNDA
à l'image de ce qui existe avec la cour
des et son réseau de chambre régionale
et et territoriale et actuellement la
couverture du territoire national tant
l'Hexagone que les outr maire n'est pas
précisé par le texte donc nous on
demande réellement un réel déploiement
territorial la aujourd'hui tout est
concentré à Montreuil alors Montreuil
c'est très beau j'en ai aucun doute mais
à un moment donné ce serait quand même
plus légitime et plus logique qu'on ait
une réelle répartition sur le territoire
hexagonal et des outrmers monsieur le
rapporteur
merci président alors on a quatre
amendements qui sont quand même
totalement différents sur le premier ça
va être dé favorable et je voudrais
juste rassurer notre notre collègue
Elisa Martin pour dire que dans la
réforme aujourd'hui des décisions de la
CNDA qu'il soit en juge unique ou en
collégialité c'est équivalent il y a pas
un surplus de
réforme de la décision de la CNDA en
juge unique donc il y a aucun problème
par rapport à
ça territorialisation des chambres et
bien un avantage pour le demandeur et
cela n'empêche pas on prend un exemple
tout bête il sera plus simple demain
pour quelqu'un qui est à Tarbe d'aller à
Bordeaux au lieu de venir à Montreuil il
sera plus simple pour quelqu'un de camp
de venir à à Paris que de de se déplacer
à Lille il y a ces réalités qu'on doit
prendre en considération donc tout ça
sera pris en considération dans la
réforme et je pense que ce que vous
proposez comme tout à l'heure de
supprimer l'article ou de supprimer
l'aliné ne répond pas à vos attentes
donc
défavorable sur le l'amendement de
Monsieur nelen sur le 709
je vous renvoie la Liga 8 de l'article
20 qui prévoit que le président de la
cenda peut en outre spécialiser les
chambres en fonction du pays d'origine
et des langues utilisées je ne pense pas
que ça soit à nous législateurs de de le
faire directement dans ce texte de loi
on risquerait de le contraindre et ça
serait contreproductif je vous propose
un retrait ou un avis défavorable
monsieur négelen parce que je pense
qu'il faut laisser à la CNDA le fait de
s'organiser et de définir par exemple on
peut prendre la cour d'appel de Nancy la
cour d'appel administratif de Nancy et
là on a peut-être besoin de d'avoir plus
de besoins de réponse sur le les Afghans
par exemple que à Bordeaux il faut qu'on
prenne ça en considération et ça c'est à
la CNDA de choisir et de spécialiser ses
cours départemental sur la
l'amendement 1020 de de Monsieur Lucas
c'est un débat
intéressant mais en l'état chaque
collectivité territoriale d'outre mère
est numérale 2 de l'article c'est pas
possible et d'ailleurs on a eu un débat
sur Mayotte où même les les les juges de
la CNDA nous disaient ne le faites pas
ne mettez pas de cours départemental à
Mayotte parce que parce qu'il y a des
complications c'est très spécifique donc
on est prêt à en débattre peut-être pour
la séance mais en l'état l'écriture ne
peut pas aller sur ce que vous proposez
sur le numéro 707 à nouveau monsieur
néelen la précision que vous ajoutez qui
n'est présenté que comme une possibilité
n'apporte pas vraiment d'élément
nouveaux par rapport au texte qui prévoi
la possibilité de créer des chambres
territoriales en l'état du texte elles
peuvent évidemment être placées auprès
de chaque cour administrative en l'état
je vous suggère de le retirer ou alors
de un avis défavorable donc sur les
quatre articles soit un avis défavorable
soit un avis de retrait et
ouvert au débat de la porte oui merci je
souhaiterais et bon c'est dommage que le
ministre soit pas là mais peut-être que
le rapporteur pourra nous le dire et ça
permettra de d'éclairer la
représentation nationale avoir un peu
plus d'éléments sur cette organisation
territoriale prévu à l'alinéa 6 parce
qu'il y a des inquiétudes par exemple
dans mon département à quand on dépend
de la Cour administrative d'appel de
Nantes or c'est plus simple de se rendre
depuis quand à Montreuil par exemple
canante et pour les avocats ça voudrait
dire partir pendant 2 jours si les
avocats canés ou ça voudrait dire que
les personnes qui sont jugées à la CNDA
dans la chambre territoriale n'auraient
plus d'avocat sur place c'est-à-dire à
quand et donc vous voyez le type de
complexité que ceci peut engendrer donc
j'aimerais avoir voilà des précisions
là-dessus et par ailleurs l'autre
inquiétude qui existe c'est celle
finalement d'une moindre
spécialisation des des juges et qui
prendrait moins en compte aussi
l'individualité des situations madame
regol merci monsieur le Président
j'entends vos arguments monsieur le
rapporteur j'entends que vous êtes prêt
à à trouver des solutions mais la
formulation de l'amendement de mon cègue
Lucas est assez clair c'est pas une
liste à la Prévert ça reprend les textes
qui sont les ntres afin d'avoir quelque
chose de clair euh donc la seule demande
qu'il y a derrière c'est d'avoir une
assurance qui est pas une inégalité
territoriale il me semble que votre
réponse n'apporte aucune assurance en
dehors de circuler il y a rien à voir ce
qui n'est pas en soi une assurance
madame
Martin je reviens sur l'affaire de d'une
forme de spécialisation par géographie
les les Afghans à Nancy bah dans ce
cas-là conservons la centralité de la
CNDA à montreil estce qu'on a gagné si
le Marseille si l'Afghan est à Marseille
et qui doit aller jusqu'à Nancy et
traverser la France qu'encore une fois à
Nancy va se poser la problème de la non
mais peu importe oui bah si vous voulez
jeis pas moi je vais vous dire les
Ukrainiens ah non les Ukrainiens c'est
réglé bon je ne sais trop quel
nationalité je ne sais où c'est pareil
autant conserver une centralité à
Montreuil et y compris n'oubliez pas
qu'il y a la question des ressources les
avocats les interprètent et ça sera plus
facile monsieur le rapporteur
Gén rapporteur je voulais juste revenir
sur la partie madame ce quie problème
c'est que vous dites que dans chaque
collectivité il devra avoir une cour
territoriale là je propose de travailler
monsieur qui d'ailleurs sur la partiere
va nous proposer quelque chose on
échange justement sur le sujet je
propose de vous rapprocher de de
travailler ensemble sur une potentielle
écriture je pense qu'on peut vraiment
atterrir sur quelque chose là enétat la
formulation ne nous convient
pas monsieur rappage oui quelques
quelques éléments peut-être à ce débat
qui est extrêmement important parce
qu'effectivement nous avons eu des
auditions importantes sur ce sujet au
cours des dernières semaines je pense
qu'elles nous ont considérablement
éclairé d'abord je je ne comprends pas
le point de vue que certains d'entre
vous ont
exprimé
concernant la la territorialisation mais
c'est c'est un rapprochement vis-à-vis
du requérant c'est un rapprochement
important disait tout à l'heure le le
requérant le demandeur d'asile
vulnérable qui au titre de la
répartition nationale a été est placé en
cada à poau bah il doit aller donc deux
fois euh en région parisienne une fois à
fontené pour
l'OFPRA et ensuite il doit le faire
aussi à la CNDA ce sont des personnes
parfois très vulnérables on on leur
impose par conséquent deux déplacements
vous êtes donc contre la la solution de
rapprochement nous voulons voilà
deuxièmement est-ce que nous sommes euh
comment dire est-ce que nous sommes en
train de contrevenir à une règle qui
s'appliquerait partout dans l'Union
européenne nous sommes le seul pays à
nous sommes le seul pays en Europe à
disposer d'une justice centralisée et
unique tous les autres États de l'Union
européenne et ils subissent également
des phénomènes migratoires ça leur
arrive bon donc de ce point de V moi
j'avoue que je ne comprends pas la
prudence que vous que vous évoquez et
puis sur sur la collégialité le le
rapporteur a eu tout à fait raison de
rappeler les les conditions je vais pas
le faire y compris d'ailleurs par le
requérant lui-même le demandeur c'est
extrêmement important qui est accompagné
qui est accompagné qui est accompagné
par un avocat je je nous connaissons
tous d'ailleurs des structures
associatives qui savent très bien
accompagner les requérants concernés
donc je je je pense qu'ils seront tout à
fait au courant de la possibilité de de
le faire d'autres pays d'autres pays je
pense c'est l'Allemagne je pense à la
Belgique font la même chose exactement
la même chose vous avez pas du HCR il
sera présent tout le temps en
collégialité mais par contre nous sommes
le seul pays au monde le seul pays au
monde à associé systématiquement y
compris systématiquement le HR bon donc
là ce qui sera important pour nous c'est
à la fois le rapprochement vis-à-vis du
demandeur ça c'est extrêmement
protecteur et puis deuxièmement le
passage en collégialité quand il y aura
des cas d'espèce particuliers un Afghan
est-ce qu'il est est nécessaire de
passer par la collégialité pour traiter
de la situation d'un ressortissant de
nationalité
afghane ils obtiennent l'asile à 92
% et donc il est tout à fait normal de
pouvoir passer par le juge unique un
ressortissant issu d'une nationalité
d'un pays où l'on sait qu'il n'y a aucun
risque ni discrimination et qu'il il a
une volonté parce que ça arrive madame
de détournement de la demande d'asile il
faut passer par la collégialité non nous
nous nous rejoignons simplement des
standards européens plus ni moins et
nous rapprochons nous rapprochons le
juge du demandeur d'asile y compris donc
les plus vulnérables lorsqu'ils seront
obligés lorsqu'ils sont obligés
aujourd'hui de de faire deux
déplacements en région parisienne nous
irons vers la proximité cela me paraît
beaucoup plus
protecteur alle monsieur nagelen très
très rapidement juste pour dire que nous
on trouve que l'article l'amendement
1020 de notre collègue Lucas est
intéressant et juste pour revenir par
rapport à tout ce que vient de dire le
rapporteur général Ben justement notre
amendement notre amendement 709 permet
en créant des cours spécialisés par
rapport à l'origine à l'origine des
personnes d'avoir plutôt quand vous
preniez les exemples géographiques et
ben au moins peu importe quelqu'un
d'origine afghane peu importe où elle
est sur le territoire elle ira dans une
chambre bien définie avec des magistrats
qui seront spécialisés sur cette zone
géographique et idem et idem pour
quelqu'un qui vient d'un autre pays par
exemple d'Europe de l'Est où le contexte
économique le contexte politique est
différent et au moins ce sera là aussi
une une zone spécialisée donc il y a
rapporteur général non mais si si votre
intention est de faire que
chaque territorialisation soit
spécialisée sur par exemple une
nationalité bien sûr que non parce que
là nous nous nous sers en train de
recréer de la centralité dans chaque
territoire ça n'a aucun sens en réalité
ce qui est certain c'est que là où il y
a des besoins spécifiques en fonction de
la nature des migratoire évidemment que
chaque entité territorialisée va
s'organiser en fonction donc il y aura
une spécialisation en en considération
du contexte de chaque territoire
concerné bien sûr je mets au voix les
amendements successifs le 747 VI
défavorable quiêtre pour
contre rejeté le 1000 le 709 avis
défavorable qui vote pour
contre qui vre pour pour
pour qui vote
contre il est rejeté le 1020 qui vote
pour contre rejeté et le dernier avec un
avis défavorable également qui vote pour
contre
rejeté le suivant le 64 madame regol je
vous propose de défendre le 64 et le
1024 ça vous convient monsieur le
Président oui je savais que j'aurais une
réponse très positive de votre part ça
aborde deux aspects le prier le
64 rappelle pourquoi le juge unique est
un souci par exemple on va prendre le
cas de ce juge qui est désigné dans une
décision du Conseil d'État du 31 octobre
dernier vous voyez c'est pas vieux et
qui est mise en cause pour ses positions
xénophobes LGBTQI phobe et islamophobe
il est quand même assez dangereux je
pense qu'on sera toutes et tous d'accord
dessus quel que soit notre pour dire que
ce juge unique là peut poser un problème
et que seul la collégialité permet
d'assurer que les droits des requérents
soit bien respecté le second amendement
le 1024 donc vise à rappeler qu'il est
préférable de conserver la
disposition de la désignation des juges
assesseurs tel qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui c'està-dire une nomination
par le représentant du HCR sur avis
conforme du Conseil d'État et non pas de
le transformer
monsieur le
rapporteur
défavorable sur le cas par exemple que
vous citez dans votre exposé dans votre
exposé des motifs exposé sommaire je
rappelle que le doute sur son appartiété
envers les immigrés les musons et la com
communauté LGBT plus a permis au
président de la CNDA de le
retirer de le mettre de côté donc de
facto il y a une organisation interne
qui fait que la personne est déplacée ou
ne puisse pas juger l'écriture que vous
proposez sur le caractère impartial sur
le le le juge le côté impartial pose une
véritable problématique en terme de
rédaction donc rien pour cette ce mot-là
je ne pourrais pas donner un avis
favorable madame rgol c'est un sujet qui
a interprétation beaucoup trop trop dure
et et là il y a trop de risque donc
défavorable sur le 64 et sur le 1024 que
vous avez défendu on est sur la même
logique en avis
défavorable parce que en cas
d'expression d'opinion hostile le
président de la CNDA peut parfaitement
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent
sans qu'une disposition
passe obligatoirement par la loi et je
pense qu'on doit aussi faire confiance à
Cees représentants qui sont des
magistrats M r
oui ben j'entends votre argument
monsieur le rapporteur sur l'article 64
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec le mot
impartial je vous propose donc de
changer ce mot-là et de trouver le bon
pour que nous puissions faire passer cet
amendement merci monsieur le Président
décidément la nupes alimente la
suspicion à l'égard de beaucoup de
fonctions ou de professions il y a
quelques jours c'était les maires les
chargés de TD les fonctionnaires et
aujourd'hui ce sont les juges dont vous
remettez en cause la partialité et pour
lesquelles vous instrumentalisez un fait
divers mais il s'agit là d'une dérive
inquiétante parce que permettez-moi de
vous rappeler qu'en France le politique
ne choisit pas les juges en fonction de
ses affinités politiques et heureusement
que tous les juges n'appartiennent pas
au Syndicat de la magistrature alors moi
je voudrais euh vous rappeler notre
attachement à une valeur éminemment
républicaine c'est que en France on ne
Baffou pas l'indépendance de la
justice enfin Madame
torinia on est excusez-moi le problème
de la police c'est la justice n'est-ce
pas vous laissez parler madame torinia
alors excusez-moi monsieur le Président
je voudrais vous poser une question il y
a 131 amendements restants et il y a
moins de 1 heure je voudrais savoir
comment vous comptez organiser la fin de
la séance si on doit terminer à minuit
ça fait plus de de amendements par
minute est-ce que nous on est prêt à
faire le travail comme il faut parce que
vous voyez qu'on a besoin d'argumenter
les rapporteurs prennent le temps
d'argumenter quand ils le veulent bien
nous on a qu'une minute pour argumenter
mais on est vaillant on essaie de
défendre tous nos amendements on est
prêt à revenir demain matin parce qu'il
est question
d'umité est-ce que vous
allez être raisonnable terminer la
séance à minuit pour que nous puissions
revenir demain matin et continuer le
travail comme il
faut j'ai plutô l'impression que les
collègues ve terminer ce soir et donc on
va continuer d'avancer jusqu'à minuit on
discutera tout cela à minuit donc je
mets au voix l'amendement 64 qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté le 1024 qui
vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté
le 262 je crois que j'ai pas de collèg
de la commission le 65 madame
regol c'est c'est toujours une tentative
de convaincre monsieur le rapporteur
qu'il y a quelque chose à faire pour
aller vers plus de collégialité et moins
de risque sur les droits donc je vais
dire défendu et je vais attendre un peu
plus de réponse de monsieur le
rapporteur madame le 1213 oui toujours
sur
suppression du du juge unique en tout
cas comme unique mode en fait vous nous
expliquez que ça va permettre de de
rendre des décisions plus rapidement
monsieur le rapporteur c'est ce qui est
défendu en tout cas dans les
objectifs de cet article mais j'imagine
que beaucoup à la CNDA vous ont expliqué
que en fait ça ne ferait pas plus
d'audience qu'est-ce qui quel est selon
vous en tout cas sur quelle étude vous
vous basez pour pouvoir nous expliquer
que passer en juge unique au-delà de
toutes les choses que mes collègues vous
ont expliqué et que je partage
c'està-dire que c'est un regard croisé
c'est un contrôle professionnel qu'il y
a beaucoup d'avantages à cette
collégialité pour les professionnels
euxmêm comme pour ceux qui reçoivent la
notification la décision en quoi ça va
aller plus vite ça n'ira pas plus vite
et vous le savez très bien il y aura pas
plus d'audience en même temps donc
arrêtez arrêtez de nous expliquer ça
quel est l'objectif selon sinon
puisqu'il n'y aura pas de rapidité plus
grande monsieur de la porte
oui merci pour aller plus loin que ce
que vient de dire Madame fossillon et je
vois que monsieur le ministre est revenu
il pourra peut-être nous éclairer mais
on a un vrai sujet ici c'est que c'est
pas parce que on a moins de juges que
derrière on accélère les délais
forcément parce que il y a toujours des
interprètes en nombre limité il y a des
greffiers en nombre limité il y a tout
un tas de personnel annexes en nombre
limité et donc finalement on va pas
accélérer comme ça de façon magique
l'audiencement dans un deuxè sujet
monsieur le ministre puisque vous êtes
là je me permets de réitérer ma question
est-ce que vous pourriez nous éclairer
sur la géographie envisager des CNDA
parce que ça aussi ça aura une influence
sur la capacité à réduire et pour
répondre enfin monsieur le rapporteur à
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure bien
sûr que si quand vous passez d'une norme
à une exception la collégialité vous
êtes dans un recul des droits et
notamment des droits fondamentaux au
procès équitable Madame Dupont le
suivant merci monsieur le Président euh
chers collègues notre collègue madame
regol vient d'évoquer un fait concernant
un juge euh en 2000 début 2019 je suis
allée à CNDA j'ai assisté à différentes
audiences et par hasard je me suis
trouvée dans la salle d'audience de ce
juge je j'ai constaté moi-même euh le
caractère Xen FOB de ce
monsieur je suis allée le signaler à la
présidente de la cour puisque c'était
une présidente à l'époque et et il a
fallu beaucoup de temps avant que ce
juge soit démis de ses fonctions donc le
fait de passer un juge unique m'alerte
aujourd'hui même si j'y suis pas opposé
fondamentalement lorsque je lis l'alinéa
19 mais je voudrais une précision s'il
vous plaît messieurs les rapporteurs
l'alé à 19 je lis le début seulement il
est indiqué qu'à moins que de sa propre
initiative ou à la demande du requérant
le président de la Cour nationale du
droit d'asile ou le président de la
formation de jugement désigne désigné à
cette fin ne décide à tout moment de la
procédure collégiale et Madame Dupont le
la demande où à la demande du réquérant
la demande du requérant n'est pas de
droit c'est toujours le président qui
décide en définitive on devrait
sécuriser cela alors messieurs les
rapporteurs vos avis oui mais je vous
donner une 30 quoi donc défavorable ça
sera défavorable alors je rappelle juste
que comme n disait le le président est
Rondard pour le taux de cassation et
celui de protection accordé à
nationalité égale sont sensiblement les
mêmes pour les décisions prises en
formation collégiale comme en formation
à juge unique la proposition qui est
faite c'est quand même de permettre
d'aller plus vite en terme de réponse
pour le requérant je rappelle que sur
les 5 dernières années en plus des des
des affaires en cours il y a 30000
affaires en stock et ce sont des
personnes qui attendent une décision de
la CNDA c'est inhumain de les laisser
dans cette situation là là l'article 20
est équilibré par rapport à tout ce que
vous demandez vous êtes satisfait par
rapport à votre demande vous souhaitez
juste que dans cette loi il soit ajouté
des choses qui seront
superfitatoire
défavorable monsieur le
ministre
alors peut-être pour répondre très
rapidement aux questions qui ont été
posées monsieur de la porte ça va
s'adosser pardon au cours d'appel
administrative donc là où il y aura des
cours là où il y a des cours d'appel
administrativ il y
aura il y aura des CNDA territorialisés
à l'exception d' l'îledefrance où il y a
déjà Montreuil j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure que vous évoquez la Nouvelle
Calédonie je ne sais pas qui l'a
fait il y a eu trois demandes en
Nouvelle-Calédonie tris demandes d'asile
je je suis pas sûr que voilà dans une
année ça exige une cour d'appel
territorialisée sur le fait que est-ce
qu'il y aura plus d'audience oui il y
aura plus d'audiences ces audiences sont
plus facilement à organiser les
audiences seront plus rapides je
rappelle d'ailleurs c'est un argument
qui a été très peu répété mais c'est le
même taux de protection exactement le
même taux de protection parce que le le
juge unique existe déjà
aujourd'hui non mais voilà il existe
déjà aujourd'hui c'est déjà énormément
et donc le la la question qui se pose
c'est est-ce qu'il y avait une
différence de traitement finalement
entre ces dossiers non c'est le même
taux de protection pour les mêmes
nationalités que ce soit collégiale ou
que ce soit que ce soit unique alors
pour répondre à la question de Madame
Dupont et pour être tout à fait honnête
avec vous le président décide si c'est
nécessaire ou pas vous avez bien lu le
l'alinéa 19 le requérant peut demander
la collégialité et elle n'est pas de
droit par principe en effet voilà voilà
c'est tout c'est tout à fait vrai mais
quel quel est le but et notamment vous
savez bien madame Dupont que la CNDA
c'est une organisation que regarde
particulièrement le Conseil d'État pour
des raisons que chacun comprend donc ce
texte il est passé au au Tami du Conseil
d'État le Conseil d'État il a fait des
observations qui étaient très cohérentes
sur lequelle d'ailleurs nous avons
beaucoup travaillé en amont avec lui
pour savoir s'il était d'accord
surganation que nous lu proposons la
seule remarque que nous fait le Conseil
d'État dans l'étude d'impact et dans la
vie c'est voilà une partie de ce que
vous faites est en fait du domaine
réglementaire grosso modo c'est à nous
organiser puisquévidemment après on
présente nos décrets en en avis au
Conseil d'État nous nous pensons que
c'est assez normal que ce soit le
législateur qui décide de ce qu'il faut
faire pour la CNDA puisque évidemment le
Conseil d'État je ne dirais pas qu'il
est jugé parti sur cette question mais
quand il va regarder les décrets
d'organisation évidemment il a un
pouvoir plus fort il n'a pas remis en
cause du tout l'organisation et compris
de Junique il a même plutôt parfois
suscité vous l'avez vu sans doute dans
vos auditions et dans le rapport Stal
qui avait été rendu voilà quelques
années pourquoi nous faisons ça madame
Dupont c'est parce que comme l'a très
bien dit tout à l'heure monsieur
rapporteur général il y a des décisions
qui méritent et pour avoir reçu
plusieurs fois le HR je peux en
témoigner que le le représent du HR le
dit lui-même qu'il y a des rions qui
sont qui sont collégiales parce qu'elles
sont importantes pour fixer la
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État des
nouveaux pays en conflit des nouvelles
zones géographiques en conflit des
nouvelles questions comme l'orientation
sexuelle en conflit qu'il faut trancher
mais une fois comme la comme la
jurisprudence Kabou mais avant la venue
des taliban en Afghanistan qui avait
poussé un peu le la jurispence de la
CNDA puis après il y a des faits qui se
répètent même si les histoires sont
différentes et queil faut toujours un
juge pour regarder ce qui se passe en
effet histoir qui se répète et donc il
faut comprendre la collégialité comme
étant le moment où on juge pour créer la
jurisprudence et pour encadrer les
grands moments évidemment de discussions
avec des changements et le juge unique
bah pour regarder si des cas individuels
de personnes qui rentrent dans cette
grande jurisprudence ne peuvent pas être
bougés ici ou là parce que les gens sont
évidemment chacun avec une histoire
différente mais qui correspond grosso
modo à la même idée quand on a évoqué
lors des premiers jours 93 94 %
d'Afghans qui avaient l'asile
franchement c'est faire perdre du temps
il compris d'afgan asile d'aller devant
la SC collégiale quand on voit que les
Comores c'est 6 % de l'asile bah ça fait
perdre du temps à tout le monde que les
comorien passent devant une cour
collégiale on a très bien compris que
l'un l'aurait que l'autre l'aurait pas
voilà donc il faut pas y voir malice et
je pense que c'est effectivement quelque
chose d'important mais moi j'ai voulu
être honnête dans la réponse que j'ai pu
vous
faire bien monsieur de la porte
monsieur le ministre juste pour
continuer sur cette territorialisation
ce que je disais tout à l'heure c'est
que la Cour administrative d'appel don
dépend mon département le calvado c'est
Nant Nant c'est 5h Paris c'est 2h Paris
c'est mieux relié finalement que
beaucoup de cours d'appel si vous prenez
le Nord enfin voyez bien la cour d'appel
elle est pas hyper centrale cour
administrative d'appel donc mais je
parle ici de quand où on va faire que
les gens se déplacent pendant 2 jours je
sais pas si ce cas se rencontre ailleurs
en France mais c'est vrai que monreuil
c'était beaucoup plus simple notamment
pour des personnes qui sont vulnérables
mais aussi pour les avocats notamment
les avocats de
proximité merci au ministre d'avoir été
clair effectivement donc le le la
demande peut-être formulée par le
réquérant mais la décision ne s'impose
pas au président de la cour je l'entends
je le comprends comme ça donc le
requérant n' n'a pas la main il peut le
seulement mais n'a pas la main de de la
du caractère collégial de de cette
course que j'entends ce que je comprends
mais je je reste réservé quant à cette
décision et cette perspective quand bien
même elle est utile comme vous le dites
monsieur le ministre dans un certain
nombre de cas bien
évidemment alors le 65 avis défavorable
qui vote pour contre rejeté le 1213 avis
défavorable qui vot pour contre rejeté
et les amendements identiques avis
défavorable pour pour contre rejeté le
1248 madame
Rousseau il s'agit d' amendement qui
vise à garantir la présence de personnes
qualifiées sur les migrations
climatiques ou environnementales et sur
les violences subies par les femmes
migrantes dans les formation de jugement
de la Cour nationale du droit d'asile
c'est absolument indispensable compte
tenu du fait que neuf femmes migrantes
sur 10 ont subis de violences sexuelles
et que le nombre de réfugiés climatiques
pourrait s'accroître à hauteur de
plusieurs C
dans les Ann àenir monsieur le
rapporteur je vois près je vois bien où
vous voulez aller et je comprends je
comprends aussi parce que c'est votre
engagement sauf que là en l'état par
exemple la notion de réfugié climatique
n'existe pas donc il y a toutes ces
réalités et ça pourrait être
contreproductif par rapport à ce que
vous voulez mettre en place discutons
peut-être ensemble sur le sujet pour la
suite mais en l'état moi je ne peux pas
le prendre et je ne suis pas certain
franchement madame Rousseau que ça
puisse vraiment servir à la cause que
voulez défendre je me vois qui vot pour
contre rejeté le 66 Monsieur Madame
madame r que vous pour le défend le 66
défendu défendu le 742 madame Tor madame
Martin je pense que vous avez compris he
ce qu'on ce qu'on ce qu'on cherche à
faire on cherche à à garantir qu'il y
ait une représentation du HCR parce que
pour nous c'est absolument fondamental
par ailleurs monsieur darin vous avez
dit qu'après tout euh la la la la
noncollégialité pouvait être pertinente
pour des situations qu'à priori on
connaît et il y a effectivement la
question des afghan où 92 % d'entre eux
se voi apporter le statut de réfugié
tout à l'heure je sais pas si vous étiez
là ou pas je vous en fais pas le
reproche ça pas l'importance j'ai eu
l'occasion d'assister à à des formations
collégiales ou à des formation non
collégiale sur la sur la la l'anecdote
que j'évoquais du je juge qui demandait
à un Afghan en l'occurrence si au sortir
de son village du côté droit il y avait
bien une maison vous êtes d'accord avec
moi céit un Afghan et c'était bien un
juge unique donc vous voyez c'est je
crois que c'est pas ça le souci le souci
c'est que au travers de la collégialité
d'abord on s'inscrit dans une certaine
tradition française ça date de 1952 ça
veut dire que dès qu'on a mis en œuvre
la Convention de Genève sous cet angle
là on a eu ce réflexe de collégialité on
a eu cette idée selon laquelle il
fallait qu'on s'appuie sur les
compétences du HCR tout simplement parce
que c'est des gens qui connaissent
parfaitement bien les situations
danspporte alors c'est pas ce que
demande le HR lors de son audition et la
nomination sur proposition du HR me
paraît pertinente et je ne doute pas que
ces propositions seront suivies par le
Conseil d'État donc
défavorable monsieur de la porte oui
écoutez moi je je vous dis que j'ai été
sollicité par des assesseurs du HR à la
CNDA et qu'ils disent que c'est un
véritable recul puisque ces assesseurs
sont indépendants particulièrement
sensibles au respect du droit
internationale en matière d'asile et que
finalement cette nomination par le
Conseil d'État ben inverse la logique
totalement alors je mets au voix qui
vote pour le 66 est
identique contre rejeté le 1266 madame
Rosso donc comme pour l'amendement
précédent ça vise à garantir la personne
la la présence de personnes qualifiées
sur les migrations climatiques
environnemental et sur les violences
subies par les femmes migrantes dans les
formations de jugement de la Cour
nationale du droit d'Asie il s'agit pas
d'avoir un statut de réfugié climatique
il s'agit juste de savoir dans quelle
partie du monde il y a des sujets autour
de la montée des eaux de sécheresse ou
de ou ou d'événement climatiques
extrêmes et vraiment dans les années qui
vont venir ce ces phénomènes vont
s'amplifier monsieur rapporteur je
comprends toujours là où vous allez à
nouveau défavorable
je monsieur rapporteur général mais une
précision parce que je ne sais pas si
vous étiez là madame Rousseau et moi non
plus je vous en fais pas le
reproche lorsque nous avons adopté la
demande d'un
rapport sur proposition d'une de nos
collègues du groupe pour le coup
Renaissance engageant justement à aller
vers la
définition et la démarche de ce que
l'État français puisse pousser
lui-même une démarche qui ne peut-être
que internationale c'est pas la NDA
elle-même qui va définir ce que sont les
réfugiés climatiques bien sûr sont des
décisions qui ne peuvent convenir que
dans un cadre international c'est une
évidence je
pense madame Rous je rappelle que ça
n'est pas pour définir un statut de
réfugié climatique juste pour évaluer la
situation des personnes en regarde des
régions dont ils viennent et ben
notamment sur le cas d'événement
climatique mais ça veut pas dire un
statut de réfugié climatique je le mets
au voix qui vote pour contre
rejeté 730
on aura on aura à nouveau cette
discussion de toute façon sur l'affaire
des réfugiés environnementaux et et
climatiques le moment venu bien nous
revenons à cette affaire de collégialité
que nous ne voulons pas à géométrie
variable parce que les règles que vous
proposez induisent cet effet selon
lequel cette collégialité malgré ce qui
nous a été dit de toute façon ne sera
pas garanti je m'autorise à glisser une
autre chose ce le droit relatif au droit
d'asile est un droit qui s'appuie
beaucoup sur la jurisprudence plus on va
éclater la les façons de faire que ce
soit sur le point de vue de la
composition du jury ou que ce soit sur
un plan géographique plus on aura du mal
à garder une cohérence dans la
construction de ce droit et bien
évidemment dans son application et ça
n'est pas un détail parce que c'est ça
qui donne la garantie de l'équité des
jugements et des appréciations qui sont
rendues monsieur
serva défendu madame madame
oui euh nous allons dans le même sens en
fait c'est de garantir la collégialité
comme nous sommes en train d'aborder le
débat tout autant sur la présence du HR
au sein de cette collégialité il y a
quand même il faut le noter une
mobilisation en ce moment des agents de
la CNDA des juristes des avocats qui
tournent autour euh en partie contre les
conditions de travail mais aussi contre
ce projet de loi et une inquiétude
profonde qu'il y a sur et le ministre
vient de le confirmer l'application
généralisée sans possibilité de recours
pour l'urohérent avec juste possibilité
de saisir et laisser à la main de la
présidence et c'est ce que ça contredit
ce que vous disiez monsieur le
rapporteur au
départ le requérant n'aura pas la
possibilité de faire de passer du juge
unique à la collégialité donc il y a
quand même quelque chose qui est très
inquiétant est-ce que vous nous imposez
le juge unique ou est-ce que il y aura
toujours
à la main du requérant la possibilité
d'avoir accès à la collégialité j'ai
entendu de avis différents j'aerais bien
avir cet éclaircissement rapporteur
déforable alors le 739 qui vot pour
contre
Reet le 710 qui V pour contre rejeter le
982 qui vot pour contre rejeté le 1080
monsieur de la
porte
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement il a été suggéré par UNICEF
France et vise à conserver le principe
de la collégialité pour les MNA et les
mineurs accompagnants aujourd'hui les
demandeurs d'asile mineurs VO leur
demande examiner par l'OFPRA et la CNDA
en cas de recours mais la procédure à
l'OFPRA comprend des spécificités pour
les mineurs notamment la spécialisation
et la formation du personnel de l'OFPRA
ou la désignation d'un administrateur ad
hoc pour les MNA donc les MNA les
mineurs accompagnants pardon peuvent
être auditionnés par l'ofpr lorsqu'il
d'un discernement suffisant et clofra
estime que cette audition est
complémentaire à celle de leur
représentant légaux est indispensable à
l'instruction de l'ASY donc comme pour
les affaires présentant des difficultés
sérieuses la qualité de la justice
nécessite de conserver une collégialité
sur les affaires dans lesquelles un
mineur est
impliqué le 1357 monsieur monsieur
Mandon merci monsieur le Président donc
notre groupe est très attaché au
principe de la collégialité dans
juridiction cela autant que faire ce
peut considérant que c'est un acquis
important puisque est-il nécessaire de
le souligner s'agissant de la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile on retrouve
dans le collège des
personnalités compétentes aussi bien sur
le plan juridique que géopolitique d'où
notre amendement 1365 qui viendra
ensuite et qui introduit une précision
c'est-à-dire visant à permettre au
président de la CNDA de décider des
typologies d'affaires dans lesquelles le
recours à une formation collégiale
s'impose mais ce point est à rappeler
nous tenons à évoquer la situation des
plus vulnérables savoir les les mineurs
aussi sur cet article 20 nous proposons
d'imposer le recours à la formation
collégiale lorsque le requérant est
mineur nous souhaitons nous ne
souhaitons pas de juge unique cet
amendement a été travaillé je me dois de
le souligner avec UNICEF France le 1022
madame
Rousseau
euh le 1022 défendu monsieur le
rapporteur vos
avis
ci favorable aux deux amendements 1080
et 1357 de Monsieur balanan et de
Monsieur brunphilippe et défavorable du
moins retrait sur le le le 3ème
amendement étant donné que on vient de
répondre aux deux
premiers je mets alors madame Rousseau
allez-y non mais retrait ok alors il est
retiré et pour les deux autres avec avis
favorable du rapporteur qui vaêre pour
qui votre contre adopté alors est-ce
qu'il fait tomber des
amendements
non il fait pas tomber d'amendement le
1365 monsieur Mandon
oui monsieur le Président j'avais dit
évoqué déjà dans la première exposé
sommaire donc nous sommes ici favorables
à l'introduction d'une précision qui
concerne certaines typologies d'affaires
pour lesqueles le recours à la formation
collégiale s'imposerait et c'est
l'éciation du président de la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable je mets au voix
qui vot pour contre
rejeté le 1379 madame Rousseau dans le
même dans le même esprit que les
précédent amendement qui vise à garantir
que la Cour nationale du droit d'asile
comprenne en son sein des personnes
parfaitement qualifié sur les violen
sexistes et sexuelles sub par les femmes
au cours de leur trajet migratoire
rapporteur toujours défavorable je mets
au voix qui vote pour contre rejeté le
suivant monsieur Kerbrat le 726 ce ser
madame auonau monsieur le Président
c'est un amendement qui souhaite
supprimer le recours à la visio audience
par la CNDA en notant par ailleurs qu'il
y a une forme de contradiction entre la
D territorialisation qui permettrait la
proximité et puis le développement de la
visioconférence qui est censé justement
répondre au problèmes de de distance et
donc tous les cas nous nous étions déjà
opposés au développement en matière de
de juridiction euh euh on va dire
général mais encore plus sur la question
du du du droit d'asile parce que s'il y
a bien domaine où la question de
l'intime conviction ou la question de
l'oralité ou la capacité à pouvoir
exprimer un certain nombre de choses par
le récit mais aussi par les expressions
et fondamentales c'est bien dans ce dans
ce genre de cas et où il y a besoin de
une présence physique et nous pensons
que l'introduction la systématisation
comme vous le faites va empêcher de
transmettre les messages essentiels
besoin de transmettre les
personnesour en fait je crois que ma
collègue vous a expliqué que c'était les
deux mêmes amendements qu'elle dé en
même temps alors je n'ai pas entendu je
suis désolé monsieur le rapporteur on
est un peu fatigué je pense
monsieur raorteur défavorable sur les
deux je mets au voix qui vote pour qui
vote contre rejeté le 123 madame
Rousseau défendu monsieur le rapporteur
déforable je mets au voix qui vote pour
contre rejeté l'article 20 qui vote pour
contre adopté après l'article 20 madame
miad votre amendement
oui je vous remercie cet amendement qui
a été travaillé avec le CN le Conseil
National des Barreaux souhaite d'une
part que le le requérant soit informé
qu'il peut en toute circonstances d'une
part choisir son avocat et d'autre part
instaurer la communication du dossier du
requérant avant tout recours effectif
devant le CNDA à l'avocat choisi ou non
je vous rappelle simplement que le le
choix de
l'avocat constitue un principe à valeur
constitutionnelle et concernant le le le
fait que
on puisse avoir communication du dossier
il faut savoir qu'il y a une il y a une
différence entre les avocats choisis qui
ne disposeraient pas du dossier avant
les recours tandis que les avocats qui
seraient désignés au titre de l
juridictionnelle eux déposeraient eux
auraient communication de de son dossier
de manière automatique voilà c'est le
sens de cet amendement qui m'apparaît
aller de soi Monsieur le
Rapporteur défavorable je mets au voix
qui vote pour contre rejeter
le alors Monsieur il est pas défendu le
1092 le 987 non plus madame tourignal
980 moame auono oui euh merci monsieur
le Président par cet amendement nous
souhaitons faire en sorte que l'État
établisse un plan d'action pour
augmenter l'offre de formation pour les
agents et et les agents de la CNDA le
manque d'accès à ces types de formation
spécifiques ne permettent pas euh au
personnel de pouvoir traiter certains
dossiers de manière la plus efficace et
la plus opofondie et euh avec la la mise
en place d'analyse pratique ce type de
formation permettrait d'appréhender les
audiences de manière plus fine et avec
des connaissances nécessaires elle
pourrait porter ses formations sur les
problématiques de violence sexuelle de
troubles post-traumatiqu euh pour la
meilleure compréhension des
problématiques des personnes LGBT euh et
il nous semble qu'il il faut établir
cela de manière volontariste y mettre
les moyens voilà le sens de notre
amendement Mons le
rapporteur supprimé euh défavorable
fatigué pardon madame madame
Martin excusez-moi je crois qu'il faut
pas négliger la souffrance au travail
qui a été exprimé par deux fois par les
les agents les salariés de l'OF pra et
de la
CNDA ce qu'il vivent
c'est un phénomène d'accélération il
parle même d'abattage et ils se sentent
fort démunis donc s'il y avait au moins
cette capacité là à leors donner le
signe qu'on porte un intérêt à ce qu'ils
font et qu'au travers de formation on
cherche à les étayer bah ça serait déjà
une bonne chose et un bon premier signe
il y a un turnover un turnover qui est
très important dans ces deux instances
enfin dans ces deux organismes je ne
sais pas comment dire c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que qu'il y a beaucoup de jeunes
gens ils y rentrent plein d'enthousiasme
cherchant du sens mais ils en sortent
relativement rapidement parce que ce
qu'on leur demande de faire c'est de
l'abattage et sur l'affaire du juge
unique et tout le bazar ils ont
parfaitement conscience que ça sera
encore plus de l'abattage ça vaut
peut-être le coup de les écouter de
temps à autre hein je mets au voix qui
vote pour contre rejeté le suivant n'est
pas défendu à l'article 20 bis monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez un
amendement si je peux avoir un micro
j'en ai encore un
pardon cet amendement a simplement pour
objectif de rendre obligatoire la
suspension de la visioconférence lorsque
les conditions techniques ne sont pas
réunies c'est une
modification qui est importante suite à
la modification du Sénat je mets au voix
qui vote pour contre adopté le 712
madame c'est un sujet qu'on a déjà
abordé tout à l'heure qui a la question
de la garantie nécessaire de la la
présence physique d'un interprète c'est
d'autant plus que moi je vous mets mon
billet que dans le cadre de la
délocalisation de la CNDA il y aura une
augmentation des visio audiences et que
ça posera la question à l'égard des
interprètes et des avocats or vu la
finesse des des des situations et des
questions qui sont posées il faut qu'il
y ait physiquement un interprète vous
refuser tout hein il y a pas de
difficulté nous on en tirera la
conclusion que l'objectif il est clair
c'est baisser le nombre de personne à
qui on propose l'asile c'est clair le
dessin il est clair dans les deux sens
du terme monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable je mets au voix
qui vote pour contre
rejeté l'amendement
su attendez oui après le 20 bis le 715
madame
obodo qui le défend
715 pe le
faire oui c'est c'est le même oui c'est
le mê en partie on VI on vient de faire
le
1712 donc moi je vous parle du
715 madame t madame faut donner micro
c'est bon oui là il s'agit en fait de
demander la présence physique d'un
interprète parce que c'est rarement le
cas et donc c'est c'est un peu c'est un
peu le même principe de d'amendement qui
est un amendement qui repose
sur connaissance
la la connaissance des conditions dans
lesquelles se passent ces entretiens on
parle de gens je le répète encore qui
ont vécu des des trajets des des
parcours extrêmement difficiles
extrêmement enfin dramatique qui ont des
traumatismes et donc il faut pouvoir
qu'ils puissent être en confiance pour
pouvoir raconter leur histoire ça prend
du temps ça s expliquit ma ma collègue
tout à l'heure donc il faut que ça se
fasse dans des conditions humaines et
donc pour qu'il ait une condition
humaine il faut qu'il y ait une personne
physique en face qui parle la même
langue parce que si en plus on ne se
comprend pas bien ça devient très
compliqué monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je mets je le mets au voix
qui va êre pour qui vre contre rejeté on
passe à l'article 21 monsieur
Kerbrat
qui qui est-ce qui le prend monsieur
porte euh un amendement pour supprimer
cet article et qui entend porter la su
la réduction du nombre de voies de
recours l'actif au contencieux des
étrangers donc 12 procédures visées par
CEJ de lois sont fondu dans quatre
formes de recours au délai beaucoup trop
bref c'est encore une fois une attaque
contre des gens qui sont déjà en extrême
précarité en extrême difficulté et la
réponse que vous apportez c'est une
réduction des voies de recours donc vous
fragilisez des gens dans la possibilité
de d' exercer un recours ça nous semble
pas euh à la hauteur des enjeux surtout
qu'on est sur un public qui est déjà
fragilisé qui a vécu des situations
traumatisantes et qui doit pouvoir
exercer ses ses recours et ses droits
dans la meilleur des conditions ça a été
déjà évoqué par mes collègues avant sur
la question des euh vidéo des
visoconférences la présence d'un
interprète et là on divise par trois la
possibilité d'avoir des voix de recours
donc c'est encore une fois une attaque
contre les
possibilités monsur le euh non madame
fon oui merci monsieur le Président
généralement quand dans un des textes du
gouvernement actuel je vois écrit
simplification je me méfie et je crois
que j'ai j'ai un peu raison je commence
à avoir un peu trop l'habitude de vous
et très clairement il s'agit pas ici du
d'une simplification non pas une volonté
avec un objectif de de désengorger les
les tribunaux de de de de de
rationaliser les choses mais très
clairement d'abaisser les protections et
les garanties procédurales pour pour
expulser plus vite donc ne nous parlez
pas de simplification mais bien
d'abaissement des garanties et des
droits ça défavorable
euh en 2022 ce conteneux représenta 43,5
% de l'activité consensueuse des
tribunaux administratifs 56,1 % de celle
des cours administratifs d'appel et 18,7
% de celle du Conseil d'État en
simplifiant les règles pour améliorer
l'efficacité du traitement des requêtes
il s'agit de répondre à l'enjeu de
l'engorgement des tribun administratif
ce que l'on fait depuis tout à l'heure
cet impératif de simplification par du
constat selon lequel ce contentieux est
aujourd'hui l'un des plus complexes et
c'est pour cela que nous échangerons il
y aura des amendements aussi rapporteur
et d'autres
collègues sur ce texte et le supprimer
ne serait pas une bonne réponse et je
vous réponds madame Martin je rappelle
juste que le
madame torigna et Martin alors comme ça
que je rappelle juste que la langue
demandée la langue demandée et
l'interprétariat est toujours respecté
étant donné que la demande est faite dès
la demande d'enregistrement à l'OFPRA et
qu'elle suit au fur à mesure du temps et
que c'est c'est bien le requérant qui
demande la langue dans lequelle il ve
son
interprète alors je mets au voix ces
amendements de suppression qui vote pour
qui vote contre rejeté amendement
suivant le 1215 madame fossillon madame
fossillon
1215 défendu le 1514 madame jeunevar
elle est
absente monsieur camardine défendu mon
le rapport défavorable je mets au voix
le 1215 qui votre pour contre rejeté le
1514 qui votre pour contre rejeté le 109
madame regol merci monsieur le Président
c'est un article de repli puisqu'il n'y
a pas eu de suppression de l'article
21 pour rappeler qu'il est important de
laisser la possibilité au recquérant de
solliciter l'aide juridictionnelle à
laquelle il a le droit à tout moment et
non je juste jusqu'à l'introduction de
son
retour 18 secondes j'ai vraiment été
très rapide monsieur le
Président rapporteur
défavorable je mets au voix qui Vêtre
pour contre rejeté alors moi j'avais un
amendement pour simplifier encore
plusastiquement les procédures suggéré
par le Syndicat des juges administratifs
et pour qu'on retienne deux procédure
une avec un délai de recours à fixer à 1
mois et un délai de jugement à 6 c'est
une plus simplifiée et qui comprend tes
les autres procédures d'urgence avec un
délai de recours à 72h un délai de
jugement à 120h monsieur le
rapporteur pour moi monsieur le
Président c'est défavorable favorable
défavorable défavorable alors faut me
dire pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre donc
j'attends j'attends peut-être le que
monsieur le Premier ministre le ministre
de l'Intérieur vous
répondeo il a dit quoi à
23h43 monsieur le ministre pas c un peu
plus allez-y non non je on y est
défavorable même si la l'idée peut être
bonne parce que l'idée c'est quand même
de simplifier les procédures donc a
priori passer de 12 à 4 puis de 12 à 3
parce que nous pensions 4 le Sénat dit 3
et maintenant 2 il faudrait monsieur le
Président peut-être qu'on prenne un
petit peu le temps pour rediscuter un
peu plus visis de la la séance parce
qu'on a peur
qu on a peur qu'en faisant cela en fait
vous alliez
complexifier recours et notamment ceux
qui sont concernés pour la voie qui
concerne les personnes qui seraient par
exemple menace pour l'ordre public alors
on comprend bien que ça peut être une
simplification intéressante mais si j'ai
un petit tableau mais qu'on pourra
partager ensemble peut-être en vue de la
en vue de la séance ce je dis la
commission je sais qu'il est tard je
vais faire le plus vite possible je vous
promets mais ce tableau et la la
difficulté à laquelle nous nous trouvons
avec le Conseil d'État pour juger des
des recours donc il est assez complexe
mais je pense que je peux le faire
parvenir à tous les parlementaires en vu
de la la séance parce qu'on on
s'aperçoit qu'entre la situation
actuelle les mesures prononcées les
propositions du Conseil d'État dans son
étude et les proposition du du du projet
immigration ils ont été pesés au
tribucher a avec le Conseil d'État
gagnant sur des côtés acceptant leur
proposition de l'autre et je pense que
les juges au tribunaux administratif
n'ont pas exactement les mêmes intérêts
que le Conseil d'État ou les cours
administratifes d'appel ou la CNDA je le
ferai circulariser c'est assez complexe
je suis pas sûr qu'en cette heure assez
tardive vous voulez qu'on fasse un
détail euh complet de de de la façon
dont on fait les recours administratifs
je propose monsieur le Président
peut-être si vous en étiez d'accord
qu'on puisse réserver ce débat à la
séance en faisant parvenir à tous les
parlementair une petite note qui est le
travail qu'on a fait avec le Conseil
d'État et le tableau ce n'est pas une
note qui oriente les décisions c'est une
note qui explique où on en est de leur
discussion donc je serai assez preneur
en effet que tous les très excellents
articles votés ne tombent pas par sens
du Conseil constitutionnel par trop
grande simplification même si je
comprends ce que vous portez monsieur le
Président très bien je je vous remercie
pour pour tout vous dire j'avais
commencé à travailler ces amendements le
1640 et le 1641 que je vais retirer au
moment où j'avais vu que le Sénat ne
prenait que quatre procédures et non
plus les trois qu'on avait imaginé au
départ et et donc j'ai vu que le Sénat a
finalement adopté en séance la version
initiale des syndicats déjà des des
juges administratifs ce qui est en soi
une grande simplification et donc je
retire et le 1640 et le 1641 avec une
opportunité pour regarder monsieur
monsieur naen j'ai retiré donc vous
n'avez malheureusement pas la parole sur
ce coup-ci mais vous en faites pas il
reste des AM
ement le 687 monsieur cab merci monsieur
le Président donc par cet amendement
nous demandons l'alignement des recours
contre les obligations de quitter le
territoire français sans prise en compte
de la situation administrative de
l'administré soumis à l'obligation la la
simplification des délais contention en
droit des étrangers a fait l'objet d'un
rapport du groupe de travail présidé par
le Conseil Stal qui comprend des
nombreuses préconisations lesquelles
n'ont pas été reprises par le projet de
loi en effet le projet de loi retient
comme critère le dél du départ
volontaire critère totalement ilisible
et injuste pour l'étranger encore une
fois les procédures vont être trop
rapides ces procédures trop rapides sont
ilogiques même de votre point de vue car
elles sonont plus plus souvent
irrégulières et annulé par un recours
nous dans cet objectif de simplification
et je pense qu'on pourra porter en effet
avec les éléments que le ministre va
nous donner pour la séance nous
proposons une simplification qui est
positive pour le droit des étrangers
c'est deux procédures distinctes en
fonction du critères de la privation
liberté un délai de recours de 72 he et
un jugement dans les 96 he en cas de
placement en rétention un délai de
recours de 1 mois et un jugement dans
les 3 à 6 mois dans tous les autres
cas le rapporteur défavorable cet
amendement aurait pu aurait pour effet
de prévoir une procédure unique de droit
commun en collégial avec un délai de
recours d'un mois et un délai de
jugement de 6 mois en fait ça ne répond
pas aux attentes de cet article donc ça
me paraît ça ne me paraît pas
raisonnable et on a besoin d'un d'une
certaine contrainte aussi sur le le
récurrant
donc est favorable je mets au voix qui
vote pour contre
rejeté le 1660 11 monsieur le
rapporteur par cette amendement je vous
propose de revenir à l'architecture
procédurale telle qu'elle été
initialement envisagée dans le projet de
loi articulé autour des quatre
procédures suivantes une procédure
ordinaire applicable aux décision
portant obligation de quitter le
territoire français donc OQTF a sorti
d'un délé de départ volontaire une
procédure prioritaire que je souhaite
rétablir par cet amendement applicable
au contentieux des eqtf lorsque qu'aucun
délai de départ volontaire n'est accordé
à l'étranger une procédure spéciale que
je souhaite voir appliquer à tout le
contentieux des décisions liées à la
procédure d'asile y compris aux eutf
faisant suite à un rejet de la demande
d'asile et enfin une procédure d'urgence
applicable dans tous les cas dans
lequels l'étranger est placé en
rétention avec un délai de recours de 48
he et un délai de jugement de
96h en fait revenir au principe de
traitement différencié de recours contre
les eqtf la différence principale avec
le texte adopté par le Sénat pardon
permet de revenir au principe de
traitement différentié des recours
contre les UTF voilà ce que nous vous
proposons AC le rapporteur général
mameol merci monsieur le Président euh
dans la mesure où monsieur le ministre
nous a proposé nous envoyer des
documents qui pouvaient éclairer ce
débat que on a le président qui propose
deux procédures le rapporteur qui en
propose quatre et le ministre qui semble
avoir une position entre les deux trois
voilà euh peut-être que pour éclairer le
débat qui est limité à une minutes par
personne et qui nous permet pas d'aller
au bout des choses peut-être que on peut
attendre en avoir quelques éléments et
donc peut-être que vous pouvez retirer
votre amendement en
attendant je vais vous fait faire une
autre proposition nous avons une semaine
de battement entre la Commission et la
séance nous pourvons tout à fait
organiser une une audition rapporteur
sur ce sujet à nouveau pour
éventuellement confronter les points de
vue avoir les éléments communiqués par
le ministre mais en attendant nous
pouvons adopter le l'amendement présenté
par le
rapporteur très bien
je je le mets au voix qui votre pour
amendement du
rapporteurre contre il est
adopté on fait une audition le madame
reg vous avez la parole pour le
1396 merci monsieur le Président mais
quand même là on est assez posé on
essaie de faire des choses qui reposent
sur des éléments formels faire passer
cet amendement malgré tout et de force
je trouve ça un petit peu
déplacé donc l'amendement de ma collègue
Sabrina cbahi sur l'article 21 du projet
de loi qui prévoit une procédure
contentieuse spécifique applicable à
plusieurs décisions administratives
susceptibles de viser les demandeur
d'asile elle recroupe les décisions de
refus ou de retrait des conditions
matérielles d'accueil les arrêtés
d'assignation à résident et les arrêtés
de transfert dit Dublin qui vise les
demandeurs d'asile dont la
responsabilité encbe un autre État
européen or le délai de recours prévu
est de 7 jours ce qui est beaucoup trop
court pour permettre au demandeur
d'asile qui souffrent souvent de
difficultés en outre d'accompagnement de
saisir un avocat et ainsi d'accéder
effectivement au juges ces situations
restent cependant des situations
d'urgence qui nécessitent une réponse
judiciaire rapide il semble donc plus
juste et réaliste de garantir un délai
de 15 jours pour ensemble des décisions
monsieur rapporteur dé favorable le la
fixation de ce délai procédural est
quand même proposé par le Conseil d'État
qui propose 7 jours donc le doubl à 15
jours ne correspond pas aux attentes ça
me paraît pas justifié donc défavorable
je mets au voix qui vote pour contre
rejet le suivant monsieur
Mandon défendu monsieur le
rapporteuror le
1363 oui excusez-moi
c'est alors c'est une demande de retrait
et on avait une écriture équivalente
proposé rapporteur qui sera aussi retiré
donc je vous propose de le
retirer alors Monsieur retirer le 1081
monsieur de la
porte merci monsieur le Président pas de
pas de tribunal mais une salle
délocalisée pas de juge mais une caméra
et un écran avouez que c'est une justice
un peu partic une justice un peu
particulière
pardon et que par ailleurs cette justice
s'applique à tout le monde y compris aux
mineurs et et par conséquent cet
amendement il a pour objet de de dire
qu'on ne peut pas traiter les mineurs
comme comme les majeurs et qu'il faut
supprimer la possibilité de de recourir
au au vidéo au vidéo audience devant le
le tribunal administratif pour les
mineurs non accompagnés qui sont
maintenus en zone d'attente pour de
multiples raisons je vais pas m'étendre
ici mais un mineur comme un majeur doit
comprendre la la procédure dont il est
un élément évidemment important un
mineur peut se trouver plus facilement
qu'un majeur écrasé en quelque sorte ou
déstabilisé par une par une caméra et
puis peut-être ne faut-il pas donner le
sentiment à ce mineur qu'il a affaire à
une justice déshumanisé alors même que
le seul fait d'avoir affaire à la
justice est déjà une véritable épreuve
donc il faut absolument sortir ces
vidéos audiences pour les pour les
mineurs monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable chers collègues on a voté
tout à l'heure la l'interdiction de
rétention des mineurs donc c'est
satisfait de la
porte j'ai pas l'impression qu' qu'il
s'agisse de la même chose là il s'agit
des auditions des mineurs tout à l'heure
on a parlé de la collégialité de de
l'audience là ici on parle de la
possibilité d'avoir une audience par
voie de viioconférence qui n'est pas la
même chose monsieur le rapporteur et par
ailleurs si on regarde tous les
protocoles notamment les protocoles nich
qui sont liés à l'audition des mineurs
il est
évidemment fermement préconisé de ne pas
avoir recours à à une audition par voie
de de visioconférence parce que ça
altère évidemment toute la perception
qu'on peut avoir des échang avec un
mineur donc voilà c'est extrêmement
inquiétant si on nadopte pas cet
amendement j'ai un amendement aussi au
1672 la rétention administrative qui
est l'alina que vous avez sélectionné
nous avons interdit la rétention
administrative des mineurs nous l'avons
bien nous avons bien voté tout à l'heure
l'interdiction de de la mise en en cras
des mineurs nous sommes d'accord donc
c'est déjà possible depuis le débart
donc vous êtes déjà satisfait vous
verrez que sur mon amendement j'en
rajoute aussi en complément je vous
laisse regarder chers collègues on peut
en parler retrait ou
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeter le 1072 monsieur le
rapporteur c'est c'est en fait afin
d'assurer une bonne administration de la
justice et de permettre à l'étranger de
se présenter de présenter ses
explications c'est ce qui permet de
répondre à différentes demandes qui a
été faite depuis tout à l'heure donc
celle-ci sur la vidéo audience par
exemple si ce n'est pas possible elle
est dans l'obligation d'être arrêté par
exemple monsieur de la porte monsieur de
la porte mais écoutez moi je vois pas du
tout où se trouvent les mineurs de
tempant qu'ici on parle de l'aménagement
des salles d'audience dans les zones
d'attent euh notamment des salles de
visioconférence donc ici c'est pas du
tout ce que vous dites monsieur le
rapporteur les mineurs ne les mineurs
pourront faire euh des visos des
audiences par visoconférence en tout cas
je ne vois pas en quoi votre amendement
les en
protège je le mets au voix qui vote
pour du rapporteur contre
adopté le 67igle
ouais euh merci monsieur le Président
son amendement de repli puisque
l'article 21 n'a pas été supprimé qui
s'intéresse aux question des moyens de
communication et pour la faire brève qui
rappelle que le recours à la vidéo la
visioconférence comme toutes les
procédures de dématérialisation
n'améliore pas les audiences de la CNDA
ça ne les améliore pour personne ni pour
les magistrats ni pour les avocats et
encore moins pour les requérants et les
personnes exhilées ça enlève encore plus
d'AINS et ça met encore plus de distance
le 1497 c'est aussi vous madame rig tout
à fait monsieur le Président cet
amendement rev une on on est toujours
sur la dématérialisation il revit une
importance cruciale pour préserver les
principes fondamentaux d'un procès
équitable et d'une justice humaine dans
le contexte du contentieux d'asile d'une
part parce que il faut préserver le
droit à un procès équitable et que la
visionférence n'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'il y a de mieux puisque ça implique
un procès équitable un accès au juges la
publicité de l'audience et une égalité
des armes euh il y a aussi l'impact sur
les personnes vulnérables qu' ces
procédures le contencieux de la as il
concerne son des personnes vulnérables
et la visioconférence peut priver ces
individus d'une défense effective active
dans laquelle ils se reconnaissent
l'exigence de solennité en aussi
eu puisque là on en perd un petit peu
avec la dématérialisation et enfin le
respect du contradictoire la
visioconférence peut en effet entraîner
des difficultés pratiques et techniques
qui entravent le respect du
contradictoire en gros cet amendement
s'oppose à des pratiques potentiellement
inhumaines et discriminatoires merci
monsieur le rapporteur je pense qu'on
partage le les on est attaché au mêm
garantiese du moins aux garanties
procédural et le fait que chacun puisse
être faire respecter son droit sauf que
en supprimant cette possibilité ira
supprimer cette possibilité ira à
l'encomte de l'objectif d'efficacité du
traitement du contentieux administratif
et serait une régression par rapport à
l'état du droit donc c'est
défavorable c'est simplement pour vous
rappeler qu'il est l'or seignor
23h58 vous nous aviez dit que vous nous
expliqueriez à minuit ce qu'on fait donc
88 amendements si on même si on fait une
minute par amendement ça fait donc 88
minutes ça fait à peu près 1h30
euh mais moi j'ai pas envie d'aller plus
vite quand il s'agit d'humanité je suis
désolée le sujet est très grave et donc
vous pouvez prendre la décision de
terminer vite on vient d'entendre
je voudrais simplement calmement le dire
calmement vous venez d'entendre donc la
députés des républicains dire il faut
aller plus vite moi je pense que sur ce
sujet il ne faut pas aller plus vite il
faut prendre le temps de la
discussion nous sommes les députés nous
avons une indemnité parlementaire il y a
pas de problème on peut revenir bosser
demain alors il reste 88 amendement je
crois que à la quasi unanimité de la
Commission en tout cas des gens qui sont
devant moi ils sont favorables à ce que
nous poursuivions et que nous terminions
88 amendements c'est largement faisable
en quelques heures s'il les faut pour
finir il n'y a pas de de de borne pour
terminer à minuit dans la Commission on
peut l'ouvrir on peut on peut l'ouvrir
autant autant autant qu' qu'on le veut
dès d lors nous allons poursuivre nous
allons nous allons poursuivre
tranquillement et et comme
et comme il n'y a pas de 493 en
commission et ben nous allons pouvoir
travailler jusqu'au bout de la
commission vous en faites pas soyez
rassuré Mame t très bien donc s' le faut
on peut travailler jusqu'à 4h du matin
en prenant le temps de
discuter t merci Madame Tor monsieur le
rapporteur AZ donné vos avis donc je le
mets au voix le 67 qui vote pour contre
rejeté le 1497 pour contre rejeté
j'avais pas l'impression de presser
quiconque madame
le 1375 madame yadan plus on est bien là
défendu monsieur le rapporteur favorable
qui vote pour contre adopté le 1673
monsieur le rapporteur retiré le 1674
monsieur le
rapporteur
défendu défendu je le mets au voix qui
vote pour contre adopté il fait tomber
le
1362 le 1500 7 madame reg quand
même merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement souhaite rétablir le
caractère suspensif du recours dans la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile la loi
du 10 septembre 2018 pardon a clairement
porté atteinte au principe du caractère
suspensif du recours garanti par
l'article 13 de la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme cette remise en
cause est contraire aux exigences
constitutionnelles Sonel lesquelles le
resp du droit d'asile principe de valeur
constitutionnelle implique d'une manière
générale que l'étranger qui se réclame
de ce droit soit autorisé à demeurer
provisoirement sur le territoire jusqu'à
ce qu'il ait été statué sur sa demande
ainsi en rétablissant le caractère
suspensif le texte protège l'égalité de
traitement des recours et reste en
conformité envers nos engagements auprès
de la CEDH et de l'un
nhcr monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
ce qu'il entraîne une difficulté de
coordination des nouvelles procédures
applicable madame
Martin madame Martin ben demander au
rapporteur des explications
al bon vous voulez la parole madame
Martin ou
[Musique]
pas bon écoutez moi je je constate que à
nouveau puisque je n'ai pas pu entendre
les explications du rapporteur qui veut
aller vite donc qui parle vite et je
n'ai pas
entendu et donc je dis que bah à nouveau
ce que porte la macronie c'est un non
respect d'un certain nombre de principes
et de considération du droit
international cela ne nous étonne pas
puis bah voilà si vous voulez on va
faire comme ça monsieur le rapporteur je
vais répéter ce que j'ai dit défavorable
parce que cela entraîne une difficulté
de coordination des nouvelles procédures
applicables excusez-moi mais quand on
est représentant de la France insoumise
et qu'on signe un courrier de pression
un procureur de la République pour qu'il
fasse appel sur une décision de la Cour
de Justice de la République on ne fait
pas la leçon aux
autres alors je mets au voix
l'amendementors vous
1587 il est qui va pour qui vote contre
rejeté monsieur Mandon le suivant la rép
c'est les arrangements oui monsieur le
Président
président oui
alors allez-y monsieur Monon ah je le
débat constitutionnel sur la CGR sera
pour plus tard peut-être pour le 7
décembre sur ce point donc sur cet
amendement nous proposons de substituer
donc les 3 ans de passer à 2 ans parce
qu'on estime que
le délai de 3 ans nous paraît
excessif n paraissait plus logique de
prendre une solution intermédiaire en
prenant 2 ans
non monsieur le rapporteur favorable
favorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour contre adopté je mets au voir
l'article 21 qui vre pour contre est
adopté le 685 madame
Tor cet amendement propose de supprimer
l'article
22 vous avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur
monsieur le Président alors que je
défendais un
amendement que je défendais une position
par rapport à un amendement du
rassemblement national où je parlais
d'humanité j'étais vraiment dans le
sujet de l'amendement vous m vous m'avez
fait comprendre que je n'y étais pas et
là le rapporteur vient de stigmatiser
encore une fois la France insoumise en
disant que nous ferions pression ce qui
est n'a absolument rien à voir je parle
tranquillement ce qui n'a absolument
rien à voir avec l'amendement donc je ne
vois pas pourquoi vous ne lui faites pas
cette remarque au rapporteur sans doute
sans doute sans doute parce que c'est le
rapporteur et que je ne suis qu'une
simple
députée
madametillon oui merci Monsieur le le
président dans la continuité de ce que
nous avons dit sur précédent article
évidemment et on l'a dit je crois à
plusieurs reprises aujourd'hui le le
droit des étrangers est d'une très
grande complexité et d'une trop grande
complexité et conduit à beaucoup trop de
de contentieux d'ailleurs il y a de
nombreuses institution qui appelle à oh
là là c'est franchement c'est
dur qui appelle aujourd'hui à une
simplification le problème c'est que ce
que vous nous proposez n'est pas une
simplification ce que vous nous proposez
aujourd'hui va plutôt dans dans le sens
d'une réduction des garantie et d'un
droit au recours réellement effectif
pour les étrangers et c'est ça qu'on
conteste et et les assurances
franchement enfin le les arguments que
vous nous donnez nous donnent assez peu
d'assurance face aux arguments que nous
invoquons monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre
rejeté amendement 1210 pardon article 22
qui vote pour contre adopté amendement
1217 madame fossillon défendu défendu
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable je le
mets au voix qui vote pour contre rejeté
l'article 23 qui vote pour contre
adopté article 23 bis amendement ensuite
madame monsieur Lucas madame
rol merci Monsieur le le président
amendement de de suppression que nous
proposons avec mon groupe l'érosion
majeur du secret médical que constitue
la modification de l'instruction des
litiges relatifs au au refus les titre
de séjours étranger malade la
possibilité d'édicter une décision
d'éloignement dès la date de
l'ordonnance rejetant le recours contre
la décision de l'OFPRA l'allongement de
la durée de validité de l'ordonnance du
jug des libertés de la détention
autorisant la visite domiciliaire d'un
étranger assigné à résidence ne présente
pas d'intérêt en matière d'accueil ou
d'intégration sous couvert de
simplification administrative cet
article effectue un détricotage
considérable des dispositifs d'accueil
et d'inclusion et attaque directement
les droits des personnes primau
arrivantes c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons de de supprimer purement et
simplement cet article madame torignia
le
682 merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement pour éviter de supprimer les
dispositions qui permettent de conserver
les données médicales secrèes
dans le cadre des instructions du litige
sur les refus de titre de séjour et
d'étrangers malad pourquoi est-ce que
nous encore une fois on se retrouve
toujours avec cette loi finalement dans
les exceptions de droit individuels qui
sont affectés au aux êtres humains aux
motifs qui sont étrangers le droit au
secret médical il doit être le même pour
tous quel qu'on soit quel que qui que
l'on soit et là on cherche au travers de
cet article finalement à permettre au
préfet de s'assurer de connaître en
quelque sorte le motif pour lequel
l'étranger est déclaré malade on a là
comment dire une un diagnostic est
établi par des médecins et c'est même
nafron qui est fait à ces médecins que
finalement remettre en doute le fait
qu'ils aient pu évaluer un étranger
comme étant malade et nécessitant des
soins que de devoir vérifier la réalité
ou la nature des des des des des des
problèmes rencontrés par les étrangers
qui se font sculpter donc c'est encore
une fois une une atteinte aux libertés
individuelles monsieur de la porte oui
en fait cette article 23 bis on pourrait
croire que on avait tout vu mais il y a
encore un certain nombre d'horreurs qui
qui sont caché dans la fin de ce texte
on a par exemple ça a été dit à
l'instant la levée du secret médical bon
ben ça c'est un premier problème pour
les titres de séjour étrangers malad on
a la capacité finalement de fixé à 144
he au lieu de 96h la durée de validité
d'ordonnance du JLD et la détention
autorisant la visite domiciliaire d'un
étranger assigné à résidence on a ajusté
des délis dont dispose le JLD pour
statuer afin d'assurer qu'il ne soit
jamais contraint de tenir deux audiences
consécutives sur le placement en
rétention et la prolongation de la
rétention d'une même personne bref vous
voyez on a aussi une augmentation de 4
jours au lieu de 48 Hees de la durée de
la première phase de rétention
administrative enfin desserment des
délis dans lequel le ministère peut
demander au premier président de la cour
d'appel ou à son délégué de déclarer son
recours suspensif lorsqu'il apparaît que
l'intéressé ne dispose pas de garantie
de représentation effective bref vous
voyez il y a un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont extrêmement inquiétante
du point de vue des droits de la défense
et c'est pourquoi évidemment il faut
supprimer cet article madame fossillon
défendu Madame Dupont je partage les les
arguments également des collègues et je
dis défendu je suis le rapporteur bah
oui pardon
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour contre
rejeté le 1359 monsieur Mandon
oui mais il est défendu j'ir pas plus
loin dans l'explication mais il y a tout
de même à rappeler que nous sommes
attachés à un nombre de principes et
comme ça a été ça pu être évoqué par
d'autres et donc nous insistons pour
défendre cet amendement monur rapporteur
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vot
pour contre rejeté votre amendement le
1615 monsieur qui devrait faire plaisir
à Monsieur de la porte c'est le le
rétablir la la durée de validité de 96h
pendant lequel l'ordonnance du JLD
autorisant la visite domiciliirere en
cas d'assignation résidence de
l'étranger est
exécutoire Jes de la porte oui merci
c'est un minimum mais pour le reste
monsieur le rapporteur pour toutes les
autres horreurs que je viens de lister
qu quelle est votre
position on l'a dit tout à l'heure on a
on s'est basé sur le rapport du Conseil
d'État on a eu un échange là-dessus là
je reviens sur les 96 he c'est on a voté
sur la sur la suppression s'est pas
passé
basta je mets au voix qui vote pour
l'amendement du rapporteur contre il est
adopté le
792 madame rol merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement qui est donc
une forme de repli vise à garantir à un
étranger placé en rétention
administrative le droit de contester
cette décision tout au long de la
période de rétention actuellement la loi
autorise la préfecture à maintenir les
individus en détention dans un centre de
rétention pendant 48 he pour organiser
leur départ délai que le Sénat propose
d'augmenter à 4 jours or C délai de 24
heur et 48ur semble particulièrement
court et inadapté pour garantir les
droits de la défense de l'étranger en
rétention administrative comment exercer
en recours dans de bonnes conditions ai
peu de temps consulter un avocat se
renseigner sur ses droits et cetera
est-ce pour autant est-ce et pardon et
ce d'autant plus que bien souvent le
point d'accès au droit est informé
tardivement de la rétention de
l'étranger et n'est donc plus en mesure
d'intervenir en raison de l'expiration
du délai de recours et notamment
concernant des personnes qui n'avaient
pas été suivies par le point d'accès au
droit ou la SIMA d'auparavant et qui et
à qui la mesure n'a pas été explicité en
amont monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
je le mets au voix qui vote pour qui
vote contre rejeté 1676 monsieur le
rapporteur le présent am vise à corriger
cette lacune en précisant le délai pour
le pendant lequel le procureur peut
exercer ce recours susp son recours
suspensif monsieur alors je mets au voix
l'amendement du rapporteur qui vote pour
contre adopté 15 1575 madame Rousseau
c'est un amendement qui vise à revenir
sur des décennies de politiques
d'allongement des temps de durée de
rétention chaque année sont plus de
45000 personnes qui sont enfermées dans
des centres et des locaux de rétention
administrative les CR ou les LRA ces
dernières années anné les politiques de
gestion migratoire ont évolué vers un
recours de plus en plus systématique et
étendu à la rétention administrative
alors que la loi du 10 décembre 2018 a
déjà allongé la durée de rétention de 45
à 90 jours le projet de loi propose
encore de l'augmenter à 120 jours nous
proposons de revenir en arrière monsieur
le rapporteur
défavorable tu pour
contre attendez on a fait en même temps
les deux
donc
vous avez pas baissé la main quand j'ai
dit contre c'est pour ça donc alors qui
vote pour qui vote
contre bah non vous gagnez pas je vais
vous prêter mes lunettes madame
r le 23 B qui vote pour l'article 23 B
qui vot contre il est
adopté madame Martin le
673 il s'agit de mettre fin à ces
tribunaux que l'on dit sur place
proximité des lieux de rétention là on
pense particulièrement à l'annexe du
tribunal de bobini sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de roissi c'est un symbole de
la justice expéditive après la justice
d'exception donc une justice qu'on juge
bien sûr troppe expéditive relativement
au droit aux personnes c'est d'ailleurs
l'objet de beaucoup de critiques
particulièrement par la Défenseur des
droits monsieur le
rapporteur
défavorable le Conseil constitutionnel a
validé la possibilité de délocaliser les
audiences au sein de ces salle dédié
attribué par le ministère de la Justice
je le mets au voix qui vote pour contre
rejeté l'article 24 madame Feillon euh
oui nous sommes sur la volonté d'étendre
le recours à la vidéo audience en centre
de rétention et en zone d'attente débat
qu'on a largement eu au cours de la
précédente loi asile et immigration et
on voit que s'apofondit cette volonté
qui met en avant d'abord des raisons
logistiqu et des raisons sécuritaires et
d'ailleurs c'est les seuls que vous
pouvez mettre en avant puisque de fait
vous ne pouvez pas mettre en avant que
c'est un meilleur jugement ou en tout
cas une meilleure façon de rendre la
justice on pense au contraire que ça
entrave le bon déroulement de l'audience
que la la compréhension est beaucoup
plus difficile pour pour les personnes
retenues il y a un rapport qui est sorti
qui s'appelle en finir avec les
audiences par visio de l'Observatoire de
l'enfermement des étrangers et il dit
que l'utilisation de cette technologie
porte atteinte au droit de la défense et
plus largement au droit à un procès
équitable en violation de l'article 47
de la Charte des droits fondamentaux qui
dispose que toute personne a droit à ce
que sa cause soit entendue équitablement
publiquement et dans un délai
raisonnable et nous rejoignons ces
arguments pour demander la suppression
monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je voit qui vote pour contre
rejeté le votre amendement le 1677
monsieur le rapporteur c'est en
cohérence un peu avec ce qu'on a fait
aussi à l'article 21 et je vous propose
de de préciser la finalité de bonne
administration de la justice en vertu de
le laquelle il peut-être recouré à la
vidéo
audience je je le mets au voix qui vote
pour
contre adopté le 678 monsieur coulom il
tombe ah
attendezou non effectivement on a on a
rédigé laalé à 4 bon c'est pas grave je
veux le défendre quand mêmeme vous
pouvez pas le défendreil est tombé
monsieur c'est bien essayé le 1390
madame yad défendu monsieur le
rapporteur favorable favorable qui vote
pour contre adopté le
1678 toujours en cohérence je le mets au
voix qui vre pour contre
adop vous pouvez alors 1498 monsieur
Lucas merci monsieur le Président vous
connaissez notre collègue taché il il a
à cœur de de coconstruire et donc il
propose un amendement de repli qui vous
offre si je pu dire une une porte de une
porte de sortie c'est bien c'est bien là
sa capacité à à faire synthèse on le
remercie défendu défendu monsieur le
monsieur
rapporteur avis défavorable ce n'est pas
conforme à l'état de droit en vigueur
monsieur de la porte oui merci pour
compléter la défense de de mon collègue
Lucas ce que dit cet amendement c'est
que la télécommunin l'audience par
télécommunication audiovisuelle ne peut
se tire sans le consentement express des
partis et ça c'est important parce que
dès lors qu'il y a un refus de l'une ou
de l'autre des parties et bien on arrête
cette visionférence et bah c'est c'est
une garantie procédurale importante et
elle devrait être adoptée sinon ça
risque d'entacher d'inconstitutionnalité
cet
article monsieur le rapporteur alors
chers collègues je je le rappelle mais
ce n'est pas conforme pourquoi parce
qu'en fait on peut déjà permettre de
recourir à la vidéo audience devant le
JLD dans le cas du contentieux du
maintien en zone d'attente ou de la
ration la rétention administrative le
recours à la vidéo audience est engadré
par toutes les garanties nécessaires
pour assurer la tenue d'une audience
dans le respect des droits des partis le
Conseil d'État dans son avis sur le
projet de loi a estimé qu'elle était
qu'elles étaient entourées de garanties
suffisantes et n'a pas fait du
consentement des partis une condition de
validité de cette disposition donc
défavorable moi ce que je remarque quand
même c'est que toutes et tous ici vous
devez recevoir dans vos permanences des
gens qui viennent vous voir avec des
problèmes de régulisation de titre de
séjour de rapprochements familiaux et
cetera et ces gens-là qui demandent à
avoir des droits qui leur soit ouvert
pour pouvoir vivre dignement et en
liberté sur notre territoire bien
souvent qui travaillent et cetera eux
par contre ils n'ont pas droit à la
vidéosurveillance avec la préfecture où
on pourrait imaginer à la vidéo
pardon la vidéo VX audience vidéo pardon
excusez-moi oui ouais ouais intéressant
ou ouais je suis peut-être en train de
me
radicaliser c'est ça donc donc encore
une fois on a une déshumanisation de la
justice lorsqu'il s'agit
d'industrialiser en quelque sorte la
répression et puis finalement l'absence
des des services publics lorsqu'il
s'agit d'accorder des
droits monsieur Lucas merci Monsieur le
le président quand même je voulais
verser à la discussion les observations
de l'Observatoire de de l'enfermement
des étrangers he qui constate quand même
que l'usage de la visioconférence altère
profondément le déroulement des
audiences et et compromet le droit à un
procès équitable je crois que c'est
quand même quelque chose qu'on doit
prendre en compte quand on quand on fait
la loi sur ce sujet le consentement des
personnes étrangères devient ainsi un
rempart nécessaire pour pour garantir
une justice respectueuse de leurs droits
fondamentaux et la visoconférence en
éloignant physiquement les personnes
étrangères crée un déficit significatif
de compréhension de compréhension pardon
des enjeux de de l'audience la présence
physique est cruciale pour permettre à
la personne de suivre et comprendre les
débats renforçant ainsi l'équité du du
procès je crois quand même que ça c'est
un constat et et une aspiration à
laquelle nous devrions toutes et tous
souscrire qui ve être pour l'amendement
contre il est rejeté le suivant n'est
pas défendu l'article 24 qui vot pour
contre adopté le 669 madame auenau
oui merci monsieur le Président nous
souhaitons supprimer cet article parce
que nous considérons d'une certaine
manière qu'il fait peser
sur les personnes les manques de moyens
de de la justice 43 nous considérons
également que la la privation de liberté
ne doit pas excéder 24 heures queles que
soient les circonstances et les
dysfonctionnement éventuel de de
l'administration et donc l'article qui
permet en fait de augmenter le le délai
qui maintient les personnes
simultanément un certain nombre
d'étrangers en zone d'attente nous
semble un délai trop important et que il
faudrait se donner les moyens pour que
les juges puissent être statués
rapidement afin de réduire au maximum
le temps de rétention des personnes dont
on prive qu'on prive de leur
liberté je vous remercie le suivant le
956 monsieur de la
porte monsieur Savignac je prends oui
cet amendement 956 vise à supprimer
l'article 25 qui porte le dél de
jugement de la requête au fin de
maintien en zone d'attente de 24 à 48h
en cas de placement simultané dans une
même zone d'un nombre important
d'étrangers ça me permet de parler donc
à la fois de ces zones d'attente qui
sont parfois surchargé donc qui peuvent
conduire à ce qu'il y ait des procédures
extrêmement accélérées et que les droits
finalement de la défense soit nié ça me
permet par extension d'évoquer ce que
cet amendement qui a été déclaré
irrecevable par le président de la
Commission au titre de l'article 45 qui
visait notamment à étendre le droit et
les garanties procédurales des zones
d'attente aux personnes ne placées plus
de 4 heures dans des locaux de mise à
l'abri ce qui selon le Conseil d'État
est interdit or ça arrive extrêmement
souvent que ce soit à Menton à
Montgenèvre et donc voilà je je je suis
absolument abassourdi par cet article 45
qui à mon sens n'était pas justifié et
donc j'alerte monsieur le ministre sur
le non respect des droits individuels le
non respect des droits à la défense le
non respect des droits des personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui en zone de mise à l'AB
dans les locaux de mise à l'abri à la
frontière franco-italienne le 108
monsieur Lucas merci merci madame la
Présidente nous proposons également de
supprimer cet article avec les mêmes
arguments que que mon collègue vientv de
développer parce que il conduirait à
allonger le délai de jugement des des
requêtes au fin de maintien en zone
d'attente ces zones constituent des
lieux privatifs de liberté
particulièrement oxyogène hein comme le
souignne les témoignages non seulement
de nombreuses associations mais aussi
les propres récits que nous pourrions
fournir au débat mais il nous faudrait
bien plus qu'une minute comme le
rappelle le Conseil constitutionnel dans
sa décision du 25 février 1992 le
maintien d'un étranger en zone de
transit en raison de l'effet conjugué du
degré de contrainte qu' le revê et de sa
durée a pour conséquence d'affecter la
liberté individuelle de la personne qui
en fait l'objet au sens de l'article 66
de la Constitution l'allongement du
délai de jugement est une atteinte à la
dignité comme au droit des personnes
concernées nous considérons donc que cet
article doit être supprimé je vous
remercie le suivant le 1220 madame
fossillon euh oui je rejoins mes mes
collègues sur cette demande de de
suppression je on pense que
l'allongement du du délai qui permet un
un enfermement plus long des des
personnes étrangères il est en réalité
uniquement ici justifié par des
questions logistiques de manque de de
moyens humains et matériels et je dirais
de volonté de mettre les moyens humains
et matériels et ce n'est pas acceptable
on voit bien ici que en réalité vous
anticipez de possibles nouvelles
arrivées d'ailleurs quand quand il est
indiqué que c'est quand un nombre
important d'étrangers on sait d'ailleurs
pas ce que veut dire ce terme
d'important c'est quand même une notion
assez floue mais que vous anticipez
potentiellement des nouvelles arrivées
donc plutôt que de préparer les moyens
pour pouvoir les accueillir en réalité
vous réduisez encore un peu plus la
garantie de leur
liberté je vous remercie pour répondre à
cette série d'amendements monsieur le
rapporteur sur lequel je seraai
défavorable mais je vais expliquer un
peu madame Tor s'il vous plaît un peu de
décence
par je tiens en premier à souigner que
ça existait déjà le JLD auprès du JLD ça
veut dire la disposition existait déjà
et dans ce qu'on a appelé l'affaire
Ocean Viking par que on a rapporté au
sein de la commission des lois sur une
mission d'information flash comment ça
s'était passé le procureur de la
République avait demandé au juges de
pouvoir rallonger le délai d'une journée
mais
l'écriture ne le permettait pas donc les
juges ont pris la décision de ne pas le
faire l'idée c'est pas de dire que si
demain on a à roissi 10 ressortissants
en plus dans la journée on va rallonger
le délai de 24 he quand on dit un nombre
important c'est par exemple l'accueil de
l'cean Viking avec 200 plus de 200
ressortissants qui arrivent d'un seul
coup sur une sur dans un département qui
n'est pas préparé à recevoir autant de
ressortissants pour lesquels les juges
ont été prévenus en dernière minute donc
l'idée c'est de pouvoir leur permettre à
eux de trouver le temps de pouvoir
apporter les bonnes réponses je rappelle
qu'on a retiré le jour franc aussi tout
à l'heure donc il y a aussi ces règles
d'application qu'on peut qu' peut
apporter donc il y a un ensemble de
sujets là c'est une on est dans un cadre
exceptionnel concernant le rajout de 24
heures pour le le JLD c'est pour ça que
je suis compte d'ailleurs je déposerai
un amendement moi-même de réécriture euh
du moins d'apport complémentaire sur
l'écriture il faut vraiment qu'on tire
faut vraiment qu'on tire les leçon de ce
qui s'est passé à Toulon euh je veux
dire on a eu un problème même d'humanité
on a euh des ressortissants qui sont
arrivés dans des situations très
complexe euh à qui on a demandé de faire
des alers-retours entre hier Exen
Provence avec une un besoin
exceptionnel en terme de mobilisation
d'agents de police et de gendarmes pour
les sécuriser alors qu'on aurait pu
apporter d'autres réponses si on
permettait d'avoir un délai
complémentaire ce qui n'a pas été
fait je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
oui merci madame la Présidente non c'est
vraiment un article très important
l'article 25 parce qu'il il évoque
effectivement le régime du JLD d'abord
le juge de liberté de la détention je
voudrais redire ici que c'est sa
position est garantie par l'article 66
de la Constitution qui donne à
l'autorité judiciaire les garanties la
gardienne pour citer le la constitution
des libertés individuelle donc il faut
évidemment être très attentif à ce que
nous faisons et cependant je vis
constater qu'il n'impose pas c'est
article 66 de la Constitution que
l'autorité judiciaire soit saisie
préalablement à toute mesure privative
de liberté mais il exige en revanche
qu'elle puisse contrôler et mettre un
terme à tout moment avec deux garanties
essentiel le contrôle exercé par
l'autorité judiciaire qui doit être
maintenu tout au long de la privation de
liberté c'est une décision du Conseil
constitionnel de 2011 et l'autorité
judiciaire qui conerve la possibilité
d'interrompre à tout moment la
prolongation du maintien en rétention
nous sommesnous très attentifs
évidemment à l'équilibre de ces deux
conditions mais ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne peut pas modifier ce régime des
juges de liberté de la détention je
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'on on a beaucoup
modifié ce ce régime depuis le début de
ce texte article 12 le juge tient
particulièrement compte des
comportements menaçant l'ordre public
vous nous l'avez euh adopté article 23
on augmenté à 4 jours au lieu de 48h la
durée de la première phase de rétention
et l' article 25 prévoit trois
modifications ces trois modifications
sont les les suivantes on revient sur le
comportement de l'étranger euh qui euh
quand il est très dangereux on revient
sur la forme des nulités ça ça me paraît
important on prévoit un appel suspensif
au-delà du parquet parce qu'aujourd'hui
le préfet peut faire un appel mais il
n'est pas suspensif alors que le juge
des libertés de la détention av voir son
sa décision suspendue par le parquet je
regarde notamment les parlementaire
Maorais c'est c'est quelque chose de
très important qu'ils avaient réclamé
jadis et donc là je pense que c'est un
point très important et puis enfin en
effet
avec les conséquences de l'EN Viking ou
234 personnes madame fosstillon pour
pour parler de de gens nombreux pour
essayer d'expliciter ce que c'est
quelque chose de nombreux mais aussi à
la Réunion où nous avons vu arriver par
exemple en 2022 le même jour cinq
bateaux représentant 140 migrants SRI
Lanquais et puis 54 autres qui étaient
arrivés dans un territoire qui n'avait
pas l'habitude de les avoir il y a une
difficulté cette difficulté c'est en
effet que le JLD ne juge qu'en 24 heur
c'est pas qu'une question de moyen on
l'a vu dans C Viking mais vous avez un
rapport ça a été dit c'est aussi une
question
de durée des audiences et lorsque la
durée s'arrête à minuit les juges sont
là les policiers sont là tout le monde
est là mais comme il est prévu 24 heur
les juges et les avocats donc s'arrêtent
alors qu'il y a effectivement encore
tous les moyens pour le faire donc c'est
pas une question de moyens madame
fusillon je voudrais ici le le souligner
c'est une question d'organisation
puisqu'à minuit on doit arrêter les les
audiences qui était strictementossible
dans l'affaire sa Viking comme dans
l'affaire de de la réunion avec les S
lanés donc nous proposons 48 he au lieu
de 24 4h c'est pas non plus
extraordinairement ambitieux mais c'est
nécessaire pour le fonctionnement de la
justice et je voudrais ici vous lire
puisque nous parlions de l'article 66 de
la Constitution que le Conseil d'État
n'y a vu aucun problème juridique je
cite au Conseil d'État il relève que le
D de 24 he la au JLD peut effectivement
s'avérer trop bref lorsqu'il doit
statuer sur un nombre important de
requêtes simultanées dans ces conditions
le Conseil d'État je le cite toujours
estime que l'atteinte Porée à la liberté
d'aller venir est regardé comme
nécessaire adapté et proportionné je
pense que on peut se ranger derrière cet
article très important qui change il est
tout à fait vrai la façon dont le JD
fonctionne mais en garantissant
évidemment l'article 66 de la
Constitution et en tirant les
conclusions notamment des avis du
Conseil
d'État madame
Martin d'abord passer de 24h à 48h en
zone d'attente ça n'est pas forcément si
anodin que cela et par ailleurs non
c'est ça donne vraiment le le sentiment
que ce sont les personnes qui sont les
variables d'ajustement vous nous dites
le derrière cette notion ce mot
d'important il peut y avoir des
situations où il y avait 234 personnes
ok mais enfin on peut pas faire la loi
de cette façon-là avec un terme qui est
aussi vague c'est pour cette raisonlà
que nous avons l'intime conviction que
ces personnes deviennent les variable
d'ajustement fon dans le même sens que
que ma collègue ellisa Martin
effectivement
235 à devoir gérer dans dans dans dans
un service juridictionnel c'est c'est
beaucoup
euh la question c'est qu'il est bien
écrit d'ailleurs un nombre important
d'étranger au regard des contraintes du
service juridictionnel donc on vous vous
dit que c'est quand même des questions
logistiques c'est que vous-même dans le
texte vous écrivez que c'est un nombre
important au regard des contraintes du
service juridictionnel monsieur le
ministre dit c'est quand il y en a 235
non non mais c'est un exemple mais c'est
quoi un nombre important d'étrangers
écoutez le rassemblement national dès
qu'il y en a deux c'est trop d'accord
donc dans la loi dans la loi non mais
comprenez ce que je dis dans la loi
c'est dans la loi ça vous le savez bien
ça ne veut rien dire donc moi notre
crainte pour le dire très clairement
au-delà des arguments invoqués pour du
point de vue du droit et cetera et des
principes c'est que à tout moment le
service il dit là il y en a beaucoup on
passe la loi nous le permet ils ont dit
important bah c'est important au regard
du service juridictionnel qui est
affaibli donc il y a quand même un petit
problème d'écriture de la loi dans ce
cadre làà monsur de la porte oui merci
donc bon j'entends vos éléments monsieur
le ministre mais nous on se réfère quand
on lit l'article enfin laave de la
Défenseur des droits elle est
extrêmement inquiète sur les sur les
garanties procédurales elle évoque
également un élément qui est que le juge
ne peut peut désormais statuer lorsqu'il
est saisi d'une demande de prolongation
du maintien dans zone d'attente au-delà
de 4 jours que sur l'exercice effectif
des droits reconnus à l'étranger et pour
exercer ce contrôle le juge tient compte
du délai de notification de la décision
de placement une notification tardive
nuisant à l'effectif des droits or le
nouvel article réduit le champ du
contrôle puisque une une décision
notifiée rapidement l'intéressé ne porte
pas atteinte l'exercice effectif de ces
droits ça c'est un des éléments que je
voulais dire le deuxième élément c'est
que vous n'avez pas répondu sur ce que
je j'ai j'ai dit sur ce qui se passe à
la frontière franco-italienne euh avec
des personnes qui n'ont pas de droit
n'ont pas de garantie procédurale et qui
peuvent être maintenu euh dans des
mesures privatives de liberté pendant
des durées qui dépassent 4 He ça peut ça
a pu atteindre au début de l'année 4
jours et forcément plus de 4h puisque à
partir de 19h le poste de police aux
frontièr italien est fermé jusqu'au
lendemain matin 7h ça veut dire que les
personne passe forcément la nuit dans ce
poste donc ça fait plus de 4 heur une
nuit monsieur le ministre donc c'est des
personnes qui devrai être en zone
d'attente et qui n'ont pas ses droits
alors je mets au voix ses amendements de
suppression qui vote
pour qui vote
contre sont rejetés le 1679 monsieur
mendz l'amendement en fait permet de
revenir à l'écriture initiale proposé
par le gouvernement et la modification
apportée par le sén ne correspondait pas
et on avait pas l'efficacité donc voilà
la
proposition je mets au voix qui vote
pour l'amendement du rapporteur qui vote
contre il est adopté fait tomber les
deux amendements suivants parce qu'il
rédige l'article
25 l'article 25 bis monsieur Lucas le
69 merci monsieur le Président un
amendement de je pas également un
amendement de de suppression de cet
article lui aussi issu du du musée des
horreurs sénatoriale en limitant la
prise en compte des nulités par le juge
des liberté et de la détention alors
qu'entat actuelle du droit celles-ci
sont celles qui pent atteinte aux droits
des étrangers cet article propose un
affaiblissement des droits des étrangers
sans aucun intérêt en terme d'accueil ou
d'inclusion et restreignant le droit au
recours effectif voilà pourquoi nous
proposons la suppression de cet article
euh monsieur carbrat oui merci monsieur
le Président pour compléter ce que vient
de dire mon collègue Lucas on a beaucoup
dénoncé ce musée des horreurs
sénatoriale venue la droite sénatoriale
euh bon il y a des hreurs aussi qui sont
venus euh d'amendement du gouvernement
au Sénat celui-ci en fait partie il
ajoute un critère d'atteinte
substantielle au droit pour le prononcer
de la main levée de la rétention donc on
considère que dans le contexte actuel
vous considérez que dans le contexte
actuelune menace forte pour la sécurité
des personnes sous droit en France il
est nécessaire d'adapter le régime des
nulités le gouvernement a trouvé vous
avez trouvé judicieux d'ajouter un
disposition une disposition prévoyant
que le juge des libertés de la détention
prend en compte la dangerosité du
comportement de l'étranger avant de
retenir une nilité rappelons que les
nilité pris en compte par le juge des
libertés des détention sont celles qui
pent atteinte au droit des étrangers et
que la dangerosité éventuelle du
comportement de l'étranger visé ne
serait échapper au magistrat
spécialisld nous considérons cette
mesure C sécuriser les formes
procédurales pour le placement ration
altère le droit des
étrangerssur de la
porte de suppression monsieur
monsieurac il est défendu monsieur le
Président Madame fon défendu monsieur le
rapporteur
défavorable j'ai même pas coupé mon
micro monsieur de la porte vous êtes
déjà en train de RER défavorable il
permet de limiter les nullités en cas
dans 1 3 dans laquelle elles ont
véritablement eu des conséquences pour
l'intéress on va revenir ce que vous
disez tout à l'heure je tiens à rappeler
que l'article 7431 du C limite déjà le
prononcer des nitéscepti d'affecter les
retention administratives au seul cas de
la violation des formes prescrites par
la loi à peine de nullité ou de de
l'inobservation des formalité
substantielle et uniquement lorsqu'elle
sont cette violation ou cette
inobservation a eu pour effet de porter
atteinte au droits de l'étranger c'est
c'est juste une mise en conformité cet
article avec ce que nous avons voté
précédemment donc je le mets au voix qui
vote pour l'endement de suppression qui
vote
contre il est rejeté l'article 25 bis
qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
adopté l'article l'amendement 662 madame
torignia alors nous souhaitons supprimer
cette 25e terre
horreur qui a été rajouté au Sénat par
le gouvernement et qui permet en fait de
donner les moyens au parquet et à
l'autorité administrative pour éviter
que des étrangers entre guillemets au
comportement particulièrement dangereux
puisse quitter le centre de rétention
avant que la Cour d'appel ne se soit
prononcée
ce qui marque un nouveau désaveux de
l'autorité judiciaire au au profit
pardon de l'autorité
administrative donc voilà pourquoi nous
y
sommes opposés madame fion défendu
défendu monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable l'extension qui
apporté par par cet
article c'est pour des particul des
actes particulièrement graves on est on
parle quand même de
personn condamné à une peine
d'interdiction du territoire pour des
actes de terrorisme ou s'il fait l'objet
d'une mesure d'éloignement etdictée pour
un comportement lié à des activités à
caractère terroriste comment pouvez-vous
madame Tor vous opposer à
ça madame
t mais en fait moi ce que je pense c'est
que c'est le juge qui doit le décider
parce que nous sommes dans un état de
droit c'est ce que nous revendiquons
depuis le début c'est c'est bizarre que
vous n'acceptiez pas qu'on puisse
défendre cette idée que nous pensons que
la c'est ce genre de décision doit être
prise par un juge et pas c'est c'est
bizarre que vous le compreniez pas non
plus voyz je vais vous renvoyer le même
compliment monsieur de la porte
oui non c'est juste une question de
garantie procédurale et droits au procès
équitable droit au recours effectif là
en l'occurrence si on formule un appel
très bien mais si on n'est pas en mesure
derrière d'effectuer son appel et bien
en fait c'est qu'on a pas d'appel et
donc on a limité un droit
constitutionnel monsieur rapporteur
général
oui il me semble quand même que le le
rapporteur sur ce plan a été
parfaitement clair lorsque il y
a des
activités terroristes et que ces
activités terroristes ont été la cause
de la mesure d'éloignement mais pardon
mais il me semble pas tout à fait
délirant qu'on considère que les
procédures les procédés dilatoires
existe et que dans certains cas il faut
y mettre fin veut dire c'est c'est une
mesure c'est une réserve d'endre
publique en réalité mon cher
collègue je mets au voix c'est
amendement de suppression du 25 terres
qui vote pour qui vote contre sont
rejetés je mets au voix l'article 25 TER
qui vare pour qui vre contre il est
adopté on va changer de
rapporteur on pas gagner 2
minutesg va faireon
susp ah il vonter vouz attendre
minutes
on va attendre que le dérouleur
s'actualise parce que certains
amendements du rapporteur ne sont pas
intégrés au
dérouleur
allez on y va monsieur le rapporteur on
commence par un amendement qui est le
vôtre merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues nous voilà tout à fait pr fra
et dispo pour entamer le titre 6
outre
absolument ce que vous faites pour moi
sans moi fait contre moi dis nel
salmandellaa et je voudrais saluer la
démarche du ministre d'armanin qui a
considérer une demande récurrente des
ultramarins de pouvoir être considéré en
dur dans la loi et non pas être traité
par ordonnance et c'est une démarche que
j'encourage la majorité le gouvernement
à faire pour chacun des textes c'est
vrai que ça demande un peu de travail
puisque il faut faire des auditions il
faut rencontrer il faut discuter
mais euh les autr maèires sont sensibles
à cette
démarche-là quelle méthodologie
avons-nous adopté pour pouvoir traiter
ce titre outreemire je rappelle pour euh
ceux qui doivent le savoir que avant le
Sénat tous les autres mères étaient
traités par ordonnance et euh à la
sortie du Sénat il y a les départements
d'utreemè c'est-à-dire Guadeloupe
Martinique Guyane Mayotte réunion plus
un territoire article 74 Saint-Pierre et
miclon qui a été traité comme
possible dans la loi en
dur nous nous sommes assurés auprès de
ceux qui restaient en ordonnance qu'il
voulait bien rester toujours en
ordonnance et c'est le cas puisque je
rappelle que nous avons pris le temps
avec l'administratrice ici à mes côtés
Camille qui a fait un gros travail euh
auditionner les autres territoires et
que ce soit
Nouvelle-Calédonie Polynésie waliss
Futuna Saint-Martin Saint-Bart ils nous
ont exprimé leur volonté de rester par
ordonnance donc ce que nous allons
étudier là dans le dur ce sont
effectivement les départements plus
Saint-Pierre mlon qui avaient cette
volonté là donc premier article premier
amendement 1724 il a simplement euh pour
but de rapatrier je dirais nos textes
qui étaient un peu disséminés jusqu'à
maintenant
ailleurs dans un article un titre 6
outre
maire alors je vous mets au voix
l'amendement du rapporteur qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est adopté le 811
madame
fossillon merci monsieur le président un
amendement à l'initiative de de mon
collègue David riman qui
s'inscrit dans la volonté des territoire
de de Guadeloupe de Guyane de Martinique
de la réunion de Mayotte et de
Saint-Pierre et mlon et bien de de
pouvoir avoir des des mesures qui sont
applicables de plein droit parmi les
adaptations il y a il y en a aucune qui
prévoit une déclinaison différencier du
schéma national d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile et et d'intégration des réfugiés
et cet amendement vise à inscrire dans
la loi la prise en compte effective des
territoires ultramarins dans la dans la
rédaction et la déclinaison de ce
dispositif monsieur le rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président chers collègues
faossillon c'est un excellent amendement
du président riman dans la mesure où il
consacre une injustice euh puisque il
n'y avait pas jusqu'à maintenant un
schéma national d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile etintégration des réfugiés en
autre m c'est une anomalie qui doit être
corrigée donc c'est un avis favorableur
monsieur le rapporteur favorable je le
mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est
adopté le suivant le
812 toujours amendement à l'initiative
de de David riman celui-ci vise à
inscrire dans la loi cette fois la prise
en compte des territoires ultramarins
dans la régionalisation du schéma
national d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile et et d'intégration des
réfugiés monsieur le rapporteur oui
merci monsieur le Président merci AC
fossillon là aussi un amendement du
président de la délégation trire des
viriman guyanet qui est tout à fait
justifié dans la mesure où c'est la
déclinision régionale du schéma national
donc avis favorable monsieur le ministre
oui oui favorable
également vote pour qui vote contre il
est adopté on passe à l'article 26
monsieur
porte merci monsieur le Président un
amendement qui s'oppose à ce que la
représentation nationale délègue au
gouvernement le soin de légiférer par
ordonnance par principe on considère
même s'il y a des spécificités que c'est
à la représentation nationale de de
s'exprimer sur ces sujets et qu'il faut
que ce soit le Parlement qui a
l'émanation du vote de la représentation
qui puisse s'exprimer sur ces sujets
donc on est opposé à déléguer via
ordonnance au gouvernement pour
légiférer sur ces
sujetsl monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le député porte a raison d'ailleurs je
l'ai dit en introduction nous ne voulons
plus et j'espère que la représentation
nationale l'entend la majorité le
gouvernement à ce que les e TR mèes
soient traités par ordonnance et
Monsieur le Député por je vous propose
de retirer votre amendement parce qu'il
est satisfait dans la mesure où les
territoires qui le souhaitaent les C
départements plus Saint-Pierre et miclon
ont l'opportunité c'est ce que nous
faisons actuellement de pouvoir
légiférer dans le dur dans la loi donc
proposition de
retrait monsieur
portes le maintien vous le
maintenez bon ok je le mets au voix qui
vote pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
euh le
1397 qui le défend madame rol merci euh
c'est un amendement de ma collègue
Sabrina sbahi qui s'est posé à ces
questions simples est-ce que l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant est un objectif de
moindre importance pour les territoires
d'autre mère est-ce que la rétention
administrative des mineurs de moins de
16 ans semblerait plus acceptable quand
elle aurait lieu dans les territoires
d'outr mè en tout cas plus acceptable
qu'en métropole sa proposition
d'amendement est aussi évidente que la
réponse à ces questions l'interdiction
du placement en rétention administrative
des mineurs de moins de 16 ans prévu à
l'article 12 de ce projet de loi doit
s'appliquer sur l'ensemble du territoire
national le gouvernement ayant prévu
d'adapter les dispositions de la loi au
territoire d'outr-emè par voie
d'ordonnance ce qui a donc modifieré il
est essentiel de s'assurer que cette
interdiction y sera appliquée de la même
manière l'enfermement des des mineurs
est intolérable ou qu'elle se déroule et
nous ne devrions même pas avoir à
rappeler cela aujourd'hui on va pas
refaire les débats de tout à l'heure
bref voilà le sens de cet amendement
monsieur le rapporteur en fait cet
amendement signale que les ut TR mèes
sont traités par ordonnance ce qui n'est
plus tout à fait juste je viens de le
rappeler et deuxièmement il y aurait le
cas concernant les mineurs de maillot on
va parler assez souvent parce qu'il y a
des amendements qui vont venir
mais en réalité pour Mayot il y a une
situation et le ministre l'a déjà
expliqué mais il redira que on ne peut
pas tout de suite permettre au mineurs
de Mayotte de ne plus être en situation
de rétention parce que sinon où est-ce
qu'ils iraient et ça créerait plus de
désordre que d'ordre donc pour ces deux
raisons
défavorables madame vous
maintenez je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
pardon je vous bon voà madameoufa mes
excuses et votre amendement
1264 merci monsieur le Président alors
cet amendement vise à supprimer une
disposition particulièr l'une des
nombreuses dérogations particularités
bizarrement bizarrerie euh dont nous
avons le secret à Mayotte cette
disposition particulière permet aux
représentants de l'État de renouveler
les cartes de séjour pour les étrangers
polygames donc euh il ne ne nous semble
pas acceptable de maintenir cette
dérogation
euh
qui je pense compte tenu de l'arrêt de
la polygamie à Mayotte suite à la
départementalisation on ne comprendrait
pas que les étrangers soient eux
autorisés à le rester je vous
remerci monsieur le rapporteur c'est ton
avis favorable collègue yousoufa tout à
fait il est normal que le doit appliqué
à Mayotte soit appliqué et aligné sur le
doit
commun monsieur coulom alors c'est juste
une petite remarque presque
rédactionnelle en quelque sorte c'est
pourquoi on précise de polygame et puis
dans un comment dire une précision de
genre on ne dirait pas aussi et
polyandre pog de polygam tous les deux
oui madame youa alors en l'occurrence la
pratique étant la polygamie et non la
polyandri à Mayotte bien qu'une femme à
Mayotte puisse avoir plusieurs maris au
cours d'une vie mais jamais en même
temps par contre il se trouve que ces
mieurs ont toujours l'ambition d'avoir
eux plusieurs plusieurs femmes en même
temps euh et et là je vous rappelle
quand même que en fait normalement la
polygamie c'est l'égalité entre toutes
les femmes et c'est rarement le cas
parce que ces messieurs ont plus
d'ambiux d'ambition de capacité alors
cet amendement 1264 qui vote pour pour
l'amendement 1264 qui vot contre il est
adopté le 1408 madame
yousoufa
allez-y
1408 excusez-moi
président alors c'était un amendement
qui reprenait la discussion qu'on a eu
précédemment à savoir que nous
souhaitons écarter de l'obtroi de toute
forme de titre de séjour l'étranger qui
conteste l'intégrité territoriale de la
République française ainsi définie par
ses frontières nationalesous faisons
évidemment référence au conflit avec les
Comor qui
revendique qui revendique maotte et et
donc nous avons sur le territoire de
Mayotte beaucoup de comoriens qui
arrivent qui obtiennent des papiers pour
mieux contester Mayot françaisise donc
nous souhaitons avoir la possibilité de
leur refuser tout titre de séjour à
Mayotte je vous
remercie monsieur rapporteur sur le fond
je partage l'avis de la collègue
yousoufa sur la forme en fait en fait je
vous proposerai un retrait puisque il a
été satisfait par l'amendement
préalablement adopté le
1107 euh dans les heures
précédentes je le retire est
effectivement satisfait je vous
remercie pouvez continuer avec le 1116
madame yufa merci beaucoup alors euh
toujours sur la question de de de ce
conflit avec les Comor il nous semble
important d'enrichir le programme de
formation civique qui est dispensé à
Mayotte dans le cadre du contrat
d'engagement républicain pour inclure un
volet dédié aux frontières de Mayotte et
de la République française de son
appartenance je me suis dit que c'était
pas inutile pour les étrangers mais
peut-être aussi pour mes compatriotes
puisque vous n'ignorez pas que nous
sommes français depuis 1841 grâce au
sultan Andrian Souli et que lors des
indépendances les Maorais à l'inverse
des des autres habitants des îles de
l'archipel des Comores se sont battus
pour rester français et que vous
n'ignorez pas que que je porte les
couleurs de zenam Deré qui est une des
grandes chatouilleuses les femmes qui se
sont battues dans notre société
matriarcale pour que Mayotte reste
française ce serait quelques uns des
éléments que nous pourrions inclure dans
ce programme civique je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur oui il est tout à
fait normal qu'un étranger qui veuille
être et s'installer en France puisse
partager les valeurs et principes de la
République àis favorable monsieur le
ministre je je veux juste dire à madame
la députée yousoufa mais comme également
au député camardine puisque c'est
d'ailleurs lui qui m'a interpellé sur ce
point que ce n'est pas des débats
ésotériques indépendamment du fait que
maotte évidemment un territoire français
comme tous les autres mais il y a eu un
une décision de justice très récemment
d'un magistrat qui a refusé la rétention
d'un homme s soi-disant que en
explicitant expressis verbis que comme
Mayotte était contesté à l'ONU comme
étant française
alors cette personne pouvait pas être en
rétention parce que le territoire était
peut-être pas français et c'est un
magistrat en poste en France à Mayotte
qui le dit cette cette décision de
justice existe signée par greffier donc
je pense que il est très important que
le législateur comprennne que la pour
nos amis maorés qui ont choisi de très
nombreuses fois de rester français et
depuis extrêmement longtemps il faut
réaffirmer et c'est un point très
important que Mayot non seulement est
française bien évidemment AC l'intégrité
du territoire et son histoire française
c'est important que l'Assemblée
nationale s'en occupe parce que
lorsqu'il y a des décisions de justice
qui j'espère seront cassé en appel si
jamais le pourvoi est formé on puisse
bien rappeler que Mayotte est un
département Fronçais Monsieur
camardine Merci monsieur le Président je
pense que vous aurez également dans
l'alliace que je défends un amendement à
peu près similaire je suis heureux que
le ministre de l'Intérieur a pris la
peine de préciser ce point parce que moi
je j'ajouterai simplement là aussi un
rappel basique que on nous apprend tous
sur les bans de la fac que les décisions
du Conseil
constitutionnel s'applique
ou s'oppose à toutes les institutions de
la République par une décision du 30
décembre
1975 le Conseil constitutionnel a dit
que maot est française elle ne peut cess
d' appartenir sans la volonté de ces
populations comment peut-on imaginer qui
magistrat français qui rend sa décision
au nom du peuple français donc qui se
trouve confronté ou comment direje qui
doit respecter la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel puisse
écrire dans une décision que Mayotte est
contesté qu' ne peut pas euh mettre
quelqu'un en rétention parce que maotte
serait contesté à l'ONU par une
puissance étrangère je crois que cela
montre bien de deux choses l'une où il
est magistrat français il exerité en
France et à ce moment-là la décision du
Conseil constitionnel s'oppos à lui où
il n'est pas magistrat français à ce
moment-là il n'a pas sa place là
monsieur
vilité je ne vais pas être très long
mais je voudrais simplement confirmer
appuyer sur cela euh il y a en effet
quelques magistrats quelques juristes
qui s'appuie sur les argusis de l'ONU
pour en fait refuser au Maorais le fait
d'être un peuple qui peut déterminer son
venir et vouloir rester dans la
République et qui considè que som toute
on aurait dû gommer ce vote et ne pas
laisser la parole à ceux qui vivaient
sur ce territoire et je pense que ce que
nous on là participe à cette
réaffirmation du droit des Maoris à
rester dans la République s'il le
souhait donc je mets au voix
l'amendement deadameou avec l'avis
favorable du rapporteur qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est adopté le 1330
madameoua je vous rends allez-y alle-y
allez-y pourtant
défendu il est
défendu monsieur le
rapporteur le 1330 merci n pas de micro
non plusci Alley
défavorable comme
ça pardon excusez-moi
président en fait là aussi une une
condition dérogatoire pour le niveau de
langue exigé pour obtenir des papiers à
Mayotte et donc il
s'agissait de de de reprendre les
critères qui sont au niveau national au
niveau national c'est-à-dire un niveau
de langue
élémentaire en français pour la première
délivrance de différentes cartes de
séjour pluri-annuel dans le département
de Mayotte je vous
remercie monsieur rapporteur oui même si
effectivement le niveau de langue le
français minimum et et normal euh vous
sollicitez là par contre l'AVE du maire
qui semble difficilement praticable dans
l'opérationalité euh ensuite l'octroie
du titre de séjour pluannuel est déjà
prévu dans l'article 1 du projet de loi
euh concernant les conditions de langue
donc à la fois en partie satisfait et
deuxièmement difficilement praticable
donc plutôt demande de retrait ou
défavorable monsieur le ministre oui
autant on peut comprendre effectivement
au niveau de de langue il y a aucun
problème et je pense qu'on peut y
travailler ensemble madame la députée en
revanche la vie du indépendamment du
fait que c'est un petit peu compliqué à
mettre en place je pense qu'il va avoir
des pressions assez fortes aussi vu les
imbrications parfois familiales on l'a
vu sur les reconnaissance de paternité
on l'a vu sur un certain nombre de sujet
qui se passe à Maillotte pression sur
les élus municipaux pour donner un avis
positif sur les tites de séjours que
peut-être le préfet refuserait je suis
pas tout à fait certain que tous les
maires pourraent résister à à ces
pressions mais vous savez connaissez
mieux votre département que moi donc on
peut travailler autour de la langue
peut-être le retirer on peut peut-être
imaginer que le maire peut s'opposer ça
peut être aussi une possibilité mais
quelque chose qui serait optionnel il
pourrait sans saisir s'il a une une un
avis négatif s'il voit un trafic une
difficulté particulière parce qu'il
connaî aussi l'économie informelle dans
l'archipel mais le rendre obligatoire je
crois que ça irait à l'inverse de ce que
vous
souhaitez madame
la merci il est retiré donc le 1330 le
1415 vous pouvez la 14 oui
1415 merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à ce que soit consulté
les collectivités territoriales de
Mayotte pour définir les métier en
tension sur notre territoire je vous
remercie nous reconnaissons bien là
l'ADN de madame ysoufa qui fait partie
du groupe
lot et les territoires sont primordieux
je partage tout à fait le fond de votre
demande je vous propose de le retirer
parce qu'il sera satisfait par un
amendement du rapporteur qui va englober
l'ensemble des territoires
ultramarin rime avec maot et donc je
retire372 madame la
rapporteur pas
encore
alors cet amendement vise de à lever
certaines protections absolu et relative
concernant les mesures d'expulsion pour
les étrangers condamnés en première
instance pour des faits de violence viol
et agression sexuelle uniquement dans le
département de Mayotte compte tenu de la
surpopulation dans le centre carcéral de
magicavo qui a 250 % de taux
d'occupation qui entraîne on l'a
entendu dans les déclarations des
procureurs successifs des peines
prononcées moins
importantes et et nous nous retrouvons
donc dans une situation particulière à
Mayotte où nous vivons avec nos bouraux
je vous
remercie monsieur
rapporteur voilà eu
effectivement c'est une demande qui en
réalité est déjà satisfaite par
l'article 9 de la loi qui vise la levée
des protections contre les étrangers euh
dès qu'ils ont un comportement qui
constitue une menace grave pour l'ordre
public euh les Crimé deslit auxquel vous
faites référence serait possible de
quantomme de peine plus important que
ceux auquels vous faites référence et
enfin euh pose problème pour cet
amendement en tout cas de la
condamnation première instance qui n'est
pas définitive donc je vous propose euh
de le retirer au profit de l'amendement
suivant madame la députée
Youssoufa monsieur le
ministre non mais si si effectivement je
pense que on comprend bien ce que veut
faire madame la la députée moi je suis
très favorable au 1383 donc je CIS qu'il
y a pas de sujet pour qu'il soit me
semble-t-il adopté le 1372 en effet pose
une question constitutionnelle
incontestablement la difficulté c'est
que vu les les les sujets à Mayotte on
pourrait imaginer que le juge
constitutionnel quand même pourit
regarder les choses œil positif mais
c'est un risque à prendre donc si on
veut assurer C 383 si on prendre le
risque C 372 malheureusement il y aura
pas de texte immigration en tout cas moi
je m engagerai pas dans l'année qui
vient hein donc il faut qu'on choisisse
voilà donc le gouvernement il a pas
défavorable je pense que la sécurité
plus forte sur 383 mais on suivra la
députée alors madame
yousoufa je suis vos recommandations et
donc retire cet amendement et maintien
le 1383 que qui est donc défendu alors
j'ai l'avis du ministre et l'avis du
rapporteur favorable alors je met au
voit l'article le 383 qu' avis favorable
du ministre et du rapporteur qui votre
pour contre il est adopté et l'article
26 qui votre pour contre
adopté après l'article 26 monsieur le
ministre pour non mais pour que la
séance publique ne soit pas surprise
nous aurons sans doute encore d'autres
amendements maorè à la fois par Madame
Youssoufa et par Monsieur camardine
puisqu'il y a un certain nombre de
dispositions qui doivent être complétés
pour maotte on s été engagé à la fois
qui a été comprise dans la loi Mayotte
proposée par Sébastien le Cornu mais qui
n'a pas été à l'ordre du jour avec un
volet immigration également sur des
sujets qui continuent à toucher le droit
du sol et et du sang à maotte qui est un
un endroit particulier pour la
République on a déjà discuté mais
également d'autres dispositions que
porte notamment le le député camardi
donc je voulais ici dire qu'on nous
reviendrons sur la question maaise à mon
avis assez longuement en séance
publique alors monsieur le rapporteur le
1725 merci monsieur le Président c'est
un amendement technique de rapatriement
de l'ensemble des disposition qui était
dans d'autres titres au titre 6 a TR ma
madame yououfa le
sous-amendement allez-y
mamef merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement vise à modifier
les conditions pour bénéficier du droit
du sol à Mayotte il est proposé que pour
qu'un enfant né sur le territoire
national puisse bénéficier du droit du
sol il est désormais nécessaire que les
deux parents soient en situation
régulière au moment de sa naissance et
ce depuis au moins 1 an je vous
remercie bien monsieur rapporteur votre
avis je rappelle même si vous le savez
ici et je pense le contrôle des deux
députés de Mayotte à peu près un tiers
des étrangers sont cette situation
irrégulière et à peu près un autre tiers
d'étrangers est en situation ça fait
quasiment 2 tiers de personnes
étrangères à maotte c'est ça la
situation que on est bien en tête les
chiffres et donc tout ceci va expliquer
que au fil des amendements à venir il y
aura des dispositions spécifiques pour
Mayot dans celle-ci avis favorable alors
je mere l'amendement j'ai pass monsieur
le ministre pardon c'est un point très
important ce sujet je suis désolé il est
1h6 mais il y a déjà un droit exorbitant
à
Mayotte sur à peu près tous les sujets
et notamment le fait de devenir ou pas
régulier régularisable ou français
aujourd'hui le droit actuel pour que
chacun comprenne validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel et porté par un
gouvernement socialiste puis ensuite par
le gouvernement d'émanuel Macron c'est
que pour avoir la possibilité de
régulariser ou devenir français à maotte
il faut aujourd'hui que l'un des deux de
parents soient français ou régulier et
que il est été 3 mois avant la naissance
de l'enfant c'est évidemment pour lutter
contre les quissaquissa et les
difficultés y compris pour les parti
oriantes qui connaissent des difficultés
je rappelle que à Mayotte il y a
950 naissances hors de l'hôpital fait
par les ST par Piers dans les bangas
donc indépendamment de la question de
l'hôpital public le le le une des
premières maternités de France c'est le
10 de Mayotte que nous avons d'ailleurs
construit avec la collectivité
maahoraaise donc vraiment je pense que
indépendamment des questions politiques
ou idéologiques qu'on peut avoir sur la
vie d'immigration dans le reste de de
notre territoire national il y a maot
sitation particulièrement explosif pour
dans tous les sens du terme d'un point
de vue de santé publique d'un point de
vue de logement d'un point de vue
d'accès à l'eau chacun le sa d'un point
vu de sécurité et moi je veux soutenir
évidemment les propositions de la
députée Youssoufa et du député camardine
sur ce point et apporter mon soutien
également à ces dispositions certes qui
sont différents du droit commun mais qui
qui se justifi parfaitement à ma
alors Madame
rogol Monsieur
léomand Merci monsieur le Président bon
je je comprends le l'idée qui est
derrière ça et que vous expliquez mais
tout à l'heure vous avez dit Madame
yousoufa et fort justement que il
fallait respecter les principes de la
République là c'est une mise en cause
pour moi pour une personne comme moi
c'est une mise en cause fondamentale de
l'idée du droit du sol justement et en
raison de la situation particulière de
Mayotte c'est-à-dire à la fois une
situation géographique particulière une
situation internationale particulière et
aussi une situation des services publics
particulières que vous venez de décrire
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre alors on
en vient à mettre en cause un certain
nombre de principes qui pour moi sont
fondamentaux et les mettre en cause
c'est quelque part faire un aveu d'échec
de ce qu'est la France pour moi donc
quand on dit à la fois que on affirme
l'existence de Mayotte à l'intérieur du
territoire de la République française
c'estéta un amendement que vous vous
venez de défendre pour moi en même temps
et ben il faut que on donne les moyens
aux outremèes de d'être réellement la
France et quand je vois les problèmes
qu'il y a notamment autour de l'eau
autour des services publics d'une
manière générale pour moi revenir sur
des principes républicains fondamentaux
c'est quelque part s'écarter de ce que
vous aviez défendu tout à
l'heure chers collègues il me semble
important de rappeler que nous sommes à
Mayotte face à une pression migratoire
qui est organisée par un pays voisin qui
utilise et instrumentalise sa population
et utilise nos propres lois contre nous
contre notre territoire c'est défini par
l'Union européenne et par l'UTAN comme
une menace hybride ce n'est pas votre
servante qui l'invente c'est reconnu par
notre pays comme une menace hybride ce
que je vous demande ce que nous vous
demandons c'est qu'à mayillotte qui est
visé par cette opération qui
instrumentalise les flux migratoires qui
utilise le le trafic humain la détresse
de la population qui utilise des enfants
qui sont des véhicules pour obtenir des
papiers dans une situation qui est
anormale qui est tragique d'essayer de
mettre fin à cet appel d'air avec des
lois particulières qui sont validées
avec évidemment le contrôle du Conseil
constitutionnel qui jugera Infiné pour
nous permettre à nous de pouvoir être à
la hauteur des principes que vous
affirmez et à laquelle nous au
mer monsieur le ministre prend votre non
mais à la fois sur le fond et sur la
forme je pense avoir explicité pourquoi
les services publics connaiss ces
difficultés je voudrais quand même aussi
dire et ça c'est un point très important
à Mayotte sur le service public de de
l'enfance où l'État fait des choses
exorbitantes je pour dire à Monsieur à
Monsieur léomand c'est nous qui payons
nous l'état donc vous avec les crédits
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat qui
qui construisont 100 % des crédits du
système scolaire et on doit construire
plus de 30 écoles par an à maillot et et
aujourd'hui les enfants qui soient
étrangers ou ou français bien évidemment
ils ont une demi cours de jour par par
un demi une demi matinée une
demi-journée pardon par jour de cours
donc je pense que les principes de la
République ne sont plus tenus à Mayotte
si on part du principe qu'on doit tous
les appliquer dans un territoire
effectivement très particulier je je
rappellerai aussi pour le pour les
commissaires au lois s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît pour les
commissaires aux lois également pour no
débats pour le Conseil constitutionnel
je rappelle que la République si elle
est une indivisible permet de des
différenciations très fortes sur le
territoire ultramarin c'est le cas de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie je rappelle quand
même qu'on a une double citoyenneté et
pour autant il y a une
volonté pardon bon par par trois fois
les Calédoniens ont voulu rester
français voilà et et mais si c'est vrai
et et maotte par deux fois les Maoris
ont décidé de rester français donc non
ben si je peux le dire donc il y a des
droits différenciés sur les territoires
de la République il est normal d'adapter
des droits il y a pas de remise en cause
dans ce que dit Madame yousoufa
profondément du droit du sol et du droit
du droit du sang elle ne dit pas qu'il
faut supprimer le droit du sol à Mayotte
elle dit qu'il faut éviter elle elle
touche pas les étrangers regardez bien
son amendement elle dit que les gens
doivent être réguliers avant la
naissance de l'enfant pour que cette
naissance de l'enfant soit le fruit de
l'amour et que leur présence sur le
territoire de la République soit le
fruit de l'envie de l'adaptation aux
règles françaises et je pense que
personne ne peut être surpris que à
Mayot dans des conditions où le
rapporteur dire 1/ers de la population
immigrée les les parlementaires Maoris
disent parfois 60 % voilà donc c'est la
vérité entre 1/3 et 60 % pour avoir été
de très nombreuses fois maot mais les
parlementaires mauris pour en parler
bien mieux que moi évidemment la
situation est très particulière et
touche le cootidien de tout le monde des
Français des réguliers et des
irréguliers et il y aura une catastrophe
humanitaire et sanitaire et civile à
maotte si nous ne prenons pas nos
responsabilités et là Monsieur Loman je
crois que les principe de la République
ils vont être en difficulté voilà donc
je je comprends votre prop propos
monsieur Loman je je le je départage pas
je dis juste qu'à une situation
particulière c'est pas la fin du droit
du sol à Mayotte c'est l'adaptation à
qui ont déjà été validés par le Conseil
constitutionnel on rajoute 7 mois on
veut que tout le monde soit régulier ça
me paraît pas tout à fait désespérant
comme proposition alors Monsieur viltier
puis monsieur cabardine on a eu le débat
un peu plusôt dans la dans la journée
sur le fait que plus les personnes
étaient fragiles plus elles pouvaient
être victimes des passeurs et c'était
bien des personnes qui étaient qui
pouvait être être comment dire mise en
danger par les passeurs là je peux vous
garantir que c'est vraiment le cas parce
que quand les femmes traversaient
enceinte à bord d'esquif qui pouvaient
pas border la mer vous garan dire qu'en
effet là on avait des personnes qui
étaient bien en fragilité qui étaient
bien sous domination des papur parce que
le problème est exactement le même donc
en ayant ces garanties là c'est en
faisant en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus
d'intérêt entre guillemets à arriver sur
le sur le territoire français en étant
enceinte et bien en effet je pense qu'on
protège ces
femmes
monsieur camardin on
votera merci monsieur le
Président moi je voudrais qu'on se m pas
qu'on se dise les choses entre collègues
j'ai eu l'occasion à plusieurs reprises
de vous inviter à venir visiter notre
territoire je vous refais l'invitation
ce soir venez nous voir et une fois que
vous nous aurez vu vous nous direz si ce
que vous vous voyez comme nous de la
situation des personnes qui viennent des
conditions de leur arrivée des
conditions de leur hébergement des
conditions dans lesquelles se trouvent
les main si vous estimez que c'est
normal et que c'est une façon de rendre
service à ces personneslà à ce moment-là
on dira bengo mais je voudrais dire
également on nous a tous appris sur les
ban de la fac que la loi est une norme
de comment d'application générale à une
société donnée sur un territoire donné
pendant un temps donné j'ajoute que le
Conseil constitutionnel admis même nous
là dans la loi Dr DS nous avons admis
qu'effectivement il peut avoir des
adaptations ainsi de suite et le conse
cons est là Rappelz tout à l'heure le le
ministre de l'Intérieur a déjà eu
l'occasion s'agissant de Mayotte de dire
oui le législateur avait la possibilité
de d'aménager donc je crois que cette
disposition nous en avons besoin comme
les autres qui vont suivre derrière nous
en avons besoin pour permettre au Moré
de vivre enfin chez eux de ne pas fu et
venir s'installer à Paris même s'ils
sont fiers d'être
français plutôt à Marseille et à der et
à Marseille évid et à la cour neuve si
j'en
crois et à tout le coin par exemple
alors je met au vo l'amendement de
madame yououfa qui un avis favorable du
rapporteur qui vote pour contre adopté
et le l'amendement du rapporteur
sousamendé qui vot pour contre
adopté le
85 madame
Fillon
oui personne n son micro ce
so merci ici le collègue Davan souhaite
que le
dispositif dérogatoire au droit commun
du contentieux de l'étranger qui est
applicable guyan en matière d'obligation
de quitter le territoire soit supprimé
et qu'il soit aligné sur celui de
l'Hexagone monsieur
rapporteur je regrette que le président
de la
délégation là en personne pour défendre
son amendement on aurait pu en discuter
je dirais entre ultramarin parce que bon
je connais bien la situation de la
Guadeloupe euh je crois connaître un peu
la situation de la Guyane même si c'est
un vaste territoire la situation
d'immigration est préoccupante aussi et
euh avoir des dispositions adaptées à la
Guyane pour avoir une certaine célérité
dans les procédures me paraît justifié
donc avis
défavorable euh monsieur le ministre
oui il y a en guyan une situation très
particulière également du fait de
l'appartenance de la Guyane à son
continent de l'Amérique du Sud et du
fait de frontières qui n'ont rien à voir
aux frontières que nous
connaissons d'abord la forêt amazonienne
au sud évidemment et puis par ailleurs
deux grands fleuves qui empêche le
fonctionnement particulier on peut pas
considérer en effet d'immigration là-bas
comme nous le considérons dans dans
l'Hexagone pour avoir un peu échangé
avec Monsieur riman et avec d'autres
parlementaires guyanis il y a sans doute
un régime d'adaptation à obtenir pour la
Guyane et nous y sommes très ouverts et
compris pour la séance publique avec
notamment la difficulté expressise
verbise de la Guyane c'est pas tellement
les personnes étrangères qui ont des
eqtf que les personnes qui viennent en
visa humanitair par le Brésil et des
Marocains des Afghans qui ne devrai pas
être là qui ensuite arrivent en guyan
pour obtenir l'égalité de visa
humanitaire pour asile et ensuite
veulent revenir en dans l'Hexagone pour
pouvoir dans la continuité territoriale
faire grosso modo Cayenne Paris et et
Paris leur refuse pour une grande partie
et on voit bien au quoi nos compatriotes
guyanaé sont pris par une immigration
qui n'est pas du tout régionale c'est
pas les surinamé c'est pas les
Brésiliens qui sont les premiers touchés
c'est bien ces gens qui font un parcours
de vie très étonnant très difficile
arrivent au Brésil et sont renvoyés
ensuite en en terre française en Guyane
donc moi je pense madame fossillon que
le régime du contentieux de qtf c'est
pas tellement le sujet en Guyane c'est
plus la question de l'asile la demande
d'asile et les refus d'asile ou
l'équivalence entre visa humanitaire il
y a eu un amendement du sénateur guyanet
George passtian qui a été adopté au au
Sénat je propose qu'on y rraavaille
c'est pas un refus par principe de de
cet amendement mais si l'idée c'est une
adaptation particulière on pourra le
faire pour la
séance si vous voulez je je le garde et
je m'adresse aussi à à à Monsieur serva
c'est sûr que dvan pourra défendre mieux
que moi cet amendement mais pour en
avoir discuté avec lui je crois qu'il a
tout à fait conscience des de son
territoire et du fait qu'il y a
effectivement des étrangers sur son
territoire et ce qu'il propose là quand
même c'est que ces étrangers puissent
quand même avoir la possibilité de de
pouvoir contester la légalité de l'qtf
c'est juste leur assurer des droit et
parce qu'il connaît bien son territoire
il souhaite aussi que les personnes qui
sont présentes puissent sur le
territoire puissent pouvoir avoir des
garanties dans leur droit et donc de
pouvoir contester une qtf il le présente
il vient de guyan et ne venant pas de
guyan je le soutiens également dans
cette demande
oui monsieur le rapporteur oui bien sûr
chers collèg vous êtes tout à fait
légitime il y a pas de souci mais je
maintiens et je leured dis j'aurais aimé
qu'il le défende lui-même ici ce soir
monsieur lomand et après on votera
merci merci monsieur le Président je
trouve intéressant les les deux
amendements en réalité de Monsieur ran
le 815 et le 814 parce que c'est des
amendements qui proposent de revenir sur
des dérogations qui existe dans les outr
mèes c'est un peu la logique inverse que
celle qu'on avait tout à l'heure qui
proposait des nouvelles dérogations et
pour
avoir
euh en avoir discuté en enfin en
commission la dernière fois je ne sais
pas si vous vous souvenez de cette prise
de parole de Monsieur Rimen justement
qui disait mais ce que nous voulons dans
les outresmèes c'est que ce que nous
nous donnons comme droit en tant que
Français républicain s'applique partout
dans les outremèes et pour cela cela
demande des moyens et je crois que c'est
ce que demande monsieur ran d' manère
générale c'est que on ne on on ne
continue pas à traiter les outresmèes
d'une manière qui leur donne
l'impression qu'ils sont traités plus
faiblement que d'autres départements de
la République française et sur cette
question là la Guyane pour que chacun
ait bien en tête de quoi il s'agit c'est
un un département qui fait la taille du
Portugal d'accord avec la plus longue
frontière terrestre de la France qui est
avec le Brésil donc effectivement il y a
des questions particulières mais on les
trait mieux en étant des républicains
convaincus je le mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeté monsieur le
rapporteur le
6765 je un amendement de Madame yousoufa
le
787 merci monsieur le Président alors
cet amendement vise à préciser dans la
loi les conditions pour bénéficier du
regroupement familial le code de
l'entrée du séjour de l'étranger du
droit d'asile exclu notamment du
regroupement familial un membre de la
famille dont la présence en France
constituerait une menace pour l'ordre
public cet amendement vise à compléter
les conditions des exclusion du
regroupement familial mais à Mayotte et
à exclure le membre de la famille qui ne
reconnaît pas l'appartenance de Mayotte
à la France ce qu'on a évoqué un peu
plus tôt je vous remercie monsieur
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
je soutiens l'esprit de cet amendement
collègue Youfa mais nous avons identifié
un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité nous vous
proposons de le retirer pour mieux le
retravailler en séance s'il vous plaît
monsieur le ministre oui nul ne peut
être nul ne peut être inquiété pour ces
pour l'expression de ces opinions même
religieuses donc éventuellement
évidemment même politique donc c'est
sans doute à C inconstitutionnel en
revanche comme vous l'a dit monsieur le
rapporteur si ça entraîne le troup à
l'ordre publ et ce qui est le cas
souvent d'ailleurs dans le territoire
Maoré là ça tombe sous le coup de
l'ordre public et pas de l'expression
politique donc je pense qu'on peut le
retravailler en effet pour la séance
madame je retire merci retirz Monsieur
serva votre amendement
1765 oui monsieur le Président merci
vous avez dit mon amendement j'aurais pu
dire c'est l'amendement de Saint-Pierre
mi clon puisque nous avons en fait
échangé avec les forces de Saint-Pierre
mlon c'est-à-dire le pouvoir local les
parlementaires en présence du préfet et
c'est eux qui ont émis cette volonté
quelle est-elle il s'agit en fait de la
régularisation des travailleurs sur les
métiers en tension ils ont estimé que
gar au fait qu'ils ont que très peu
d'immigration sur leur territoire
euh considérant aussi que ils ont besoin
souvent dans certains métiers de
travailleurs venant de l'extérieur ils
souhaiteraient après une régularisation
d'une année pouvoir permettre une
régularisation pluriannuelle de ces
travailleurs concernant les métiers
ention alors je le mets au voix qui vote
pour l' du rapporteur qui vote
pour contre il est adopté le 1770
monsieur le
rapporteur
oui c'est aussi un amendement très
important c'est à fois là une demande de
l'ensemble des territoires ultramarins
qui ont été auditionnés de façon unanime
où il s'agit de parler de la
territorialisation finalement de cette
commission qui va statuer sur les
métiers entention et les acteurs locaux
sous l'autorité du préfet souhaite une
commission consultative qui permette
avec
les forces consulaires avec T ceux
toutes celles qui ont connaissance des
métiers enention de pouvoir
s'exprimer sur cette liste annuelle des
métiersention et je rappelle que c'est
amendement unanime de l'ensemble des
territoires
auditionn je mets au vo l'amend du
rapporteur qui vote pour contre
adopté
814 défendu monsieur
rapporteur
même défavorable également non madame
frill vous AZ pu le défendre
[Rires]
plus non c'est un amendement où nous
avons un avis très
favorable du président ran qui a pu le
défendre luême vous le défendez très
bien à sa
place c'est favorable alors je le mets
au voix qui vote pour contre adopté le
813 Monsieur
camardine Merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement propose de
rallonger le délai de justification de
la part d'un parent pour pouvoir
prétendre à un titre de séjour au titre
de fait qu'il est papa d'un enfant voilà
et et cette-ci est justifiée par le fait
que souvent les les gens qui font ça
arrivent comme ça de manière occasionnel
à produire un
[Musique]
un une facture d'achat d'un stylo ou
d'un crayon parce que désolé monsieur le
ministre mais la préfecture n'a pas les
moyens de contrôle et à ce moment-là on
on renouvelle les titres de séjour donc
il faut peut-être qu'on peiss justifier
que sur une durée un peu plus longue
effectivement que le papa entretient son
enfant avant de pouvoir prétendre à des
droits tirés de C de ce qu'il est perdun
enfant euh en situation régulière se
place
voilà alors monsieur le
rapporteur nous considérons euh monsieur
le député camardine que cet amendement
est satisfait euh par l'article 13 bis
du projet de la loi du Sénat donc nous
proposons de le euh retirer s'il vous
plaît monsieur le
ministre
Olivier laisser favorable alors
finalement c'est un avis favorable du
rapporteur qui qui a échangé avec le
ministre
donc alors l'excellent
rapporteur un avis favorable
effectivement alors avis favorable du
rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote contre
adopté le suivant c'est le vôtre
monsieur le rapporteur
1727 il faut vous rendre les micros
voilà c'est un article qui rat un
article sur le
titrere le 14g qui vote pour contre
adopté le SU monsieur le
rapporteur là encore ça pourrait être
l'amendement des quatre députés
Guadeloupéens cette
fois-ci parce que nous subissons en
Guadeloupe une insécurité croissante
liée entre autres pas que pas que je le
dis mais pour tous ceux et toutes celles
qui pourrai mal interpréter mes propos
mais aussi lié à une immigration
clandestine à une importation d' d'armes
à une importation de drogue et donc ce
que nous voulons comme ailleurs comme ça
se fait par exemple à Mayotte nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait un rapport
monsieur le ministre euh pour pouvoir
étudier les possibilités de renforcer
les moyens technologiques et humains
pour contrôler nos côtes qui sont
d'ailleurs archipéliqu et qui nous
permettrai d'être assuré que tout ne
rentre pas de façon clandestine et avec
des risque de violence avéré chez nous
en
Guadeloupe monsieur le ministre oui un
avis favorable monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur alors je dire en
deux mots il y a à Martinique avec
saintlucie en Guadeloupe avec la
Dominique mais pas simplement une
difficulté en effet migratoire qui peut
être lié à une partie d'insécurité qui
n'estévidemment pas la seule raison
d'insécurité quiévoque unanimement les
élus de Martinique et les élus de
guadeloup dont vous êtes quel que soit
leur bord politique et chacun sait que
pour une grande partie d'entre eux ils
ne soutiennent pas le le gouvernement en
Martinique nous avons mis un préfet
délégué à la sécurité qui a vous l'avez
vu travailler et je crois grandement
réussi à faire des propositions j'ai
fait la même proposition Guadeloupe il y
en a donc désormais un et vous savez que
je vais venir sur dans votre magnifique
île monsieur le rapporteur très bientôt
mais je veux bien m'engager en effet
pour voir les moyens les moyens alors
peut-être qu'on le corrigera peut-être
légèrement si vous le souhaitez en en
séance pour que ce ne soit pas qu'un
moyen qui touche le ministère de
l'intérieur parce que notamment dans les
Antilles mais c'est aussi vrai à la
présence des armées de leur technologie
de leur action aide vraiment à la
surveillance des côtes et à la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière c'est
le cas des des radars des des drones et
de manière générale des contrôles des
des des grands ports maritimes qui
posent un certain nombre de de
difficultés donc je je veux vraiment et
puis bien sûr du secrétariat général à
la mer don on dépend directement la qui
dépend directement de la première
ministre donc on modifiera peut-être en
séance pour bien que ce soit
interministériel parce que souvent le
ministre d'intérieur se retrouve un peu
seul parfois à défendre les les les
autres maires je sais que le ministre de
des armées sera particulièrement
sensible mais peut-être que l'écrire
c'est c'est mieux saiton jamais et en
tout cas un avis favorable même si c'est
vraiment un des des seuls rapports que
je vais
accepter contre il est adopté le 1771
monsieur le rapporteur
oui alors nous sommes sur une loi pour
contrôler l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration nous avons pas beaucoup
entendu améliorer l'intégration et nous
vous proposons
euh amendement parce que nous avons
additionné euh l'entreprise each one
dirigeant Theos Cuba et je peux vous
dire que j'ai été impressionné par sa
capacité à permettre aux étrangers qui
ont du mal avec le français tiens c'est
le sujet de la loi ou qui ont du mal
tout simplement à pouvoir être formé et
bien sa capacité à les intégrer de cette
façon-là et c'est peut-être l'une des
réponses à tout ce et toutes cell qui
voient à
l'étranger un être menaçant et bien je
propose cet amendement pas que pour les
étrangers parce que chez nous en autre
mare nous avons trois fois plus de
chômage qu'en hexagone et donc il y a
aussi des gens éloignés de l'emploi qui
mériterait une formation pour mieux les
insérer par exemple cette structure a un
taux de réussite et d'intégration en
emploi de 80 %. donc voilà monsieur le
ministre un rapport sur cela pour aussi
améliorer l'intégration monsieur
ministre
ministre alors je suis je suis embêté
que sur un deuxième rapport et surtout
que qui concerne le ministère du du du
travail je propose qu'on l'adopte
monsieur le rapporteur et qu'en séance
peut-être les les différents ministres
puissent s'exprimer sur cette question
je comprends tout à fait la question des
demandeurs d'emploi et et la difficulté
en NRE maire donc on va dire un avement
favorable maintenant et on en recnera la
présence peut-être en séance publique si
vous le voulez bien alors je mets au
voix avec favorable du ministre qui vote
pour contre adopté article
27 amendement de Monsieur
Lucas merci Monsieur le le
président l'amendement de suppression de
cet article 27 la France a signé la
Convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant et le comité des des droits de
l'enfant chargé du contrôle de
l'application de ce texte à affirmé sans
ambage que l'enfermement des enfants
pour des raisons migratoires était
contraire au principe de l'intérêt
supérieur de le de l'enfant l'objectif
poursuivi par le projet de loi
concernant cette disposition étant de
prendre en compte la vulnérabilité
particulière des mineur et donc d'agir
en conformité avec les obligations
internationales de la France par
conséquent cont tenu de l'objectif
urgent et primordial poursuivi en la
matière un report de l'entrée en vigueur
au 1er janvier 2025 nous apparaît comme
injustifié cet amendement proposé par
France Terre d'Asile la Fédération des
acteurs de la solidarité et le forum
réfugié cosi il suit également les rend
les recommandations pardon de l'UNICEF
en matière de droits des enfants je su
rapporteur merci Monsieur Lucas sur le
sur le sur la forme en fait l'amendement
supprime le mauvais alinéa puisqu'il
supprime l'alinéa qui se fonde sur le
texte initial et non pas celui transmis
par le Sénat mais surtout et ça je le
redirai dans quelques amendements et
donc je vais pas trop le répéter mais je
le dis maintenant euh je rappelle la
problématique des mineurs à Mayotte si
vous supprimez cela et bien vous
supprimez aussi la capacité à gérer euh
beaucoup de mineurs à Mayotte et le
ministre je crois va s'exprimer sur
cette questionlà donc surtout pour
raison là même si en plus sur la forme
il n'est pas bon avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre oui entendons-nous
bien il s'agit pas de revenir sur les
dispositions très importantes et il
serit comme sou rapporteur général de la
suppression la présence des des mineurs
dans les centres de rétr administratif
et dans les LRA mais dès le début
j'avais annoncé que Mayot était une
exception parce que d'abord le régime
des personnes qui sont dans le Crâ
Maillotte et notamment dans le Crâ de de
Petite Terre comme je dit tout à l'heure
ne sont pas les mêmes types de deux
personnes qui sont sur les cras de
l'Hexagone ou des autres territoires
ultramarins donc je pense qu'on peut pas
tout à faire faire la comparaison
deuxièmement vu la la la difficulté
d'action monsieur le député Lucas je
sais pas si vous êtes déjà allé dans
l'archipel Maoré mais il y a à Mayotte
plus de la moitié des reconduites à la
frontière que nous faisons nationalement
alors quand on parle des chiffres de
reconduites à la frontière on parle
jamais de maillot on les sort par par
honnêteté intellectuelle mais cependant
si on devait les additionner plus de la
moitié des reconduites de la frontière
sont faites de toute la France sont
faites à maotte et donc évidemment
énormément de de familles je prends
l'exemple de 2019 c'est le cas de 663
hommes 1651 femmes 3191 mineurs c'està
direire qu'il y a 7 fois plus de femmes
et d'enfants que d'hommes dans
l'immigration maoraise et puis
évidemment quand on regarde 2022 si je
prends l'exemple le plus récent 917
hommes 1678 femmes 3443 mineurs donc si
vous mettez pas les mineurs dans centre
de rention administratif nous n'y
arrivons pas alors cependant ce qu'a dit
le gouvernement c'est qu' était pour
surtout le territoire national y compris
Mayot pour la suppression des minant
dans SRA donc ce que nous avons proposé
c'est nous laisser un peu de temps parce
que en étant honnête avec l'article 27
vous aurez constaté qu'il y a une un
décalage de date il n'y a pas l'idée
queon apppplique pas à Mayotte il y a un
décalage de date pourquoi parce que
d'abord on va construire un deuxème
centre de rétention administratif euh
sur Grande Terre parce qu'il faut savoir
que comme la de rétention administratif
est sur Petite Terre il faut prendre une
barche pour aller euh sur Grande Terre
pour pouvoir éloigner vers les Comores
enfin bref c'est assez compliqué
évidemment à organiser pour y mettre
notamment un CR spécialisé dans les on
va dire les personnes les plus les plus
dangereuses les plus radicalisées il y a
un tout petit peu de radicalisation à
maot mais il y a beaucoup de personnes
évidemment qui sont violentes et qui
relèvent de de la politique hexagonale
que nous mettons mais pour ça faut un
deuxième cras qui a été annoncé financé
et qu'il faut évidemment construire et
le deuxième c'est qu'il faut transformer
le premier CRAT et avoir d'autres lieux
de rés résidence notamment des hôtels
mais il y a peu d'hôtels à Mayotte il
quelquesuns qui sont excellents mais peu
d'hôtels sont à Mayotte surtout de ce
côté-là du territoire c'estàd entre
Petite Terre et Grande Terre entre
mamouzu et Petite Terre et là il faut
évidemment y mettre des moyens
d'infrastructure impossible de le faire
bien sûr en quelques jours puisque je
vous rappelle que un am du Sénat a éé
adopté notamment du groupe socialiste
pour dire que la fin des mineurs dans
les cras c'était la probbligation de la
loi donc soit on décale soit on décale
tout sur un modèle 26 mais là évidemment
l'Hexagone qui est les plus concerné
vous dirait vous reculez pour mieux
sauter so on accepte le décalage qui a
un décalage de concret voilà la
politique c'est l'idéal à travers des
réalités on ne sait pas faire un
Maillotte autrement donc je rappelle en
plus qu'à Mayotte pour avoir visité
plusieurs fois le cran de Mayotte ce
n'est pas le même univers carcéral c'est
pas non plus un centre de loisir mais
c'est pas un univers carcéral comme on
en connaît dans lescas d'île-de-fance ou
d'ailleurs sur le territoire national
donc franchement monsieur Lucas je sais
pas si vous retirez votre amendement
mais mais ce n'est pas l'objet de cet
article que de ne pas appliquer à
Mayotte ce que nous avons décidé c'est
juste de nous permettre de mettre les
moyens de le faire
voilà madame
yousoufa je pense que il est important
ici de de rappeler qu'à Mayotte nous ne
sommes pas une population sans cœur une
population sans humanité une population
qui peut entendre la moindre leçon sur
l'accueil plus de la moitié des
personnes sur notre île sont
étrangères nous avons des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants qui sont avec des
adultes dont le L de parenté est quand
même très suspect sinon complètement
inventé l'enfance à Maillotte elle est
effectivement en danger pensez que de
d'interdire l'éloignement ou
l'enfermement pour
l'éloignement va les protéger c'est un
enfer pavé de bonnes intentions parce
que ça va augmenter les abandons à
maotte et ces enfants qui sont déjà en
grande difficulté qui sont souvent dans
des conditions d'insalubrité qui V dans
des conditions d'insalubrité
innommable vont continuer à subir des
déchirements familiaux et je pense que
c'est ce que vous devez aussi garder à
l'esprit et c'est pour ça que je me fais
l'écho de l'invitation qui a été lancée
par mon collègue Mansour venez à maotte
vraiment nous vous accueillerons les
bras ouverts et venez regarder la la
réalité du terrain je pense que les
grands principes maotte a beaucoup à
vous apprendre sur la
question alors met au voix l'amendement
de Monsieur Lucas avec défavorable du
rapporteur qui vot pour contre rejeté le
suivant madame jaie Laforge merci
monsieur le Président en fait il a été
présenté dans le cas du titre premier en
fait c'est un déplacement donc voilà on
a déjà eu la
discussion je mets au voix alors
Monsieur rapporteur vous êtes favorable
favorable je mets au voix qui vot pour
contre adopté suivant madame
Fillon défendu madame Martin
on réaborde le le le sujet que d'une
certaine façon nous venons nous venons
d'aborder il faut qu'on trouve la
solution j'entends qu'elle soit complexe
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de mineur non
plus h enfin à maotte en l'occurrence
alors il y a peut-être quelque chose qui
peut nous permettre de nous en sortir
c'est qu'il est écrit dès que possible
et il y a sans doute des modalités
d'accueil plus que d'enfermement qui qui
sont à revoir puisque vous-même vous
dites que l'univers carcéral est moins
est moins prignant au cras au cras de
maotte pour les enfants j'entends hein
pour pour les
mineurs bon nous j'avoue hein je le dis
clairement on maintient on maintient
cette cet amendement parce qu'il nous
semble que par principe il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver surtout surtout sil y a
un accord général pour dire qu'il y a
qui a une enfance en danger qui a des
liens discutables avec les adultes bon
et cetera donc j'imagine évidemment
qu'ils soit enfermés ensemble j'ai
compris mais il me semble qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver d'autres façons
de
fairefendu défendu monsieur le
rapporteur pour les mêmes raisons
défavorables
madameon oui merci monsieur le Président
je pense que c'est c'est une discussion
importante parce que ça touche comme l'a
indiqué notre collègue
léomand à notre
conception de la patrie républicaine et
la question par rapport aux
interpellations des collègues Maoris
n'est pas que nous ne croyonss pas ce
que vous dites euh et que nous mettions
en doute des éléments que tous les
rapports que toutes les associations que
tous les élus font depuis des années
nous ne
pensons
ça fait 30
secondes
voilà
euh la suite est est importante parce
que la question c'est que nous ne
pensons pas que la politique menée et en
fait qui s'accentue je me rappelle les
débats que nous avions eu déjà lors du
précédent mandat et qui avait donléneux
à des restrictions nous ne pensons pas
que en fait justement c'est la solution
dans ce sens-là et et que en fait ça
nous entraîne à avoir toujours plus de
restrictions qui ne répond pas en fait à
la situation donc c'est vraiment ce
n'est pas une mise en doute de la
réalité de la difficulté des
particularité c'est simplement que de
fait
l'expérience des des années passées
montre que le choix restrictif des
droits et libertés fondamentales
n'apporte pas la solution et et ne peut
qu'entraîner en fait à une escalade de
restriction
Mad alors en l'occurrence les les
exceptions sur la question du du droit
du sol comme de
l'enfermement sont extrêmement récentes
donc là ce dont on est en train de vous
parler c'est le droit commun bête et
méchant qui en fait ne fait que donner
plus de droit pour les étrangers à
Mayotte et qui en fait sans que les
moyens que vous évoquez régulièrement
soi donnés à notre territoire sans
prendre en compte sans prendre en compte
la réalité de euh de l'insularité
qui fait qu'en fait nous on a quand même
des zones où il y a déjà la densité de
Hong Kong c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on n
pas un territoire extensible on peut pas
continuer à dire surtout quand par
exemple le reste du territoire national
ne veut pas appliquer la solidarité
nationale ne serait-ce que pour la
circulaire tobira ben en fait à un
moment il va falloir accepter que vous
pouvez commencer par le commencement
c'est-à-dire mettre en place toute la
solidarité nationale avant de nous dire
vous serez gentil de limiter les
monsieur camardine et après on
votera merci Monsieur monsieur le
Président on vous met au courant vous
demandez à ce qu'on vous mette au
courant on vous met au courant et
immédiatement au pouvoir au pouvoir non
au courant déjà au pouvoir on verra au
courant
déjà on vous met au courant déjà
allons-y par
étape Mayot c'est
374 km Carr les amis
ça c'est la carte 374 km² c'est 450000
habitants soumis à la règle de 3 tiers
1/3 de franc c'est vous et moi 1/3 de
régulierers qu'on a qu'on a mis là qu'on
veut pas laisser partir et tout à
l'heure des amendements comme ça vous
allez tous voter contre ces
amendements ensuite ensuite il y a le
tiers qui sont des clandestins autrement
dit aujourd'hui Mayotte par la
population notamment par la population
réelle je parle pas de la population
légale mais par la population réelle
Mayot n'est déjà quasiment plus
française si on s'appuie sur les
populations c'est comme si on vous
disait que sur l'hexagone sur les 68
millions de population 40 millions étai
des étrangers je ne suis pas sûr que
vous auriez cette sourire ici au sein de
cette commission j'ajoute qu'il y a
actuellement 100000 titr de ce jour sur
place 28 10000 de stock qui demandent à
être traité et qui n'est pas traité et
du coup ça transforme la préfecture en
régularisation permanente c'est plus de
10000 gamins qui sont livrés parce que
tous doivent aller à l'école à Mayotte
pendant qu'il y ait 200000 qui attendent
à 50 km de là 70 km pour aller voilà la
situation par conséquent je crois que
nous ne pouvons pas et je soutiens
complètement ce qui a été dit nous ne
pouvons pas adopter cet amendement parce
que c'est la me façon détuer ce
territoire alors je le mets au voix qui
vote pour contre rejeté l'article qui
vot l'article 27 qui votre pour contre
adopté on passe aux derniers amendements
après l'article 27 monsieur cardine le
732 oui merci monsieur le Président le
732 a pour objet de proposer de limiter
à Mayot le groupement familial à ce que
nous appelons le la famille nucléaire et
tout ça soumis à une durée et notamment
il est proposé que euh le la personne
admis à séjourneré à Mayotte peut
demander à bénéficier de son droit à
être rejoint auut du regroupement
familial par son conjoint sur C derniers
étager d'au moins de d'au moins 18 ans
pour qu'on il y ait pas de des mineurs
euh soumis à des affres du mariage et
par les enfants du couple mineur de 18
ans Monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur la situation particulière de
Mariotte et à la forte proportion
d'étranger rant sur le territoire cela
justifie des mesures dérogatoires avis
favorable c'était
pour
favorable monsieur Lom ouais simplement
pour continuer le débat parce qu'on est
toujours sur sur Mayot
vous savez il y a eu une situation où la
France a d'un seul coup qu'est-ce qu'il
y a allez allez il y a une sit il y a
une situation
où la France a fait a fait une
régularisation massive et c'est une
situation historique
ou mais si vous voulez pas avoir des
débats à 1h du matin faut
[Musique]
B allez bon on en parlera en séance on
en parlera en sé mais non c'est pas
possible on en parlera ensemble on en
parlera on en parlera ensemble et on
fera en séance non je le ferai en séance
bon alors c'est pas grave alors on
parler en séence le 732 qui vote pour
avec la vi favorable du ministre qui vot
contre il est adopté le 1387 monsieur
camardine
1387 amendement monieurésent avec le
micro toujours cet amendement merci
monsieur le Président propose de poser
la condition de tout que tout détenteur
de titre de séjour à Mayot doit
respecter l'intégrité du territoire
national c'est été rappelé mayoté
française par la volonté de ses
habitants nous avons des gens qui
utilisent parce qu'ils savent mieux
notre législation que nous qui détourne
cette législation pour arriver à ma
s'installer y compris pour travailler
pour ensuite pouvoir contester euh
contester la francité de mayott donc
l'idée c'est de vous dire que quand on
vient à mayott on signe un document
qu'effectivement on éait d'être sur un
territoire français monsieur rapporteur
le principe de la faveur est àquis
Monsieur camardine simplement nous
identifion un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité donc nous
proposons de le redéposer pour la séance
le
ministre oui c'est le même que celui de
Madame yousoufa par le jeu des écritures
on sait pas pourquoi il discussion
commune mais on pour riscuter en séance
d en effet qu'il est tard puisquil est
3h46 samamouzou
donc monsieur
camardine retiré euh le 700 alors vous
pouvez poursuivre avec le 766 mais
mettez votre micro pour le 766 s'il vous
plaît
quelqu'un bon merci monsieur le
Président ce le
766 euh propose la levée à Maillotte de
protection contre l'expulsion prévue euh
à l'article 631 l 631 T2 de sesada j'ai
eu l'occasion notamment en décembre 2000
décembre dernier de soutenir une
proposition de loi de l'IR sur ces
questions-là et il été clairement établi
que souvent nous avons des difficultés
avec ces ces protections puisque nous
n'avons pas la possibilité de reconduire
les personnes quel que soit les
difficultés qu'il posaent et donc l'idée
ici c'est de dire que çaagissant des
agissant de Mayotte le 2e 3e et 4e m du
présent titre ne sont pas applicables à
Mayotte pour tenir compte pour tenir
compte de la spécificité de la situation
ou de la particularité de la situation
ou la singularité de la situation de
Mayotte Mons
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
nous considérons monsieur le député
camardine que votre amendement est en
grande partie satisfait par l'adoption
de l'article 9 de la loi qui permet
d'ors et déjà de lever des obstacles à
l'expulsion des étrangers protégés dans
certaines situations donc nous vous
proposons le retrait s'il vous plaît
monsieur ministre oui même avis que
Monsieur que monsieur le rapporteur je
pense que c'est tout à fait puisque
l'article 9 s'applique évidemment à
maotte peut-être vous pourriez le
retirer redéposer juste la trème partie
celui qui concerne les dispositifs de
reconduite d'office des pêcheurs
illégaux puisque c'est une partie de
votre amendement qui n'est évidemment
pas prévu dans la levée des réserves d'
publique général si vous redéposez cette
partie là dans amendement spécifique en
séance moi je donnerai un avis favorable
monsieur camardine retirrez vous pouvez
poursuivre avec le
729 ah oui
je le
729 il s'agit là aussi c'est dans cet
amendement de proposer d'élargir les
possibilités d'expulsion des étrangers
constituant des menaces à l'ordre public
CELI que dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure d'accord bon euh ok bah moi je
je vais bien le retravailler avec cette
idée monsieur monsieur le ministre j'ai
besoin également voyez-vous que parce
que je veux attaquer les les complicités
et les réseaux et notamment les saisies
immobilières euh voilà je suis sous
cette réserve je le retire et nous
l'écrivons ensemble alors retirez le 729
le 757 monsieur
camardine ouais c'est ouais euh merci
mon
assistant cet amendement propose de
renforcer les sanctions pour l'entrée le
maintien et l'appui de l'immigration
clandestine en particulier à Mayotte
contenu de flot euh parce que tous les
jours y compris ce soir monsieur le
ministre nous devons avoir au quelque
chose comme entre 150 et 200 migrants
qui arrivent à
Mayotte monsieur le rapporteur avis de
sagesse monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre bon c'est un amendement
important parce que je sais qu'il est il
est en effet un petit peu tard mais ce
que propose monsieur le député camardine
c'est de doubler les peine du délit
d'entrée irrégulière en imaginant que ce
délit avait été maintenu dans la version
sénatoriale appliquée à l'Assemblée
d'augmenter les peines du délit d'
d'entré en séjour pour les mariages
fruduleux et adapter les dispositions
relatives à la vérification de
l'authenticité des actes je pense qu'il
faut le retravailler monsieur le député
pourquoi moi je suis favorable je le dis
devant la commission des lois à ce déli
de séjour irrégulier à maotte à la
condition que vous retiriez ce qui n'est
désormais plus constitutionnel ni
conventionnel les peines de prison et
qu'on garde l'amende pas tellement pour
l'appliquer que pour pouvoir donner à
maotte les moyens de de lutter contre
ces immigration illégale je pense que
votre deuxème point et votre troisème
point on pourrait en effet également les
garder dans un nouvel amendement que
vous pourriez redessiner donc là je
crois qu'il est clairement
inconstitutionnel si on le déposait
comme ça mais pour la séance si vous le
souhaitez on peut y travailler avec les
administrateurs et et les et les et les
rapporteurs si vous acceptez l'idée que
on on recorrige sur l'amende et pas sur
la peine de prison qui toute façon ne
s'appliquera pas je pense que ce sera un
beau signe pour Mayotte que de le
permettre pour les
policiers merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais simplement rappeler j'ai
conscience que nous avons une prison qui
aujourd'hui est peuplée à
euh j'ai peur de je crois 250 % 250 250
% sur ces 250 % il faut imaginer que 80
% des populations qui sont là qui sont
des qui sont des populations qui ont
commis des infractions graves euh c'est
pour cela qu'ils sont là souvent pour
des lourdes peines l'idée de cette
amendement n'est pas temp d'aller
déférer les gens en prison puisque de
toute façon il y a pas de place de sorte
qu'aujourd'hui même aujourd'hui encore
il y a des gens qui sont condamnés les
les les les peines faibles ne sont plus
exécuté en maison d'arrêt l'idée ici
c'est de permettre et ça ça m'a été
inspiré par les monsieur le ministre par
les les autorités en charge de la lutte
contre l'immigration donc des autorités
étatiques char l'immigration à Mayotte
qui me disent que lorsque ils
poursuivent une personne en situation
irrégulière quand il réussit à pénétrer
dans un banga on est obligé de s'arrêter
sinon c'est une violation de domicile et
par conséquent ça devient inefficace
l'idée c'est de permettre euh NOTAM euh
voilà retiré maintenu
retir désolé
monsieur et le 1388 monsieur
camardine demandez à votre assistant
d'Er le
micro avec le micro monsieur camardine
assistant monsieur camardine
monsieur l'amendement 1388 cet
amendement rétabl c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure rétabl le dél de sjour
donc qu'on avait pour les mêmes raisons
mais je peut-être je vais le retirer
pour permettre et faciliter le débat
pour que je crois que tout le monde est
fatigué pour qu'on
le mais c'est eux qui ont pas voulu
s'arrêter donc on prend le temps qu'il
faut ah si 1300 le tout dernier le 823
monsieur camardine le tout dernier le
823 vous laissez pas déconcentrer par
vos collègues non mais vous savez il
faudrait un peu plus vous voyez cette
tête je crois aussi alors le 823 le 1800
le le le 823 monsieur le ministre il est
proposé que le gouvernement examine les
moyens de développés euh l'efficiente de
la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine à Mayotte en renforçant
l'architecture de l'administration
déconcentré de l'État à Mayotte et
notamment en étudiant la pertinence de
créer un poste de préfet délégué au
pilotage de la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine vous savez
monsieur le ministre sans doute le sait
mieux que moi euh mais aujourd'hui quand
on regarde la la structure de la lutte
contre l'immigration à mayott vous avez
la gendarmerie vous avez la police vous
avez les services de la préfecture sous
l'autorité du secrétaire général et vous
avez un sous-préfet chargé de la lig
tout ce petit monde à mon avis on peut
imaginer qu'il soit regroupé euh euh ou
relié à une autorité en dessous du
préfet mais il fasse autorité commune de
façon à ce que tout le personnel à la
fois militaire policiers et
administratif en charge de la lutte sont
soumis à la même autorité ce qui
permettrait de
c'est des synergies de circulation
d'information de vérification autre donc
plus d'efficiente plus d'efficacité dans
la lutte contre l'immigration à
maotte Monsieur rapporteur
indéiablement on se dit qu'aujourd'hui
Mayot manque de moyens pour lutter
contre l'immigration indéiablement donc
je crois qu'un rapport permettrait
d'avoir un éclairage précis surtout çais
favorable monsieur le ministre favorable
monsieur Lom merci monsieur le Président
simplement pour que si vous retravaillez
les amendements monsieur camardine et
dans cette logique du préfet délégué à
la lutte contre l'immigration que vous
voulez mettre en place même si moi je
préférais un préfet délégué au fait
queon respecte les règles de la
République
partout mais plusieurs plusieurs choses
premièrement augmenter les peines ne
sert à rien toutes les études le
démontrent quand on augmente les peines
ça ne provoque pas une diminution des
actes délictuels qui sont commis par
ailleurs monsieur le ministre vous avez
dit quand même quelque chose d'assez
assez assez étonnant c'est peut-être
parce qu'il est tard mais vous dites on
va créer une amende pas tellement pour
l'appliquer quand même c'est bizarre
c'est bizarre comme manière de faire
vous avez parlé de la peine de prison
qui n'est pas applicable parce que les
prisons sont sur peeuplé mais vous avez
aussi dit on va créer une amende pas
tellement pour l'appliquer et en effet
pas tellement pour l'appliquer parce
qu'une amende de 7500 € avec des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
j'attends de voir qui vont les payer je
je je demande à voir à quoi ça sert de
mettre en place ce type d'amende
monsieur le ministre alors je pense
vraiment qu'il faut que vous alleiez à
Mayotte vous verrez tion irégulère àot
alors sur l'amendement qui a reçu un
favorable qui vote pour contre adopté
le8 581 monsieur
cabrat a micro a
micro merci monsieur le
Président si si mais c'est un amendement
pour demander un rapport sur le
contentieux de masse qui est créé devant
les tribunaux administratifs avec
l'augmentation des otf qui sont délivrés
et notamment sur vos consignes monsieur
le ministre beaucoup deqtf pour un taux
d'exécution faible qui engorge les
tribunaux administratif donc une demande
de rapport monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président je vais peut-être
me prononcer globalement sur les
demandes de rapport le seul
rapport qui recevra un avis favorable de
ma part c'est celui de Monsieur Thomas
porte le 600 qui demande une remise d'un
rapport sur les conditions d'accueil un
autre maire c'est important parce que ça
fera le point notamment sur s'il faut
des CAD ou pas plus de Guda ou pas et
donc c'est ce rapport qui reçoit un avis
favorable 600 pour les autres avis
défavorables pour
tous alors le 581 je le mets au voix qui
votre pour avec un avis
défavorable qui contre rejeté monsieur
kbrat le 836
oui merci monsieur le Président donc par
cet amendement nous proposons que le
gouvernement remette au Parlement un
rapport sur les services de santé dans
les centres de rétention administrativ
ce rapport évaluera notamment
l'opportunité pour l'autorité
administrative d'instaurer des contrôles
sanitaires euh je pense et je l'espère
que tous les collègu commissaire au lois
et je sais que nous sommes très très
très majoritaires à l'avoir fait on ont
fait des visites des centres de
rétention administrative une ou
plusieurs et nous avons tous vu les
problématiques liées à la santé dans ces
dans ces zones de rétention et on est
arrivé dans un à un stade où que ça soit
au niveau des tenu mais aussi des forces
de police qui qui maintiennent ces lieux
dénonce les conditions dénonce les
violences qui sont subites dedans du par
exemple au l'usage de la drogue ou
d'autres problématiques et je pense que
au vu de la du projet qui a été de la
volonté politique qui a été affichée par
le ministre avec le soutien de Monsieur
siti d'ouvrir plus de cent de réttention
en France il serait important d'avoir un
rapport sur ces servic de santé merci
monsieur le rapporteur c'est défavor
je mets au voix qui vote pour contre
rejeté 38 de Madame mard n'est pas
défendu le 173 de Madame
jeunevard il est défendu monsieur le
rapporteur vous êtes toujours
défavorable je mets au voix qui vre pour
contre rejeté le 9 n'est pas défendu le
592 madame
Martin alors donc 2h du matin et il
s'agit tout à fait quelle heure chez toi
il est 4h du matin très bien et 4 heur
chez mon voisin c'est quand même pas mal
ça et donc l'idée c'est d'avoir un
rapport qui nous puisse permettre
d'objectiver les raisons et les
conditions dans lesquelles l'OFI refuse
ou limite l'attribution des conditions
matérielles d'accueil bon c'est
évidemment un sujet qui est majeur
puisquil permet
d'avoir des conditions de survie qui soi
moins difficile voilà quel est le sens
de notre
amendement alors l'AVE est défavorable
du
rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté alors le 600 monsieur porte
monsieur léoman ah c'est lui qui veut la
vi favorable merci monsieur le Président
écoutez il est donc 2h à Paris il est
5h à la Réunion il est 22h en Guyane il
est 21h en Martinique et en Guadeloupe
et il est 4h à Mayotte et il se passe
des choses intéressantes à 2h du matin à
Paris puisque nous avons un avis
favorable sur ce rapport qui vise à
parler des conditions d'accueil dans les
outr-mers et à faire en sorte que le
gouvernement remette un rapport
justement sur ces conditions d'accueil
on a beaucoup parler de la situation
particulière d'un certain nombre de
territoires d'outremer sur les questions
de migration et il semble qu'il serait
une bonne idée d'avoir justement un
rapport permettant d'avoir des
informations détaillées sur les manières
dont sont faites dont est fait cet
accueil dans ces outresères et peut-être
que ça permettrait de répondre à un
certain nombre de questions que nos
collègues ultramarins en particulier ont
posé j'espère que cet avis favorable
emportera l'adhésion de l'ensemble de
nos collègues je mets au voit
l'amendement qui vote
pour contre il est adopté
le 508 n'est pas défendu le
588 Monsieur
coulum Merci monsieur le Président qui
reste encore un peu vif à 2h du matin
ici à Paris donc c'est un amendement
dont l'objet est de disposer d'un
rapport annuel pour notre Parlement de
façon à ce que nous connaissions le coût
humain et financier de l'enfermement t
ut en rétention administrative qu'a opté
pour lequel la France a opté C
associations de droits humains la simade
France Terre d'Asile forum Réfugiés
Groupe SOS solidarité et solidarité
Mayot identifie que nos 25 centres de
rétention administratif
lescas ont enfermé 15922 personnes en
2022 et que même pas la moitié ont
finalement fait l'objet d'une mesure
d'éloignement c'est dire l'échec de
cette politique c'est dire finalement
l'incurie de de ce dispositif et bien je
pense que lorsque nous évaluons entre
1000 et 4000 € le coût d'une détention
en centre de rétention administrative il
est tout à fait pertinent que
l'Assemblée nationale dispose d'un
rapport qui permet d'évaluer à combien
coûte euh le les centres de rétention
administratif monsieur alors il était
bien signataire c'est le 588 par celui
affiché derrière moi
voilà avis défavorable qui vote pour qui
vote contre rejeté le
735 madame auono oui merci monsieur le
Président alors c'est une demande
rapport en fait sur le dispositif
d'information sociale au sein des
préfectures concernant en particulier la
question du droit du travail puisque je
pense que ça c'est un constat y compris
du gouvernement et des députés
Renaissance et d'un certain nombre
nombre de députés sur la manière dont un
certain nombre de travailleurs et
travailleuses étrangères peuvent être
exploité voir leurs droits remis en
cause par des employeurs peu scrupuleux
et il nous semble important de faire en
sorte que ces personnes en préfecture
trouvent les informations qui leur
permettent de faire valoir leurs droit
comme tous les autres salariés et donc
un rapport sur ce sujet permettrait de
notre point de vue de remédier peut-être
à des situations
précarité sociale et informationnelle
qui amène à des situations de
surexploitation défavorable qui vote
pour contre rejeté et enfin l'amendement
de Monsieur tacher le 1453 monsieur
Lucas merci monsieur le Président nous
voilà donc au terme d'une semaine
d'examen de ce texte pendant laquelle
vous avez monsieur le ministre Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs céd en race
campagne au thème et au terme de droite
radicalisée au Sénat qui elle-même court
après l'extrême droite et nous ne
légiférons pas dans n'importe quel
contexte et je le dis avec beaucoup de
gravité malgré l'heure tardive en dehors
de ces murs en fin de journée
aujourd'hui on manifestait dans les rues
de Paris des nazillons animés de slogans
contre les étrangers réels ou supposés
d'ailleurs et je crois que nous avons de
ce point de vue-là une grande
responsabilité qui est de ne pas
entretenir un racisme d'atmosphère qui
s'empare de notre pays et d'un et uit
dans un débat public englouti sous les
thèmes et les termes de l'extrême droite
de ce point de vue là nous continuerons
à combattre ce texte quel qu'en soit la
version qui en réalité participe d'une
analyse qui consiste à donner le point à
l'extrême droite sur sa vision de la
complotiste de la submersion migratoire
et pas à construire une véritable
politique de l'inclusion et de la
fraternité ce à quoi pour notre part
nous
aspirons la viis est défavorable pour le
rapporteur mais pour le
ministres non juste dire à Monsieur
Lucas que comme lui je
je je suis scandalisé par la
manifestation à Paris je voudrais quand
même rappeler parce que vous ne l'a pas
fait que le préfet de police sur mon
instruction l'avait interdite et que la
justice l'a autorisé et je respecte nous
respectons de justice mais il aurait été
il aurait été assez honnête de
d'expliquer que le gouvernement est
évidemment défavorable à cette
manifestation d'ultra
droite
bien
TR bien bon alors l'amendement de
Monsieur tacher le 1453 qui vote pour
contre il est rejeté on va voter deavant
la loi dans son intégralité donc je
demande un peu de concentration hein je
vais l'appeler une première fois
alors sur l'ensemble de la loi pour
contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration qui vote
pour bien la m il y a 21 membres du
groupe Renaissance ils sont tous
présents il y a 6 membres du groupe
démocrate ils sont tous présents il y a
quatre membres du groupe horizon ils
sont tous présents il y a trois membres
du groupot ils sont tous présents je
compte 34 voix
pour monsieur camardine vous votez pour
également donc 35 voix pour
ensuite qui vote contre la loi il y a
trois membres du groupe rassemblement
national il y a un membre du groupe les
républicains il y a SEP membres du
groupe la France insoumise il y a trois
membres du groupe les écologistes il y a
un membre du groupe socialiste il y a un
membre du groupe GDR il y a donc 16 vois
contre la loi est adoptée par la
[Applaudissements]
Commission